[Musique]
Olivier Dubois, bonsoir.
Bonsoir.
Nous vous recevons pour une chaîne
internet qui s'appelle Syerview. Nous
sommes en direct. Est-ce que vous pouvez
vous présenter succintement ? Oui.
Alors, je m'appelle Olivier Dubois, je
suis je suis journaliste. J'ai commencé
par des sujets de société. Ensuite, j'ai
été en Afrique. Je suis resté 8 ans au
Mali et pendant cette période là, j'ai
travaillé pour un hebdomadaire local et
puis après, j'ai été correspondant pour
des médias français. Et j'ai une petite
particularité, c'est que les deux
dernières années, j'ai été kidnappé au
mains d'Alqedaïda pendant 700 son jours,
c'est-à-dire quasiment 2 ans.
Ça a dû être joyeux, ça a dû être
gratiné. Non,
je dirais pas ça comme ça. Je dirais pas
ça comme ça.
L'assurance mondiale, l'assurance
rapatriante, ça s'est bien passé ?
Non, j'avais oublié de l'apprendre.
Ah,
on rentre directement dans le sujet.
Alors,
alors OK.
Euh
séquestrer, enlever euh comment ça se
passe quand on est journaliste ? fait
d'abord le périmètre extérieur. Euh, il
y a une assurance, il y a un médiateur
dans l'assurance, il y a un négociateur
dans l'assurance, il y a un fond
d'indemnisation des des journalistes le
temps que ça dure. Comment ça se passe ?
Bah, il y a rien de tout ça. Moi,
j'étais un indépendant, j'étais un
pigiste. Alors, on est seul, on au
niveau de voilà, c'est c'est pas c'est
pas quelque chose où on est baqué, on a
pas une rédaction derrière nous. Et il
se trouve que sur ces sujets,
c'est-à-dire interviewer un chef
dijihadiste, euh j'avais eu un refus de
ma rédaction, de mes rédactions même à
l'époque. Donc c'est quelque chose que
j'ai fait totalement en autonome, en
indépendant, quoi.
Et le papier, vous comptiez le vendre
combien ?
Bah j'avais pas j'avais pas vraiment
d'idée, mais le vendre le vendre un bon
prix et pas forcément pour des journaux
français puisque j'avais pas
leutorisation. Alors, je pensais
peut-être à d'autres médias, des choses
comme ça, mais j'avais pas vraiment
pensé. L'idée c'était plus de ramener
cette interview, c'était déjà l'exploit
et puis après on verrait
combien ça vaut ce genre de papier.
Bah tout dépend qui quelle était la
cible
qui était la cible. Alors un chef
djihadiste Abd Abdouahbaka qui était un
chef du gennim qui était qui est
toujours un chef du gnim et qui était
dans le nord et qui était quelqu'un qui
était la la tête de pont le fer de lance
des combats qu'il y avait entre Al-Qaïda
à l'époque et puis l'État islamique au
combien ça vaut ça ? Alors au prix, je
peux pas vous dire euh j'ai même pas je
crois pas de souvenir avoir pensé à une
somme en me disant mais tiens celui-là
j'en tirerai tant et tout. J'ai pas
vraiment pensé en fait.
L'idée c'est déjà de le faire le le
premier.
Mais votre femme elle fait quelle tête
quand vous lui annoncez le sujet ?
Alors euh elle me connaît un peu. C'est
pas la première fois que je fais des
reportages en dehors de Bamaco de ce
style. Enfin de ce style plutôt plutôt
dangereux. Elle me connaît, elle sait
elle sait voilà, elle sait que c'est
vendu avec. Donc elle évidemment elle me
elle est un peu inquiète mais elle me
laisse faire.
Je parlais euh en faisant une bouteille
d'assurance rapatriment et des choses
comme ça. Euh normalement euh quand il y
a une salle de rédaction derrière vous,
il y a une petite assurance, il y a un
négociateur qui est dans le coin. Bon ça
ça a été balayé d'un verre de la main.
Vous avez prévenu quand même le quiet
d'orsc ? Vous allez faire des bêtises ou
pas ? Alors c'est c'est moi d'habitude
quand je faisais ça, je ne prévenais
personne et il se trouve que quelques
mois avant, j'avais fait un reportage,
j'étais embarqué dans une milice d'Agon
qui s'appelle Dambassagou dans le centre
du Bali et en revenant l'ambassade
m'avait appelé, m'avait dit : "Écoute,
très bien, tu fais tes choses à toi,
mais la prochaine fois que tu fais
quelque chose comme ça, on aimerait au
moins être au courant." Et et cette
fois-ci, je me suis décidé avant de
partir donc à Gao pour cette interview
les appeler. Donc juste un appel, en fin
d'après-midi, je me souviens la veille
pour leur dire "Écoutez, je pars mais tu
es avec une ONG ? Non, je suis tout seul
mais on te déconseille de le faire.
J'écoute et puis je je l'ai pas fait
parce que évidemment que à l'époque
quand on sort de Bamo, on déconseille à
tout journaliste de le faire. Donc c'est
c'est quelque chose d'habituel et en
même temps voilà.
Avant de rentrer dans le détail de
comment, pourquoi par qui et et ainsi de
suite et l'expérience sur place et
l'after et peut-être le
rentrer dans le détail.
Le qued d'orsais dans ces cas-là euh ils
vous déconseillent, ils vous
interdisent, ils préviennent nos copains
qui sont dans le coin histoire qu'ils
gardent un œil sur vous. Ils ont
suffisamment de renseignement sur ce que
ils vous demandent des faveurs, pas de
faveur, des choses comme ça.
Bah je sais pas, moi j'ai eu que qu'un
fonctionnaire de l'ambassade
qui a appelé en numéro privé ou en
numéro.
Alors, j'imagine que quand il sait que
je je veux faire ce projet, que je vais
partir le lendemain, il prévient qu'il
doit prévenir. Mais je sais pas comment
ça se passe. Enfin, je sais un peu
comment ça se passe de la part du MA
parce que le lendemain matin,
Ministère des affaires étrangères,
voilà, le lendemain matin, quand je
serai dans l'avion, je reçois un mail
que je ne peux pas lire, je suis dans
l'avion me déconseillant formellement
d'y aller. Mais mais j'imagine oui
qu'ils ont sonné, ils ont tiré les
sonnettes d'alarme et à Bamako et à Gao,
sachant que j'allais partir là-bas le
lendemain.
Quand on se retrouve euh je vais vous
demander en fait de nous décrire comment
ça s'est passé les premiers instants.
Les premiers instants. Euh comment ça
s'est passé ?
Alors les premers il y a plusieurs
premiers instants. Quand j'arrive à Gao
ou quand j'arrive à Gao, j'arrive en fin
de matinée. Il fait très chaud, je me
souviens. Mon mon fixeur est là. Euh
un fixeur, c'est le local qui connaît
les gens.
C'est l'intermédiaire indispensable
quand on va dans une zone qu'on ne
connaît pas et qu'on doit frayer avec
des gens qu'on ne connaît pas et qui
sont plutôt dangereux. C'est celui qui
organise tout et qui qui rend la chose
possible si vous voulez. Euh alors non,
je l'avais pas, il y avait pas d'argent,
je l'avais pas payé, il y avait rien.
C'est quelqu'un qui travaille depuis un
certain temps, mais c'est lui qui a tout
organisé.
Il travaille gratuit, il fait quoi ?
Euh dans mon cas, en tout cas, je le
payais pas. C'est pas quelqu'un que je
payais. C'était c'était un comptax. On
avait une sorte de modus. Je l'ai pas
payé pour pour ce cette interview là.
Vous l'avez criblé le fixeur un peu
avant ou pas ?
Ah b, on se connait depuis un moment.
Euh on a on avait traversé pas mal de
choses. C'était limite un ami, je
connaissais bien et donc voilà. Donc
c'est lui qui me récupère quand j'arrive
à Gao. On est en fin de matinée. La
première des choses qu'on fait, c'est
aller à l'hôtel. Je dis pose mes
affaires, je dois me préparer encore
là-bas. Je suis vraiment dans dans mon
interview hein. Je suis déjà vraiment
dedans. Je suis vraiment sur mes
questions. On mange ensemble. Alors, je
sais pas si je rentre dans les détails
mais déjà il y a un premier un premier
je dirais coup de théâtre, un premier
rebondissement, c'est qu'il me il me dit
"Écoute Olivier devait venir avec moi,
c'est lui qui devait assurer la la
traduction. Il me dit "Écoute Olivier,
je ne viens pas." Ils m'ont appelé, ils
m'ont dit que je je ne viens pas. Donc
là, évidemment, ça met un arrêt tout de
suite. Je sais pas si on doit continuer.
On avait prévu des des filets de
sécurité. Si je le sentais pas ou s'il y
avait un problème, je pouvais l'idée
c'était de m'amener au camp des des
forces maliennes. Et je me pose la
question, on est si près du but en même
temps et et il vient pas. Donc je sais
pas comment la traduction va être
assurée. Me rassure. Me dit bah écoute
c'est eux qui qui ont prévu le coup.
Mais mais voilà
parlait pas le le langage par pas je
parle je parle pas Bambara, je parle pas
arabe, je parle pas de Tamchèc, je parle
français et je me débrouille en anglais
et euh et donc oui là là il y a une
vraie enfin il y a un vrai moment
d'arrêt et puis je me dis voilà c'est
lui qui a tout organisé. Je dis est-ce
que je peux voilà qu'est-ce que tu en
penses toi ? On arrête on continue et il
me dit écoute je pense qu'on peut y
aller. Il me donne des arguments qui
pour moi tiennent la route à ce
moment-là.
Le premier des arguments, c'est qu'il
doit voir la personne que je dois
interviewer, ce chef djihadiste après
l'interview parce que ce chef
dijihadiste me dit-il est diabétique et
de lui faire sa piqûe. Et puis ensuite,
il me rassure en me disant mais écoute,
tu sais toutes les portes qui sortent de
Gao sont gardées par des militaires. Ça
m'étonnerait qu'il te kidnappe comme ça
et qu' te Ça me suffit en tout cas. Et
on on continue.
Et vous l'avez coulé dans le béton
depuis ou pas ?
Non, j'ai rien fait. J'ai rien fait.
Mais c'est pas l'envie qui en manquait ?
Non. Non. Il y a pas de de volonté
agressive de le couler dans le béton
quoi. Mais par contre de d'avoir des
réponses à mes nombreuses questions.
Ouais. Mais
faut commencer, il faut il faut le
couler mais jusqu'au genou.
Ouais. Alors c'est
et à partir du genou, on pose des
questions.
Ouais. Ça ça permet au moins d'avoir des
réponses. C'est clair.
Ça permet qu'il partent pas. Il partent
pas.
Moi je sais pas mais en tout cas j'ai
des tas de questions. J'ai plus de
rancune, c'est fait. J'ai eu le temps
d'y penser quand j'étais là-bas mais par
contre j'ai le droit d'avoir des
réponses à mes questions. Ouais
il habite toujours sur place. Alors, aux
dernières nouvelles, il est toujours sur
place, il est toujours au Mali. J'ai pas
trop de nouvelles, mais aux dernières
nouvelles que j'ai eu, il était toujours
à Gao, toujours au Mali.
On a des copains là-bas si vous voulez,
on peut lui poser des questions. Il
travaille dans
Vous avez des copains là-bas ?
Revenons, revenons à notre sujet. Donc,
on se retrouve dans un 44. Il y a pas le
traducteur.
Alors oui, donc OK, là on a fait un bon
mais oui, on se je me retrouve dans dans
un pickup trois jihad de derrière, je me
souviens, je suis à côté donc je suis en
passager, il y a un conducteur et puis
on quitte Gao et on on quitte Gaoo à
toute berzingue, à toute allure et on
sort de Gao rapidement et il y a un
événement moi que je note qu'on
m'expliquera après, c'est quand on sort
de Gao, on est croisé par un pickup qui
est exactement comme le nôtre. Les gens
à l'intérieur sont exactement comme le
conducteur. Enfin, ils sont en toir
quoi.
Hux
V6 Toyota couleur crème et et j'ai
l'impression que les gars quand on les
croise, ils nous voient, ils sont
surpris quoi. Euh voilà, j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont surpris mais
moi j'y prends pas garde, je suis à fond
sur mes questions et on m'apprendra
quelques jours plus tard donc après
après que j'ai été kidnappé que c'était
un groupe de l'État islamique me
disent-ils qui nous ont pris en chasse
et qu'il y aurait même eu des coups de
feu. Et j'étais totalement, enfin moi
j'étais totalement dans mes questions.
Je n'ai rien entendu. Par contre, j'ai
senti le coup d'accélération dès qu'ils
nous ont pris en chasse, ça. Oui.
Après,
alors après donc euh moi je suis dans
mes questions, mais c'est vrai qu'on
roule, on roule et la fenêtre que j'ai
avec ce chef Di 45 minutes hein. Ça
devait être dans Gao, on est déjà à
l'extérieur de Gao. Et et je devais
rentrer, on avait on avait convenu ça
avec mon fixeur 2h plus tard. Donc le
temps passe, on roule. même si je suis
dans mes questions, je commence un petit
peu à m'inquiéter par rapport au à
l'heure quoi qui file. Et je me tourne
vers mon le le conducteur, je dis "Mais
écoute, excuse-moi, mais euh moi si mon
fixeur n'a pas de mes nouvelles dans 2
heures, il sait quoi faire et ce qu'il
doit faire prévenir les forces
internationales, prévenir ma famille,
enfin voilà." Et il a pas l'air d'être
inquiet. Il me fait signe que après
et moi en même temps, même si je sens
monter quand même une sorte d'angoisse
un peu sourde, je me dis "Bon, c'est des
jihadis, ils vont pas être là où on les
attend. C'est le rendez-vous état, je
sais pas. 16h et ben ils me receverront
ce soir, il me ramèneront demain matin.
Voilà pour leur sécurité, pour la
mienne. Enfin bon, je m'explique ça
comme ça. On roule à toute allure
pendant encore quelques heures et au
bout au bout d'un moment, on s'arrête,
on s'arrête, il y a quelqu'un qui qui
ouvre la portière, qui me bande les
yeux, on me sort du véhicule, on me
déshabille, on me met dans un autre
véhicule, donc on me met un chèche. On
met une autre tenue Tourag que j'avais
déjà parce que je devais avoir une tenue
Tourarg, c'était le préalable pour aller
les voir. On m'enmène une seconde, on me
fait monter dans un second véhicule et
quand je monte dans ce véhicule, le
conducteur qui s'assoit à côté de moi,
il y a un passager, il a un second donc
ahad dit j'imagine que ça soit à côté de
moi, il me dit écoute, c'est là où il
m'apprend que je suis kidnappé.
En français, en anglais, en arabe, en
commun,
en français. En français, les deux
parlent français. Euh
parle français,
il parle français bien,
genre de chez nous.
Ah oui oui. Non, il parle français bien.
Il parlent français très bien. Et il me
font comprendre qu'il me détiennent que
je suis captif et que c'est maintenant
une ma situation est entre les mains de
ma famille et de mon gouvernement.
Et euh et puis là, bon bah là ça là
c'est c'est le c'est le choc quoi. C'est
le choc. On
passe par quel état ?
On passe déjà il faut faut faire face à
la nouvelle
en sachant qu'on est les yeux bandés et
ainsi de suite.
Ouais ouais je suis les yeux bandés, je
suis encadré et on part directement.
J'ai je je j'ai j'ai des liens au au
poignet. On il y a il y a un choc
d'abord on réalise pas quoi. Moi je bon
pour pour en résumer un petit peu euh on
a on a 2 mois 3 mois de d'aller-retour
de messages avec eux via mon fixeur.
J'ai réussi à avoir un sauvecit euh un
laisser passer qui me permet d'être
amené là-bas et de revenir. Donc c'est
le choc c'estd tamponner pas tamponner.
Non non. Alors il y a pas de tampon et
puis il y a pas de document type, on
connaît pas ça quoi. Mais on sait que
quand on va aller voir ces gens-là, vous
avoir ce type de papier, il faut se
faire délivrer ce papier là que
normalement c'est une garantie sur leurs
paroles de de vous ramener en sécurité.
Et c'est pas ce qui se passe. Je suis
kidnappé, j'ai l'impression d'être d'y
être allé les les les bras les bras en
avant quoi. Mettre totalement engouffré
là-dedans. Donc il faut réaliser ça.
Puis tout de suite il y a une peur qui
qui arrive quand même qui qui est très
rapide. C'est savoir qui vous détient.
Qui vous détient ? On est dans une zone
où ça peut être Al-Qaïa, ça peut être
l'État islamique. Moi, j'ai bibonné
enfin par mon métier par parce que je
couvre ces groupes là de vidéos de de
films de propagande et de vidéos où on
voit des exactions, des choses très très
violentes, des assassinats à l'écran et
euh et j'ai tout de suite peur. Je me
dis si c'est l'État islamique, je suis
pas sûr d'être vivant le soir dans dans
les heures qui vont suivre quoi. Donc
c'est c'est ça que je ressens tout de
suite. Et il y a il y a énormément de
choses. Vous êtes bombardé de de de
penser. On pense à sa famille, on pense
à ses parents, on pense à ce qu'on vient
de faire. On sait pas et puis on sait
pas de quoi la minute l'heure d'après va
être faite.
Tu es pas du genre à te faire des
blagues pour te détendre ? Genre c'est
surprise surprise.
Ouais. Non là il y a pas de blague. Il y
a pas de blague. Et puis incapacité à me
détendre c'est impossible. Enfin je veux
dire je sais pas on sait pas où on va.
Donc qu'est-ce qui est passé par la tête
? C'est dès qu'ils vont m'enlever le le
bandeau, ils vont m'enlever les liens.
Je vais en désarmer trois, je vais en
buter trois, je avec le 44.
Euh la cavalerie va arriver.
Non, j'aurais l'occasion de fantasmer
beaucoup sur ce genre de truc.
C'est-à-dire parce qu'il y aura des
occasions, il y aura il y aura des armes
qui traînent, il y aura des brèches, il
y aura des moments, il y aura des
failles. Mais euh mais il y a toujours
cette question d'ce que ça marche quoi
dans un film ? Ça semble clair. Une
rafale, tout le monde tout le monde
tombe quoi dans laé.
Tu as une formation aux armes ?
Non, je fais des arts martiaux. J'ai
fait
alors j'ai fait de la boxe, j'ai fait du
judo et là je pratiquais le bagoisan qui
un sport interne chinois à l'époque.
Mais mais enfin ça ça dans tous les cas,
c'est pas voilà, c'est pas suffisant.
Enfin, faut fautincre sa peur
aux armes pan. Non, jamais. J'ai jamais
touché une arme.
Service service militaire, vous avez été
quel âge ?
Non non, j'ai été réformé.
Réformé quoi ? P4.
Non non non.
C'était une période un peu transitoire.
Vous avez plus trop besoin. C'était un
an avant que ça s'arrête. Peut-être
82.
Donc j'avais un problème de vision et
d'audition. C'est que j'ai bluffé un peu
l'audition mais ils m'ont pas retenu
quoi. Et c'était cool. Ça m'allait.
Donc euh ouais donc non, on pense pas du
tout à ça. Enfin à ce moment-là en tout
cas, je pense pas du tout à ça. Je sais
moi, c'est surtout ce qui va arriver
après.
Et la question parce qu'on a tous vu le
film Teken, la gamine qui est au
téléphone et qui dit il y a son père au
téléphone et le père lui dit compte
combien de distance si tu vois des
bruits pas des bruits sur le chemin pour
pouvoir te repérer. C'est passé par la
tête ça naturellement. Après ça viendra
après.
Là vraiment c'est la terreur, c'est la
surprise, le choc, la terreur et puis
les conséquences. commence à avoir une
pensée sur les conséquences que ça va
avoir. C'estàd la famille, je verrai
plus mes enfants, je rentre pas ce soir
et puis on rentre dans un truc dans une
inconnue. Puis moi j'ai travaillé sur
les otages, donc je sais ce que ça
implique. Euh c'est-à-dire que le mon
gouvernement va être mis dans la chaîne,
ma famille va être prévenue. Le 10 2
jours après, je devais prendre un avion,
c un samedi, le samedi 10 de mémoire
pour rentrer sur Bamaco.
Je sais que je serai pas dans cet avion.
C'est ça en fait qui qui me traverse.
C'est ça qui me qui me bombarde à ce
moment-là.
première nuit,
ça je m'en souviendrai toujours de cette
première nuit. Euh alors d'abord donc on
m'amène en voiture, on m'amène dans un
lieu où il y a plein de gens, ça sent la
bouffe, ils vont ils vont étranger
toujours les yeux bandés.
Euh oui, j'ai les yeux bandés. Sauf là,
on m'enlève mon bandon, mais sur un
tapis, moi je me souviens qui m'a
marqué. Le truc qui m'a marqué, c'est
bête mais c'est les bousses de vache,
les crottes de chèvre qu'il y avait tout
autour de moi. C'était sale. C'était
j'osais pas avancer. La nuit commença à
tomber. Il y a plein de gens, ils ont
fait à bouffer. J'ai rien pu avaler et
il y en a certains qui ont essayé de me
rassurer mais euh mais bon je enfin
j'avais l'impression d'être sourd en
fait et d'avoir plein de gens qui me qui
me parlaient autour euh
parce que parce que pas de maîtrise de
la langue parce que
non parce que on est dans un sorte de de
de de combat intérieur quoi. On on doit
on réalise pas enfin on doit réaliser on
réalise pas et puis on sait c'est
toujours cet inconnu. On sait pas ce qui
va se passer. C'est des tas de gens
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire une heure
après ? Ils vont vous prendre, vous
mettre à genou, vous tirer une balle
dans la tête, vous savez pas. Donc on
est on est vraiment à l'intérieur. On se
on a j'arrivais pas à écouter ce qu'on
me disait. J'arrivais pas.
Et euh ça a duré, je crois, on est resté
1 heure, quelque chose comme ça dans ce
en plein désert là comme ça. Puis on me
met sur une moto, on file dans la nuit.
Je me souviens de la voûte étoilée.
Alors là, je vois plein d'étoiles. C'est
à la fois magnifique et terrible parce
que j'ai fait un papier avant. J'ai
travaillé sur un sujet avant sur les
drones et il y a eu on sort de Bunti, il
y a eu la bavure française de l'armée
française de la force barcan qui est
présente sur le terrain à Bunki et euh
voilà, je me dis on est seul dans la
nuit, je suis avec des djihadistes, il y
a peut-être un drone qui est en train de
nous suivre, j'ai peut-être une cible,
il y a peut-être une cible sur cette
moto. Et je peut-être il passer
connement, enfin je veux dire bêtement
comme ça. On roule 10 minutes, ils
mettent, on s'arrête, il traînent une
chaîne en métal autour d'un petit arbre,
enfin d'un arbre assez solide mais
petit. Je me souviens, ils mettent une
natte et puis se mettent à 60 70 m de
mois et puis on me laisse comme ça. J'ai
pas de couverture, j'ai rien dans la
nuit, il y a plein de bruit, je sais pas
ce qui va se passer. Je dors pas cette
nuit-là, je dors pas du tout.
Pas de papier toilette.
J'ai même pas pensé à pisser ou chier du
tout. C'est marrant. C'est alors pour le
coup Ouais. Non non non.
et et je redoute le lendemain matin. La
rigueur la nuit c'est comme même si je
j'ai peur des bruits, j'ai peur de cette
nuit que je connais pas, je suis pas
dans ma chambre, je suis dans rien.
Qu'est-ce qui va se passer demain matin
? Ils vont voilà, qu'est-ce qui va se
passer ? Qu'est-ce qui m'attend le long
de ma matin ? Et ça ça m'empêche de
dormir ça. Les bruits dans la nuit, tout
ça m'empêche de dormir.
Quel type de bruit ?
Bah vous avez le vent dans les arbres,
vous avez pu ça rampe, il y a il y a
c'est le désert hein, il y a une vie, il
y a une voyez, il a des insectes, il y a
plein de choses. Euh puis il y a eux
aussi qui sont là. Euh euh voilà, il il
y a tout ce cet environnement que je
connais pas quoi et que je je ressens
comme ça, que je prends brutalement. Euh
enfin, c'est impossible de dormir.
C'était impossible de dormir ce soir là.
Lendemain matin,
bah le lendemain matin, moi je je me
réveille pas, je suis réveillé. Euh eux,
ils se lèvent tranquillement. Ils font
le thé euh et puis je sais pas
font la prière.
Oui, ils font la prière aussi. Et puis
je sais pas de temps après, il y a un
pickup qui arrive avec deux autres. Je
me souviens des yeux rougis, moi. C'est
ça. Parce que faut faut bien imaginer
que les gens que j'ai autour de moi se
découvrent très peu le visage. Donc vous
avez une fenêtre comme ça de tissu, vous
avez des yeux rougis parce que quand on
roule dans le désert, vous avez l'air
qui vous arrive, ça vous rougit les
yeux. Mais c'est impressionnant. Vous
vous dites pas ils sont rougis par le
vent du désert parce qu'ils roulent.
Vous dites parce qu'ils sont voilà, il y
a de la haine, ils sont injectés de
sang, ils vous en veulent quoi. Et je me
souviens de ça, c'est un truc qui
m'avait marqué, enfin qui a renforcé ma
peur et ma terreur à ce moment là. Et
puis vous êtes un automate, vous bougez.
Quand on vous dit de bouger, vous vous
assz là, on vous dit de vous asseoir et
vous essayez de guetter, d'anticiper le
prochain mouvement parce que vous avez
l'impression que ce prochain mouvement,
il va vous mener au trépas. C'est que ça
en fait, c'est la période de terreur.
Moi je dis les trois premiers jours, tr
qu premiers jours de ma captivité, c'est
la période de terreur, hein. Je voilà,
je suis pas je suis pas à l'aise. Je
sais pas comment me comporter, je sais
pas quoi dire. Euh je je suis pas bien.
Je suis pas bien du tout.
Là, on fait quoi ? On fait sa prière.
Alors moi je prie pas, je pense pas à
prier.
Pas d'amis imaginaire.
Non. Euh on est il y a juste je crois
c'est à partir du 3e jour, il y a un ral
de cet état-là et puis on s'habitue à
tout hein aussi 3 jours, on commence à
s'habituer quand même. On a passé la 3è
nuit, on commence à ils ont le même
fonctionnement
et et là je me dis c'est pas possible je
bon je sais pas ce qui se passe. On on
déjà on se rassure aussi. Je me dis
t'inquiète pas c'est une erreur. Petite
Katyba ils savent pas ce qu'ils font.
Ils ont entendu qu'un français venait à
Gao. Tiba, ça veut dire
c'est unité jadis si vous voulez euh
autonome ou pas. Ils ont ils ont entendu
qu'un français, ils ont eu vent qu'un
français venait à Gao. Les idiots, ils
sont venus le kidnapper alors que savait
pas que j'étais en deal avec un chef et
que je devais l'interviewer, que j'avais
en plus une autorisation. Donc les
choses vont s'arranger, je vais leur en
parler, ça va aller. Ça c'est ce que je
me dis pour me rassurer. Et puis après,
je je peux pas rester dans cet état là.
Ça m'empêche de réfléchir. J'ai la tête
qui bourdonne parce que j'ai 10000
questions. Il faut se reprendre. Il faut
se reprendre. Puis on reste du temps sur
une ade. Vous faites rien quoi. Vous
attendez, vous faites rien. Et il faut
que je me reprenne. Il faut faut que ça
faut faut que j'arrive à à avoir une
impulsion et ça va être le sport d'abord
parce que j'ai du temps et je me dis de
Dieu hors de question qu'on me crache
dessus, qu'on me frappe ou si ça arrive,
faut que je puisse répondre, que je
parte avec pas, je sais pas. Mais voilà
et je me dis je vais faire du sport.
Moi, je fais du bagou chez les arts
martiaux, mais j'ai arrêté depuis un
moment. Je suis dans une vie un peu
confortable, j'ai pris du poids vraiment
et et je me dis là, il y a du temps, il
y a des heures euh voilà, je vais faire
du sport. Et quand il me voi commencer à
pratiquer la première fois, je dois
prétexter que j'ai mal au genoux, euh
que j'en ai besoin pour ma santé et
cetera. Il laisse passer et ça va
devenir une sorte de routine euh à
partir du 4e 5e jour, faire du sport
tous les matins. Et je me rends compte
queeux n'en font pas. Eux, ils font pas
sport du tout. Ça m'étonne. Moi, je je
suis resté un petit peu sur les camps
d'entraînement comme on voyait en
Afghanistan. Voyez, les mecs, ils font
des trucs dingues, paramilitaire et tout
et ceux-là non, ils se lèvent, ils sont
plutôt ls, levés. Bon, c'est des jeunes
hein
qui m'encadent en 24, je dirais. Ouais.
Entre 18, le plus vieux à la trentaine,
début de la trentaine à Bouillousouf. Et
je peux tout couper le c'est quel profil
mis à part que ce soit 24 25 ans ? C'est
du blédard local, c'est du blédard de
chez nous, c'est du blédard de
c'est des toeg, c'est des gens du cru de
la région de Kidal. Euh, ils sont ils
sont cornaqués par un chef qui lui est
plus âgé. Il me dira plus tard qu'il a
connu les prisons maliennes, qui faisait
partie des des dijihadistes qui ont été
délivrés lorsqu'il y avait eu la la
transaction avec Sophie Pétrona et
Sommet la Sissé. Il faisait partie de
ces djihades là. Euh et c'est lui, c'est
lui le chef quoi. Mais sinon c'est des
c'est des jeunes qui entre 18 et 24 ans
et c'est des des des des toeg du coin.
Ils ont arrêté l'école, ils ont jamais
été à l'école. C'est c'est des bergers
quoi.
Alors ça je l'apprendrai plus tard. Il y
a différents profils mais en gros oui,
il y a pas eu d'école où il y a eu
l'école du désert, l'école sous les
arbres. C'est c'est des médras hein,
c'est des c'est des écoles coraniques.
C'est du cours qui est dispensé comme ça
par un imam sous les arbres. Et je me
rends compte très vite que le Coran,
c'est euh c'est ça hein, c'est leur
éducation. Ils ont appris à lire, à
écrire avec le Coran et surtout ils
croient, enfin, ils sont vraiment dans
le Coran quoi. Moi, je suis vu comme un
infidèle, quelqu'un qui vient de de
voilà un coufard, un infidèle. Donc
c'est comme ça qu'il m'appelle. Et donc
je suis comme le Coran me décrit. Euh
c'est comme ça qu'il me considère au
départ.
Tu décrit comment ?
Bah je suis quelqu'un qui suis, je suis
un aposta. Je suis quelqu'un qui associe
d'autres déités à Dieu. Je suis
quelqu'un qui on ne peut pas faire
confiance, qui veulent Je suis quelqu'un
qui est pas dans le droit chemin parce
que je ne crois pas en Allah et c'est un
gros gros problème. C'est le problème
que j'ai. C'est un problème pour eux.
Ils ont essayé de te convertir ?
Pas tout de suite, ça va venir plus
lentement. Ça m'en a des discussions. Je
reviens un petit peu pour qu'on
comprenne un peu cette transition. 3 4
jours, il faut plus que la terreur, faut
faut que je trouve un un palliatif,
quelque chose pour parer la la terreur.
Ça va être le sport et au bout d'un
moment, il va y avoir un second truc qui
va venir, c'est me dire il faut faut que
je change le le ce que ma façon de
percevoir la situation. Ça c'est très
important. Et alors pour être un peu
clair, non seulement il faut que je
change ma façon de percevoir la
situation et en même temps il y a une
sorte de rancune qui monte en moi parce
que j'ai l'impression d'avoir été trahi
quand même
pour le fixeur.
Euh non non, je parle alors justement je
pense pas du tout à mon fixeur. Mon
fixeur il a rien fait pour moi pour le
moment. Je travaill par eux. J'ai un
sauvecit. Euh ils doivent me rab en
sécurité. Ils en profitent pour me
kidnapper. OK, je suis l'idiot du
village, je suis le con du game parce
que je m'engouffre dans le truc. Mais en
même temps, ils respectent pas leurs
paroles. Donc ça ça fait monter une
sorte de ouais de sentiment d'injustice,
de rencœur, quoi. Et donc je me dis il
faut que je change de perception, je
travaille sur ces sujets-là. Euh OK, je
suis au boulot, OK, le l'interview
continue. Euh voilà, je continue à faire
mon travail et donc tous les matins, je
me lève avec cette idée-là. Mais pour
faire son travail, il faut avoir un but
quoi. Et moi, il y a énormément de
questions que j'ai généré, enfin que
j'ai j'ai engrangé depuis que je
travaille sur ces sur ces groupes-là et
que je meurs d'envie de leur poser. Donc
en gros, c'est leur poser des questions,
essayer d'avoir même des choses. Alors,
je sais pas, par exemple, je je pense là
maintenant à un chef djihadiste euh qui
s'est fait euh qui s'est fait tuer en
2016 qui s'appelle Cheragaousa en
sortant d'un cas d'Ainusma. Bon ben, je
veux savoir qui l'a tué. Il y a
énormément de rumeurs là-dessus. Je suis
pas sûr d'avoir de réponse. Je sais pas
comment outrepasser la barrière de la
langue mais ça donne un but. et des but
comme ça, je vais m'en fixer l'état.
Donc le sport, continuer à investiguer,
observer,
voilà pour s'occuper et puis après petit
à petit aussi se mettre peut-être parce
que c'est nourri par la colère, se dire
"Tu n'as rien fait, c'est eux qui ont
besoin de toi, c'est pas toi qui a
besoin d'eux, tu n'es pas en faute, ne
t'incrimine pas, ne te culpabilise pas."
Donc l'idée c'est d'inverser d'inverser
la vapeur et petit à petit, bon malin,
je vais y arriver.
Donc le profil des
joliers 24 25 ans, l'école de sous les
arbres, sous les acacias, leur leur mode
de communication c'est quoi ? C'est
sûrement pas téléphone satellite.
Non,
c'est quoi ? C'est la
téléphone satellite, il y en aura. Ça
viendra plus tard. Et c'est euh j'en ai
vu dans les mains des chefs hein des des
supérieurs. Eux ils ont des téléphones,
ils sont tous en mode avion hein. On a
interdiction sur le camp d'activer enfin
d'enlever le mode avion et c'est de la
radio. C'est beaucoup de radios radio
Motorola, des radios de marque chinoise.
Il ils communiquent qu'avec des radios
des Toky Walky.
Chiffré ou pas chiffré les Toky ?
Je ne sais pas mais s'inquiète pas trop.
Moi moi ça m'a quelque chose qui
m'étonnait. Je dis mais attends toutes
ces conversations Toky Wolk il les
utilisent et qu'ils savent que c'est
sécurisé. Enfin sécurisé dans le sens on
peut pas les on peut pas les capter.
Et euh enfin, ils avaient l'air très sûr
de leur moyens de communication. Puis
tout, ils ont toute une sorte de relais.
Tout ça est très organisé. Tout est
centralisé dans ce qu'ils appelle un
Rizou qui est un peu le le chef
messager, celui qui dispense en même
temps les informations. Puis ils ont des
relais comme ça. Apparemment, ça peut
embrasser 80 km 80 à 100 km où une
information peut voyager très très vite.
3è jour.
3è jour. Donc c'est ce que je disais, je
commence à reprendre du poil de la bête
avec le sport et en me arrivant à me
convaincre qu'il faut que je change
d'état d'esprit. Pardon, faut que je
change d'état d'esprit. Faut pas que je
je me considère comme un otage
journaliste, mais un journaliste qui est
otage ou un journaliste qui fait son
boulot.
Nous, moi je vais ouvrir une parenthèse.
Nous, on avait vu que tu étais abonné à
notre compte Twitter.
Et comment vous avez fait pour voir ça ?
Parce que je
Bah, quand tu es abonné sur notre compte
Twitter, il y a marqué "Vous".
Oui. Oui. Mais j'ai pas de compte Marqué
Olivier du bois.
Si si si. Olivier du bois je te montre
c'est comme ça que je t'ai contacté au
fait hein. C'était peut-être pas toi.
Et donc on voit Olivier Dubois vous suit
et là on se dit merde il y a un membre
de la communauté qui est dans le dans le
caca.
J'ai toujours aimé votre émission
et donc le le nous on a essayé de mettre
un peu la pression au qui est d'ors pour
qu'il s'intéresse toujours à à ton
dossier. Du moin qu'il te laisse pas
tomber.
continue les gamins, le mode
organisationnel, ils te font bouger
souvent, c'est tous les combien de temps
? Il y a d'autres personnes, tu es tout
seul, tu es en première classe, pas en
première classe.
Euh alors, il y a il y a
Tu manges, comment ça se passe ? Comment
voilà, c'est la découverte, c'est la
découverte de la captivité de comment on
vit dans le désert. Alors bon, je dors
sur le sol, je expliqué. J'ai pas de
couverture, j'ai une natte, je mange
comme eux. Donc les premiers temps,
c'est une chèvre qui vient, elle est
zigouillée, il la dépaisse, on mange de
la viande. Je me souviens d'un j'ai les
souvenirs d'un c'était c assez primal
comme truc. Donc le la viande est
dépaissée, ils mettent tout ça dans une
cocotte, du sel, de l'huile. Allez,
peut-être qu'il y avait un peu d'ariss
dedans. Vous fermez la cocotte, vous
laissez cuire, puis vous avez de la
viande qui est bouillie, quoi. Puis tout
ça dans un grand plat en métal. Tous les
djihadistes sont là. Je suis autorisé à
manger avec les jihadistes et on fait
bien comprendre, on fait bien comprendre
que que c'est pas normal. Ils ont
l'impression de manger comme avec un
chien. C'est comme dira, on t'accepte
mais on a l'impression de manger comme
un chien et je dois vraiment manger dans
la portion qui m'est qui m'est donné
quoi. Et et puis et puis on est là et
puis on mange cette viande. C'est que de
la viande quoi. Je me souviens, ça
m'avait marqué ce truc là. Je sais pas.
très primal, très très carnacie, très un
truc très donc de la viande fraîche les
premiers jours, après on sèche cette
viande parce que sinon elle pourrit, on
est dans le désert, on l'ouvre comme on
dit, on la on les file quoi, on la fait
tenir sur le bout de sur le gras et puis
on la met sur des branches, elle sèche
et on peut la réactiver en la mettant
dans l'eau. Euh l'hygiène, je me lave
pas hein, moi je crois que je me suis
pas lavé avant, je suis pas lavé pour
une dizaine de jours he j'ai
l'impression. À ce moment-là, euh ils
boivent beaucoup de thé. Très vite, je
me dis le thé, c'est pas pour toi, c'est
très sucré.
Comment on dit le thé ?
Chary.
Cha
le thé est très sucré.
Chary.
Ah ouais, le thé est très sucré et il y
a un problème de diabète, on va et je me
dis tout de suite, si tu commences à tu
sais pas combien de temps ça va durer,
mais si tu commences à boire du thé
comme ça, comme ils font trois quatre
fois par jour, c'est pas bon. Et je fais
du sport par ailleurs, donc je refuse le
thé. Ce qui est c'est un peu bizarre
pour eux parce que le thé ça autour du
thé, on discute, ils viennent avec un
verre de thé, ça permet de et je refuse
ce verre de thé. Donc ça c'est un peu
comme refuser un peu refuser un peu le
contact quoi.
C'est du thé en poudre ou du thé en
feuilles ?
C'est des petits paquets de thé. C'est
du thé en feuilles mais limite comme de
la poudre hein. Le premier est très
amer, le second est un peu plus sucré
mais amer et le troisème est doux et
très sucré. Euh je crois j'en ai bu à ce
moment-là deux fois puis après
j'arrêterai. Je vois plus du tout de
thé.
Euh on vit on vit à l'extérieur queles
que soient les conditions climatiques et
euh et puis surtout on observe quoi moi
j'observe beaucoup. C'est la découverte
euh comment ils vivent, comment se passe
une journée type pour eux et je me rends
compte très vite euh qu'ils sont assez
oisfs sur le concoin en fait. Euh c'est
pas moi je m'attendais à avoir des
patrouilles, je m'attendais à avoir
quelque chose de très carré et cetera.
Non non, ça se lève gentiment 9h enfin
d'abord à 5h30 du matin, ça fait la
prière mais ça va tout de suite se
recoucher après. Moi quand j'entends la
prière, je suis au zagé, je sais pas ce
qui va se passer, je m'endors pas.
Ça fait juste la prière ou ça fait les
ablutions ? Oui, enfin quand je dis la
prière, c'est tout, c'est tout ça. On
fait pas la prière sans sans sans sans
ça, sans les ablutions. Ça va se
recoucher euh 8h30, 9h, ça émerge. Le
thé, tranquillement, ça discute hein. Le
soleil monte, ça discute. Donc il y a
pas les patrouilles, il peut y en avoir
peut-être en milieu de journée comme ça,
en fin de journée. Euh, ils veulent
garder une distance entre moi et eux.
C'est ce qu'ils me disent. C un coufard,
voilà, comme si j'étais un peu
contagieux. Ils viennent me voir quelque
fois comme ça mais je suis surveillé de
loin. Donc ça déjà c'est quelque chose
qui va assez me surprendre.
Ça parle français ou ça parle
entre machec ?
Mais quand il te parle à toi ? Alors
moi, le groupe avec qui j'étais en
premier parlait quasiment pas français,
sauf le fameux le chef qui va rester les
premiers jours avec nous, Abou Youssouf,
qui parle français puis après il part.
Et euh si il y en a un autre qui parlait
français, Farok, je me souviens un petit
jeune, il devait avoir 21 22 ans et lui
parlait français. C'est avec lui que
j'ai posé enfin c'est à lui que j'ai
posé les questions.
Il parlait français euh du coin ou il
parlait français ?
Ah non, français bien. Lui il a je me
renseigne un peu sur lui. Il a été à la
fac, il a été au Burkina, il a fait des
études. C'est quelqu'un qui est, c'est
quelqu'un qui sait écrire le français,
qui sait le parler. Il va même me poser
des questions sur les séries télévisées
qui regarde lui aussi et c'est lui qui
va devenir mon interlocuteur. C'est à
lui que j'ai posé les questions dont je
parlais. C'est avec lui que je vais
faire. je vais pouvoir accomplir un peu
mon boulot de journaliste au départ et
on
on va pas se sympathiser mais il il
comprend que je connais un peu leur leur
nébuleuse que je m'intéresse à ça et ça
lui fait évidemment aussi plaisir de
parler de ça. Donc on va pouvoir avoir
des échanges et je vais pouvoir
apprendre un peu plus qui ils sont ces
jeunes et euh
et petit à petit ça va se faire comme
ça. et moi très vite, il y a un sujet
qui va qui va je dire supplanter les
autres, c'est l'assassinat des deux
journalistes de RFI Gl du po de Verlon
parce qu'ils ont été tuésid kidnapper,
ils ont été tués malheureusement et que
je me dis si je peux comprendre pourquoi
ils ont été tués, ça peut peut-être être
une manière pour moi d'éviter que ce
destin funeste
m'arrive aussi quoi. Et et très
rapidement, il va il va s'ouvrir, enf,
il va me dire "Écoute, c'est un secret
que pour vous." Il y a une intervention
aérienne, certaines disent terrestres
mais lui dit aérienne. "Les djihadistes
ont été acculés et ils ont tué les deux
journalistes de vérifier."
Donc bon, il me dit ça et je peux donc
voilà, il y a une possibilité de parler
avec lui. En parlant avec lui, il y en a
d'autres aussi que ça intéresse qui
parlent pas la langue. Je me souviens
qu'on utilisait euh Google Translate à
l'époque quand j'avais à un moment fait
toute une soirée Google Translate et je
peux poser des questions qu'
une connexion internet.
Ah non, pas de connexion internet. Non
non. OK,
je pense on peut l'utiliser connexion,
je crois. Et on arrive à échanger un
petit peu comme ça. Je commence à à
voilà pour un peu profiler on va dire
mes gardes qui sont à cette époque là au
nombre de 4 5 5.
Toi tu es toujours tout seul ?
Je suis toujours tout seul. Je serai
seul pendant 5 mois
avec eux.
Ouais, je serai alors il y aura
différentes équipes mais je serai seul
pendant 5 mois.
Donc ça se passe comme ça, c'est les 10
premiers jours. Il y a le sport, il y a
une volonté d'en apprendre plus sur eux
et puis en même temps de d'en apprendre
plus en gros sur comment ils
fonctionnent et cetera. Rapidement les
questions vont déranger parce qu'on a un
résoud donc un informateur qui vient, il
se rend compte que je parle aux jeunes
et l'ordre leur est donné de plus me
parler. Et puis je vais avoir un
ceux qui m'ont kidnappé reviennent
aussi, je connais leur nom, c'est Mossa
pour celui qui conduisait qui m'a appris
que j'étais j'étais kidnappé. Et puis le
passager qui s'appelle qu'on nomme le
caucasien la la cacaocase qui s'appelle
la cacaocase. est blanc
euh il ressemble à un caucasien donc on
l'appelle comme ça, on le surnomme comme
ça et et je vais avoir des difficulté
avec l'un de avec Mosa qui lui est tout
de suite très vite convaincu que je suis
pas je suis pas venu à Gao pour rien,
que je suis pas là au hasard et que je
je travaille certainement pour les
services français euh ou que je suis un
agent de Barcane et que voilà je suis là
pour avoir des informations et que je
suis une sorte de de de d'agent qu'ils
ont capturé un agent. Il t'a dit
pourquoi ?
Euh non, je sais pas pourquoi mais c'est
quelque chose qui me fait très peur
parce que je me dis je suis déjà
journaliste et déjà voilà, je suis
journaliste, j'ai été kidnappé mais si
on prend pour un agent là, ma vie est
vraiment en danger. Euh et je je je vais
m'employer, essayer de les convaincre du
contraire quoi. C'est quelque chose qui
me fait vraiment peur. Je suis pas un
agent, je suis un journaliste. Allez sur
internet, allez regarder tel site, tel
site, vous verrez mes articles. Je suis
journaliste. Ils vont se renseigner. Ils
vont se renseigner. Mais lui il reste
convaincu que je suis un agent. Et au
bout d'un moment, je crois que
Pourquoi il reste convaincu ? Parce que
certains services utilisent les ONG, les
journalistes comme source d'information,
source de questionnement sur zone.
Ouais. euh et que ils ont ils ont terni
l'image des ONG et l'image des
journalistes. Et c'est pour ça que les
ONG et les journalistes deviennent des
cibles ou c'est parce que tu es un peu
costaud, tu es un peu carré euh que euh
le Mali c'est le trou du cul du monde.
Qu'est-ce que tu aurais Qu'est-ce que tu
t'emmerdes à Bamako à faire des papiers
sur Bamo, quoi.
Moi moi je pense qu'il y a le fait
d'être journaliste déjà c'est une
couverture comme vous l'avez dit c'est
une couverture déjà ça peut être une
couverture pour d'autres activités
d'autres un autre métier.
Faire du ménage.
Voilà et puis il y a le
quoi faire du ménage.
Faire du ménage
pour un journaliste.
C'est porter un sujet pour des intérêts.
C'est ça.
Ah d'accord. OK. Oui oui enfin je
pensais même pas à ça journaliste comme
couverture en étant en étant un agent ou
quelque chose comme ça et
je pense aussi que le fait que je
commence à faire du sport que je fasse
des arts martiaux ça les met direct sur
la piste militaire et il y en a qui me
le diront mais tu es pas journé mais
pourquoi je dis mais tu fais tu fais tu
fais des trucs là tu tu fais tes machin
tes arts martiaux mais alors les
journalistes font pas d'arts martiaux
les militaires font des arts martiaux et
j'ai essayé bon j'ai beau essayé de les
convaincre ça ne fonctionne pas ils sont
convaincus et ça va monter à un point au
bout d'un moment où excéder, je crois
que c'est la peur qui me fait parler à
ce moment-là, je traite ce mot ça de con
parce que je vois que ça ne porte pas.
Ce que j'essaie de lui dire ne porte
pas. Et et là c'est voilà là sa réaction
est très froide d'un coup. Je suis allé
vraiment loin. J'ai l'impression que je
vais y passer.
Vraiment loin ? Comment ?
Ben dans le sens j'insulte un de mes
jeiers quoi. Euh
j'insulte comment ? Il comprend pas un
mot.
Ah si si, il parle français. C'est l'un
des deux qui était dans la voiture. Il
parle très très bien français. Il
comprend ça et je l'insulte est entouré
de ces hommes et je l'insulte comme ça
devant ces hommes et c'est c'est sorti
comme ça. Enfin, vous avez peur, vous
êtes excédé, vous ça porte pas ce que
vous dites. Vous voilà. Et euh et là,
son regard change du tout au tout tout.
Et puis mes conditions de détention à
partir de ce moment-là aussi, il veut
vraiment que la règle soit respectée. La
règle veut qu'un coupard soit très
éloigné du groupe qu'il garde. C'est à
peu près 100 m, qu'il soit enchaîné nuit
et jour. il veut qu'on rationne ma
nourriture. Il lance ces ordreslà et
puis il part avec son son collègue le
caucasien et ça va pas être respecté par
les petits jeunes qui étaient avec moi
parce qu'on avait j'avais posé des
questions, on avait réussi un petit peu
à discuter. Ils vont pas appliquer ça,
ils vont même pas m'enchaîner le soir.
Je leur dis mais c'est bizarre, vous
m'enchaînez pas. Ils me disent non, on
te fait confiance, on te fait confiance.
Et ça va activer un petit déclic dans ma
tête ça. Cette confiance, le fait qu'il
soit oisf sur le camp qui qui est des
farilles. Il y a des fois il je sais
pas, il va il va il va pisser derrière
un fouret, il laisse son arme, enfin il
y a des choses comme ça. Et il faut que
je m'active en dehors du sport parce que
c'est bien beau d'essayer de faire le
journaliste, d'essayer de faire du
sport, ça suffit pas sur sur une
journée. Et je me mets en tête de
commencer à à circuler un peu dans le
camp et de circuler de plus en plus
loin, de dire voilà de de m'éloigner. Et
c'est une façon pour moi aussi de
repérer, de savoir ce qu'il y a autour
de moi, euh s'il y a des pistes, si
j'entends des bruits, s'il y a des
camions, des choses comme ça.
Le camp, le camp se résume à quoi ? 2 4
4 euh tris trois dates par terre.
Peut-être que j'explique où est le camp.
Le camp, c'est quoi ? En plein désert,
mais vous avez des euh ce qu'ils
appellent des wadiis, des sortes de
poches comme ça végétales, des sortes de
mini forêts euh euh dans lesquels on est
hein, on est on est planqué sous les
arbres en faitin. Donc et puis quand
vous sortez de là, vous avez le désert
de cailloux ou ou de sable. Et moi, je
vais élargir ça petit à petit pour aller
voir ce qu'il y a, essayer d' guetter,
essayer de trouver un véhicule. J'ai
l'impression qu' idiotement qu'il y a
des pistes et qu'il va y avoir des
véhicules qui vont qui vont qui vont
passer quoi. Mais ça va marcher et ça ça
va me conforter. C'est-à-dire qu'il y a
une possibilité parce qu'ils font de la
sieste aussi de petit à petit comme ça
s'éloigner et d'aller partir en
reconnaissance. Et ça va jouer un petit
peu dans ma tête en me disant mais
écoute, il y a peut-être l'opportunité,
la possibilité de de t'enfuir. J'ai pas
encore cette idée-là mais c'est une
possibilité. Moi, je suis sur un autre
scénario à ce moment-là. J'ai toujours
l'impression qu'ils se sont trompés.
Donc, il me faut prévenir leurs
autorités, leurs supérieur qu'en fait,
ils se sont trompés. Donc, je demande
d'avoir du papier, un stylo, on me les
donne et je suis une lettre de trois
pages que j'adresse à l'émire
d'Al-Qaïda au Sahel, il y a d'Agrali et
je plaide ma cause en disant "Écoutez,
vous m'avez invité, il faut le respect
de la parole donnée, vous m'avez
kidnappé. Je comprends pas pourquoi.
C'est peut-être une erreur de leur part,
mais dans ce cas-là, pas en
dédommagement, mais accepter puisque je
devais interviewer un de vous chefs
régionaux, répondez à mes questions.
J'inverse le truc. Euh, j'essaie d'avoir
Ouais. de demander plus quoi. Il faut il
faut faut que je me paye. J'ai envie de
dire sur le il faut que j'inverse la
chose. Je pense que c'était ça surtout.
et je fais je transmets je leur
transmets cette lettre qu'ils envoient
certainement à leur émir et je n'ai
aucune réponse. Je pensais avoir une
réponse 3 à 4 jours après. Rien ne
vient. Donc je prends mon malin en
patience, je m'occupe comme je peux mais
j'ai pas de réponse.
Donc ça c'est au bout de combien de mois
? Non, ça c'est pas au bout de combien
de mois hein. Euh la lettre euh
les événements si tu veux de la première
semaine, c'est donc il y a la phase de
terreur, je 3 4 jours après, je me dis
qu'il faut que je fasse du sport, il
faut que je me reprenne, il faut que je
je change de paradigme par rapport à la
situation et puis après il y a cette
idée de la lettre, c'est les 10 premiers
jours, c'est dans la les les 10 premiers
jours,
je dirais
pas de retour. Là, tu te dis ils sont 4
C pour me surveiller.
Ça commence à être intéressant. Ils sont
4 c pour me surveiller et ils vont
passer au bout d'un moment, ils seront
plus, ils seront h voire une dizaine. Un
matin dans la journée, il commence le le
le wadi, on se trouve sous les arbres
euh au-dessus dans le ciel, il y a des
patrouilles de de drones. Alors, au
début, c'est rien. Puis ça repasse les
drones, c'est ça, hein. Ça passe, ça
revient, puis après ça circule autour
d'une zone qui les intéresse. Et là, il
y a commence à avoir une petit vent de
panique qui les prend. Euh, il passe des
appels àoky Walky. On est vite rejoint
par des d'autres jihadis, je sais pas
d'où ils sortent en moto et puis on file
on file euh on doit rouler je sais pas 1
heure à peu près on se retrouve en plein
désert dans un autre endroit. Ils ont
des armes lourdes à ce moment-là avec
eux. Ils ont
alors un PKM, moi je me souviens d'un
PKM
euh je crois que c'était qu'un PKM.
Chacun est armé de Kalashnikov. J'ai pas
vu d'armes de point. Ils sont nombreux
et ils sont sur les dents. Je sens
qu'ils sont voilà, ils s'attendent à ce
qu'il y ait quelque chose. Euh on va
rester de tr jours dans cette zone là et
puis après on va regagner un autre
endroit, le dispositif va s'alléger, ils
vont rester 4 c avec moi et la captivité
va continuer comme ça. Et ça c'est dans
les Ouais.
15 premiers jours, ça arrive à peu près
au bout du 10e jour, je pense.
Bon là, tu te dis euh qui dors ils
doivent s'activer un petit peu. Mon
fixeur a dû donner l'alerte.
Le plan A, plan B, plan C ont dû donner
l'alerte. Euh,
j'ai pas de radio, j'ai pas de moyen de
savoir ce qui se passe. J'imagine, je
sais que j'étais pas dans l'avion le 10
le samedi d'Ortur Bamaco. Je sais aussi
que ma compagne avait des directives au
cas où ce genre de situation allait se
passer. Donc, je sais que bah le Kidor,
le mae est au courant. Je sais que ma
famille est au courant normalement.
Après, je sais pas quelle réponse il
donne à ça. Je sais pas comment ça se
passe. Mais c'est vrai quand j'entends
la première fois des drones passer
au-dessus de moi, je me dis bah tiens,
c'est peut-être une réponse, peut-être
qu'il y a quelque chose. Quand je les
vois sur les dents, je dis bah tiens,
peut-être que ce soir il y aura je
l'espère, il y aura une intervention.
Elle ne vient pas, il se passe rien.
Donc tu as pas de montre, tu apprends à
lire le soleil
et tu
ça va venir un peu après ça le soleil
mais rapidement il faut Ouais.
Moi, il y a il y a un réflexe qui se met
en route tout de suite. Ça je m'en
souviens et ça c'est au bout du 4e jour.
3 4 Ouais. 4e jour, je dirais c'est "Je
sais que je vais perdre les dates. Euh
je sais que j'ai pu savoir et puis il me
il me provoque un peu." On est quel jour
? Tu sais quel jour on est ? Hein ? Ils
veulent jouer de cette confusion. Enfin,
ils aiment voilà se meter un petit peu
ce et et je me répète la date tous les
jours. Ça c'est un c'était mon rituel du
matin me levant me donner la date exacte
tous les jours. On est je sais pas alors
donc le le 10 avril 2021, on est le 11
avril et trois fois. Trois fois parce
qu'au bout de trois fois, il paraît
qu'on mémorise et je me fais ça tous les
jours pour pas être déboussolné. Ça va
les étonner d'ailleurs quand il me pose
la question, je peux répondre exactement
la date. L'heure, pas encore mais après
ça vient le soleil c'est quand même
assez facile. Vous commencez à avoir
l'heure aussi et puis à savoir où est
l'ouest, où est où est l'est, où est le
nord, où est le sud. Ça aide quand on se
déplace. Vo
là, ils ont compris que tu étais pas
militaire.
Ça va mettre 1 an pour que le ils
acceptent enfin ou ils croient enfin que
je ne suis pas un militaire. Ça va être
à peu près un an parce que je pense qu'
ils sont renseignés enfin petit à petit
parce qu'au départ alors oui, j'ai pas
dit moi je subis des compressions. Donc
la personne le fameux Mos là qui a un
supérieur sur le camp, ça se voit très
vite et qui croit que je suis un agent
va se renseigner et va revenir une autre
fois en me disant écoute on sait que tu
as deux bureaux à Bamaco. Écoute mon
gars, moi je suis pigiste. Deux bureaux
c'est le luxe. J'ai pas deux bureaux à
Bamac aussi. Si il y a un bureau où tu
reçois où tu reçois les gens et un autre
où tu il t'amènes les informations, les
documents machin et cetera.
Mais ça crée une peur très forte chez
moi parce qu'il me disent on a parlé à
des gens qui te connaissent. Donc c'est
peut-être quelqu'un dans mes contacts
qui désinforme. Mais cette
désinformation elle peut avoir des un
effet terrible sur le terrain là où je
me trouve. Je veux dire c'est elle
crédibilise le fait que je suis un
agent. Et ça c'est quelque chose qui me
fait très peur. Je me demande tout de
suite qui dit ça et comment je peux me
sortir de là.
Donc là ils disent tu as une sacrée
couverture parce que bon tu as deux
bureaux. On voit que tu es journalistes
que tu fais des papiers et ainsi de
suite.
Il me montre des documents aussi. Enfin,
il me montre des documents, il me montre
pas mais il me parle de documents. Donc
ça veut dire qu'ils ont eu accès à à mon
téléphone ou je sais pas. Il me montre
un document où je suis sur la photo avec
un leader d'un d'un groupe armé, d'un
groupe ex-rebelle de l'exrébellion et
c'est qui est un de leurs ennemis qu'il
recherche activement et ça aussi ça
devient un problème. Donc tu connais ce
ce chef du groupe armé donc tu peux nous
dire où il est. C'est un ami à toi donc
tu tu travailles avec lui hein parce que
nous on sait que lui travaille avec les
Français. Enfin bon et ça amène
toujours, ça vient nourrir cette
réputation que j'ai cette idée que je
suis un agent au service de la France.
Toi tes justifications par rapport à ça
c'est quoi ? Tu leur dis euh
bah elles sont minces.
Moi, pour moi, c'est voilà, je suis
journaliste, je publie aller sur
internet, je leur donne même des noms
d'articles, allez sur tel site, tel
site, allez voir dit SV.
Non.
Non non, c'était pas Non non, c'était
pas
Ça marche bien hein.
Et euh et ça marche pas. Enfin, je le
fais, je sais pas s'ils l'ont fait mais
en tout cas ça marche pas. Au départ
quand je leur dis ça, c'est pas Je crois
même qu'une fois on a prétexte "Oui,
mais ça ça peut être des faux articles,
ça peut être ta couverture, on a pu
mettre des faux articles." Enfin, je me
sens je me sens acculé quoi. Je vois pas
de porte de sortie par rapport à ça.
Tu as pas essayé un peu de casser du
sucre sur le dos de tes confrères ?
Non. Non mais je me souviens d'une
discussion, je crois que je le mets ça
aussi dans le livre, je me souviens
d'une discussion avec eux. Enfin, c'est
eux qui comment le livre ?
Prisonnier du désert, 700 jours en main
d'Al-Qaïda.
Et il y en a un après-midi comme ça, il
va vers moi, il me dit "Mais tu as de
l'argent toi ?" Et j'ai dit "Eh bon non,
enfin pas plus que ça. Il se trouve que
je devais emménager dans une maison
avant d'être kidnappé. Donc bonne partie
de l'argent était parti en caution,
ameublement, machin et cetera. Et il me
dit "Mais si tu dois avoir de l'argent,
tu es français, tu as de l'argent. Euh
et je tente un truc, je dis "Ouais 3000
€ ça va." Les clad me dis "Non, non,
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup plus." Il me
dit "Si si tu as de l'argent, tout
s'arrête. Si tu as de l'argent, tout
s'arrête, on te libère, c'est fini."
Et je lui dis "Bah non et puis je sors
comme ça spontanément, j'écoute moi non,
je suis pigiste, je travaille pour des
médias, je suis pas Serge Daniel." Elle
me dit
"Qui." Serge Daniel
qui est un grand journaliste
malien et il me dit "Ah Ser, tu sais où
il habite ? Tu sais où il est ? Tu peux
tu peux nous aider, nous donner
l'information et dans ce cas-là, on peut
faire l'échange. On te on te libère et
on prend Serge Daniel qui a de l'argent.
Je suis à bassourdi par ce truclà et
voilà. Donc ça
combien ça vaut un notage français euh
paumé dans le désert ?
Alors il y a il y a il y a une sorte
d'argus. Moi je l'apprendrai plus tard.
Ça tout dépend de la nationalité.
En tant que français, il m'informe de
ça. En tant que français, moi je vaux
100 millions, pas moins. Un italien 5
millions, je serai après plus tard. On
en parlera certainement avec un africain
du Sud, un sud-africain euh allez 6
millions au départ mais ça peut
descendre à 3 millions. Ils ont une
sorte de de de d'argus de des des savent
à peu près c'est pas la première fois
hein. Ils ont ils ont reçu des rançons.
C'est bizarre, on voit pas d'otage
russes.
D'otage russes. Alors on en parlera
après. Des otages russes. Tu Wagner,
c'est ça ?
Non non. Des Russes journalistes qui se
sont kidnappés.
Ah non bah non.
Tu sais pourquoi ?
Non
non
non. Pourquoi
c'est dangereux de payer de de prendre
un russe en Afrique ?
Euh pourquoi c'est dangereux ? Je
sais pas le FSB ou le comment ils
appellent ça le service extérieur le
grou.
Ouais. Ouais. Gru. Ils viennent chercher
qui ? Ils viennent chercher la sœur du
djihadiste, le père du djihadiste, la
mère du djihadiste, l'imam du djihadiste
et ils font bah c'est très simple. Ah ou
première semaine, on va t'envoyer les
mains
puis on va voir si notre compatriote
ressort.
Ah c'est une stratégie la peur de
changer de camp. Eux, ils font très
peur, ils font beaucoup d'exaction. Il
faut faire donc plus d'exaction pour que
la peur change de camp. Mais ça c'est
pas
merde la DGSE,
c'est pas c'est pas c'est pas que la
Panagé russe mais ça c'était une
stratégie sur le terrain qui était qui
était là au Mali en tout cas à l'époque
où où j'y étais qui était
parler des popof un peu ou pas du tout ?
Ça va venir après ça parce que Wagner ça
arrive fin décembre 2021 début 2022 et
moi j'en entends parler alors il y a du
temps, j'aurai une radio d'ici là j'en
entends parler à la radio, je le
découvre voilà comme eux mais ça les a
jamais vraiment inquiété, ils y croient
pas et quelque part moi j'y crois pas
non plus mais comment une force
mercenaire pourrait faire ce qu'une
force régulière comme l'armée française
la force barcagne qui connaît hein la la
force bacane n'est pas arrivée quand
quand qu'en 2014 la France est là depuis
un moment elle a ses réseaux elle sait
faire c'est une armée elle était équipé,
comment pourrait-il faire mieux ? Donc
j'y crois pas moi non plus.
Bah parce que les mercenaires n'ont pas
le droit international à respecter.
Non mais qui pas le droit mais il faut
quand même du renseignement, faut quand
même pouvoir est-ce qu'un un un
mercenaire de Wagner peut détecter au
milieu d'une foule de Touareg dans un
village Toareg qui est djihadiste, qui
est un ex-rebelle, qui est commerçant
qui vend des chameons ? Le fait de pas
de respecter pas les droits de l'homme,
toi tu es capable de le faire ? Euh
alors ça va ça va venir ça va venir
petit à petit parce que ils ont il y a
les motos, il y a la il y a beaucoup de
choses mais euh mais je crois que c'est
c'est très compliqué et c'est pas je
pense pas que les Russes soient plus
forts que les Français là-dessus.
Euh tu vas m'excuser une seule une
petite seconde si tu m'as fait boire
trop de café. Il faut que j'aille faire
un petit tour juste une seconde. Je vais
te poser une question. Tu sais que je
t'entends euh
je vais te poser une question et tu vas
me laisser 30 secondes ou même 45
secondes tu vas meubler pendant que je
vais t'abandonner.
Parle-moi
de parle-leur
à partir de quel moment tu t'es dit je
me barre ? Tu t'es mis en mode prison
break à dire la petite agrafe, je vais
la mettre dans ma poche. Ça, je vais le
mettre dans ma poche. Le stylo, je vais
le mettre dans ma poche. Je vais faire
un trou sous ma paillasse pour planquer
tout ça.
Et je vais me faire un plan à analyser
Youssouf qui part à telle heure, qui
fait sa sieste à telle heure, qui mange
machin. S'il y a une plante du désert
que j'ai appris, je vais me faire un
petit cocktail que je vais mettre dans
la marmite, ça va tous les faire dormir
ou je vais ramasser des aiguilles, je
vais lui planter dans la jugulaire, je
vais essayer de me barrer.
Je te confie le le crachoir juste une
infiniment désolé mais c'est c'est ta
faute. Trop de café.
OK. D'accord. Bah tout part d'une tout
part d'une information en fait que je
vais obtenir d'un chef dihadiste qui me
garde qui m'a gardé pendant 15 jours qui
s'appelait Alassan. Et ce ce chef
djihadiste en fait il me donne la
réponse que j'attends ou du moins il
m'informe sur une réponse que j'attends.
Cette réponse c'est celle de la lettre
que j'ai envoyé à cet émir d'Al-Qaïda il
d'Agrali et il me dit "Écoute la lettre
on l'a bien reçu mais euh ici les
réponses mettent du temps. Tu es un
français on n' pas votre tempo.
Peut-être que voilà pour l'instant ils
te font pas confiance et il m'explique
qu'en gros faut laisser passer 5 6 mois
et que dans 5 6 mois si tout va bien il
pourra pousser pour moi relancer en gros
cette lettre et je je comprends tout de
suite que je vais rester 5 6 mois
encore au tâage dans ces conditions de
vie avec eux et c'est là je crois que
c'est ça le déclic qui me fait me dire
OK maintenant il faut que je trouve une
autre voie de sortie une autre sortie il
faut que je repère faut que j'observe
pour pour m'évader et ça va devenir une
sorte d'obsession. Je crois que ça a
commencé le lendemain où j'apprends ça
directement le lendemain. Je me souviens
que c'était la fête de Laï.
Ouais, c'est ça. C'est la fête de Laï.
Donc ils se sont occupés sur le camp,
ils se font à manger, ils ont des euh
ils mettent des beaux basins, c'est la
fête, pour se pour se détendre et pour
se divertir. Ils tirent sur des sur des
canettes, sur des bouteilles et puis
après ils font la sieste. Et ça va être
ma première action, on va dire euh pour
dans dans l'idée de m'évader. Et cette
action, c'est euh de l'endroit où je
suis, me rendre au pickup qui est à peu
près à une centaine de mètres pendant
qu'ils dorment, ils sont au milieu et
euh essayer d'aller jusqu'au pickup pour
trouver une clé parce que j'ai une
chaîne quand je dors le soir, une clé de
serrage, la ramener, la planquer et puis
le soir quand ils dormiront pouvoir
pouvoir m'évader. Et je crois que c'est
la première action que je fais en fait
d'évasion et ça va ouvrir toute une
séquence que j'appelle dans le livre
justement voilà la séquence des
évasions. J'ai tenté quatre fois de
m'évader et tous mes efforts vont être
tournés vers ça. Tous mes efforts vont
être tournés vers ça.
Quelles étaient les mesures de rétorsion
quand tu te faisais attraper ou quand
je me suis jamais fait attraper sauf la
dernière fois. C'est-à-dire moi, j'ai dû
faire quatre tentatives d'évasion sèche.
J'ai envie de dire. Bon, les trois
premières, je revenais parce que j'étais
pas prêt différentes raisons. La
première elle était elle était c'est
arrivé de façon impromptue. La personne
qui doit m'enchaîner le soir n'a pas de
clé de serrage. Il fait un mic mac
rapide pour me faire croire qu'il sert
mais je comprends qu'il en a pas. Donc
il part, j'ai dans l'idée de m'évader
depuis un moment hein, depuis maintenant
quelques semaines, mais je suis pas
prêt. J'ai pas j'ai pas mis deux trois
gâteaux de côté, j'ai pas assez d'eau et
euh et puis commence le le ciel est
d'ancre, il commence à pleuvoir. Mais je
je dois saisir l'occasion, tant pis, j'y
vais. Je me libère de ma chaîne le soir
facilement, elle est pas serrée, je
j'arrive à sortir de la forêt dans
laquelle on est, qui est au milieu donc
d'un désert. Il faut savoir que la
plupart des arbres dans les Wadis, c'est
des arbres à piquants. C'est des
piquants très voilà. Et ça ne pose pas
de problème parce que la terre est
meuble. On est sous les bois, on est
dans le sous-bois. Mais dès que je sors
c'est un désert de cailloux, on a des
sandales. J'ai des sandales et toutes
les épignes qui se sont logés dans mes
sandales à ce moment-là, elles me
torturent les pieds, me vrigu les pieds,
elle me elle me transperce les pieds. Et
il y a une question de temps, quand on
s'évade, faut pas mettre 3 he pour faire
100 m, quoi. Et là, je comprends que ça
va être compliqué. Ça divise ma vitesse
de mouvement par deux ou par trois et
puis je pompe l'eau que j'ai. J'ai
qu'une moitié de bouteille, j'ai pas
j'ai pas prévu et je je pompe je pompe
l'eau et au bout je sais pas ça a dû
durer, j'ai dû j'ai dû essayer comme ça
30 40 minutes. Puis au bout d'un moment
je rentre, je peux pas, je sais que ça
va pas marcher parce que moi la distance
le peu de distance que je vais faire le
lendemain matin, même quand ils vont se
réveiller, même si j'ai allé 3 4 heur
d'avance, ils prennent la moto en 20
minutes, ils sont sur moi et donc je
rentre, c'est la première grosse
déception. Je rentre, je je pas je
rentre tard et puis il y a la peur aussi
enfin il y a une situation assez
spéciale, c'est que je rentre dans une
forêt. Donc il faut imaginer, vous êtes
dans un désert, vous avez une grande
forêt qui s'ouvre devant vous. Je me
souviens qu'il y avait une colline et
euh vous ne savez pas où vous dormez
dans cette forêt. Dans quel point, on
sait pas parce que l'idée c'était de
partir, pas de revenir. Et heureusement
quand je m'entraîais, je m'entraîis en
face de cette colline. Donc je savais
que si je faisais le tour du bois et que
je me mettais face à la colline et
plutôt dos à la colline en continuant
tout droit et en tournant comme ça dans
pleine nuit he nuit noire, je devrais
tomber normalement sur l'endroit où je
dors. Et alors on est dans les
sous-bois, ça craque, il y a des
branches, il y a plein de choses. et je
vais mettre je sais pas
pour sortir du bois j'ai dû mettre allez
un quart d'heure 20 minutes pour
rentrer. Je vais mettre 2 he ou un truc
comme ça parce que vous faites j'étais
obligé de faire des pas faut pas qu'il y
ait ça c'est des pas donc il faut qu'il
y a on attend
tu marches comme danse.
Ouais voilà un peu. Voilà c'est un peu
ça et ça ça met du temps et il y a le
stress il y a des bruits puis on a peur
d'être tiré dans la nuit. Eux s'ils
entendent ça ils se réveillent puis ils
ont l'ordre hein. Je l'apprendrai plus
tard. euh s'il y a du bruit dans la
nuit, s'ils entendent quelque chose, ils
tirent d'abord, hein. Donc c'est c'était
c'était c'est le premier échec d'évasion
euh de mon fait et euh qui va mener à
d'autres. Alors il y a d'autres
évasions. La deuxième fois, j'annule
aussi parce que j'ai repéré pendant la
journée la route et cetera. Je fais
toujours ses balades, hein, sous
prétexte de me dégourdir les jambes. Je
fais ses balades, je repère la route et
je découvre une route au bout d'un
moment. Et je me dis c'est génial, c'est
un peu long pour y arriver mais je la
repère. Mais je la repère de jours et je
m'évade de la nuit. Et la nuit, c'est
pas du tout pareil que le jour. Je
reconnais pas les routes, je me perds.
Ça, je fais énormément de bruit. Je
comprends aussi qu'il y a pas forcément
que notre camp, c'est un bois dans
lequel vont les djihadistes. Nous, on
est dans un camp mais il peut y avoir un
autre camp de djihadiste à côté. Et là,
ça me paralyse. Finalement, au bout de 2
heures et quelques, j'arrive à trouver
cette fameuse route et quand je
l'emprunte, elle est elle est jonchée de
détritus, d'arbus qui me signale en gros
qu'elle a pas été empruntée depuis
longtemps. Donc, il y a aucune chance de
trouver un camion, un véhicule, une moto
qui passe par là qui pourrait me prendre
et m'amener comme je l'espère au camp
des forces internationales en très peu
de temps. Donc là, je rentre pareil. La
troisème fois, on a bougé. Alors, il
faut savoir qu'il y a une succession.
tous les 15 jours, il se relève, hein,
on bouge, hein, j'ai pas dit ça. Et euh
il y a une une occasion qui va qui va
faire le laron, qui va me permettre de
de faire ma troisème évasion, c'est
qu'on me donne, je sais plus pourquoi,
on me donne une bâche. Ah oui, c'est
pour la saison des puis on me donne une
bâche en plastique et moi, faut que je
me prépare le soir. J'ai pris un
pantalon que j'ai noué qui me sert de
sac à dos dans lequel je mets un peu de
bouffe, un peu à boire des bouteilles.
Et bon, je peux pas faire ça au grand
jour. Faut oublier que si je suis là,
eux sont à quelques cinquantaines
cinquantaines de mètres et qu'ils ont eu
sur moi. Et je je fémine de me
construire une cabane et j'utilise cette
bâche pour faire un toit, ce qui me
permet de me cacher d'eux et le soir
pendant qu'ils dorment, je me mets à
genou lentement. Alors tout ça prend
énormément de temps, faut pas faire de
bruit. Lentement, je charge mon sac, je
me prépare, je me mets à genou et au
moment, alors ça prend au moins une
heure. Au moment où je suis prêt à
sortir de cette cabane de fortune, il y
en a un qui se lève,
il va pisser. Don, je dis "OK, je reste
je reste à genou." il va pisser, il va
aller se rendormir. Et je l'entends
qu'il se remet sur sa date, il sort son
téléphone et puis il commence à à rester
sur son téléphone. Et là, j'attends,
j'attends, la fatigue vient, le stress
et je me sens, j'ai plus la force, je me
sens plus capable de le faire. C'est
trop tard aussi parce qu'il y a un
certain temps hein, il se lève à 5h du
matin pour les ablutions, 5h30 pour pour
prier. Donc en gros le timing c'est vous
quittez le camp à 10h, vous avez en gros
le maxi maxi jusqu'à 1h du matin pour
trouver un véhicule parce que c'est ça
l'idée hein, c'est en 5 points les plans
d'évasion et si c'est pas le cas il faut
vraiment commencer à s'inquiéter parce
qu'on est là dans la partie matinée, il
est 1h 2h du matin dans 3h ils sont ils
sont levés. Comment qu'est-ce que je
fais ? Et donc là je suis trop fatigué,
j'abandonne.
J'apprends aussi sur le camp toujours.
Je pose des questions, je je m'habitue
plus. Euh, j'enlève parce que j'ai bien
compris le coup du bruit des des
craquements sous les bois. Donc, petit à
petit pour la 4e évasion, je nettoie
sans avoir l'air de nettoyer. Je je
prétextais que j'avais besoin de d'aller
chier ou d'aller pisser loin. Ça me
permettait d'aller beaucoup plus loin,
de de pousser les branchages et tout et
cetera. Donc, je construis euh bon,
normalement la route qui va me permettre
de me barrer. Et surtout, j'écoute
j'écoute les véhicules, j'écoute les
camions. Euh, ils sont là, il y a une
route donc qui passe par là et tout et
cetera.
Il se trouve que il y avait du bruit.
Les camions, vous les entendez beaucoup
au début du mois et à la fin du mois.
Début du mois, milieu, 15 jours après,
milieu du mois, fin du mois. Je pense
que c'est le roulement des
approvisionnements qui viennent
d'Algérie, qui viennent du Niger, qui
viennent de Mauritanie dans les petites
boutiques qui est un peu partout, hein.
Donc, je savais à peu près la date pour
ça. Et et donc le la 4e évasion, elle
est préparée celle-là. Je suis avec des
bons dormeurs, les mecs dorment bien.
J'ai fait le test quand il dormait, je
me suis rapproché comme ça pour demander
quelque chose de l'eau et cetera et je
suis au-dessus d'eux. Il y a les armes
pas loin et il y a rien. J'ai super
ceux-là ils dorment, c'est fantastique.
Et le soir venu de cette 4e évasion, je
sors, paf, sans problème. Pas de bruit
dans le sable parce que j'ai enlevé,
j'ai préparé la voie. Euh et puis j'y
vais, je pars et je me rends vers
l'endroit où je crois qu'il y a une
piste et où devrait y avoir des camions.
Euh j'y arrive à rien, il y a rien du
tout. Mais par contre, j'entends des
camions beaucoup plus loin. Je me dis
merde, qu'est-ce que je fais ? Donc j'y
vais, je prends la route et puis j'ai
beau marché, j'ai beau marché, il y a
pas de pistement, il y a plus de camion
et je sais plus comment m'orienter. Je
suis perdu, je sais plus où est le camp.
Je me demande si je vais pas tourner en
rond et revenir comme un comme un con
sur le camp. Je sais pas m'orienter avec
la lune. Donc idiot, je suis la lune.
J'ai qu'à suivre la lune mais la lune
elle fait tourner en rond.
Tu es journaliste toi, c'est sûr.
Et au bout d'un moment, je suis crevé.
Je suis crevé et j'ai une petite
couverture rose fuchia, je me souviens
avec moi. Ouais. Ouais. Je l'étale au
pied d'un arbre. Puis je me dis, je vais
dormir de 3h, je suis vraiment crevé. Et
demain matin très tôt, demain c'est mort
hein, je sais que c'est mort. Euh demain
matin très tôt quand il fait l'a j'y
verrai clair, j'aviserai une montagne,
un wadi puis j'irai me planquer quoi. Et
je dors pas de la nuit parce que je sais
que c'est mort. J'ai dépassé la le truc.
Ils vont se réveiller dans 3h. La
première chose qu'ils vont faire c'est
prier puis après ils vont aller
m'enlever ma chaîne, ils vont aller sous
ma tente et puis ils vont voir qu'il y a
personne.
Donc au petit jour blè dès que le le le
soleil se lève, je suis debout. Il faut
plan faut me planquer. Faut faut faut
que je me planque. Je marche, je marche
et je vois une j'entends des grondements
et je vois une
un nuage de poussière au loin. J'arrive
pas à le croire et c'est un camion ce
que j'ai cherché toute la nuit, je le
découvre au matin. Alors là, je cours
vers la piste. Le camion arrive, un gros
camion, je me souviens, je l'arrête. Euh
je je vais à la fenêtre, il y a deux je
me souviens deux un conducteur, un
passager, le passager, un chèche vert.
Je rougis, il me regarde, il semble
super étonné. avec ta couverture fuchia.
Ah non, la couverture est rangée et
d'ailleurs mon j'avais planqué mon
balluchon dans un ta et je je suis sur
le bord de la piste
et puis je commence à leur dire s'il
vous plaît prenez-moi avec vous,
prenez-moi avec vous et cetera et puis
le le bon je vois qu'il parle pas
français, je fais quelques mots que j'ai
j'ai pu grappiller avec eux et c'est
hatif ça veut dire prisonnier. Atif
monde et je dis flin sur flin surfatif.
Et là les mecs changent totalement de
regard. J'ai l'impression que j'aurais
pu peut-être les convaincre mais là il
change de regard direct. Le regard
change totalement. Il me fait "Ah non
non non non non." Et puis là, j'ai une
peur qui me prend d'un coup. Je me dis
"Ces gars-l, je sais pas qui sont, je
sais pas s'il travaillent avec les
autres. Ils ont une radio, je sais pas
ce qui va se passer et j'ai qu'une
envie, c'est me tirer." Donc il
continue, je passe par le tailli puis je
vois que le le mec où si chèche vert
regarde ma direction. Je prends mon
balluchon puis j'avise une sorte de
colline. Il y en a beaucoup comme ça,
des collines de sable ou de Et je me dis
"Je vais aller là-bas. Je vais griller
mes dernières forces, l'eau que j'ai, je
vais aller là-bas et puis je vais me
planquer et quand parce que le soleil
commence à monter hein, faut faut c'est
le désert. Donc à midi, on se planque,
on se met sous l'ombre normalement. Là,
je sais que je vais pas pouvoir marcher
comme ça indéfiniment. Je grille mes ma
dernière mes derniers
ma dernière énergie à aller sur cette
colline. Je suis vraiment crevé. Je me
mets sur le versant, j'avise des
taillis, je me mets dessous, je je mets
ma ma couverture rose, je m'étale
dessus. Je suis vraiment crevé. Je me
dis je vais puis j'ai plus à boire, j'ai
plus trop à boire, j'ai plus trop à
manger et je sais pas, peu de temps
après, j'entends des brombissements,
enfin j'entends une moteur d'une moto
quoi et je suis je suis quasiment sûr,
instinctivement, je je suis quasiment
sûr ce sont ils doivent faire des
patrouilles pour me trouver. Et je me
lève comme ça pour voir et je vois une
moto qui vienne dans mon sens. Je suis
sur une pente, hein, sous détaillé mais
sur une pente. La moto passe, alors je
me je me plaque sur le sur la
couverture. La moto passe à côté, je me
souviens, je les vois passer et je les
reconnais. Je reconnais je reconnais les
deux jihadistes qui me gardaient. Je
vois la moto qui passe. OK, ils m'ont
pas vu, c'est cool. Et puis bon ben vous
prenez de la hauteur, vous son en moto,
il il tournent, ils redescendent. Il
suivaient les traces, c'est des
pisteurs. Et puis là, il voit un gars
même sous les taillis étalé sur une
couverture fuchia, quoi.
Et euh
tu prends un coup de cross, tu fais
qu'est-ce qui se passe ?
Bah il déboule. Moi je me souviens tout
va très vite he moi dès que je les vois
débouler alors j'essaie de les enfin le
mec déboule il sort de sa moto, il
cherche son son sac àov et il vient vers
moi. Là j'éclate en song non mais non
enfin tu vois je enfin c'est très
émotionnel on va dire très émotionnel et
il veut rien entendre je me souviens que
là mes lunettes ont été cassées on m'a
on m'a mis un chèche autour des yeux et
puis on me on me fait mettre à genoux je
me dis c'est l'exécution quoi. et
j'entends l'arme qui se charge et puis
rien ne vient après. Moi, je me souviens
d'avoir pensé à un truc, c'est assez
dingue dans ces situations là. Euh moi
ce qui me faisait peur, c'était voir le
fusil braquer sur moi et attendre le
coup de feu. Mais par chance, ils m'ont
mis le bandeau sur les yeux. Donc je ne
vois rien et une balle, ça va vite. Au
moment où j'entendrai boum, je serai
mort quoi en fait. Et je me dis c'est
bon, c'est cool ça. Je vais pas voilà je
vais pas te confronter à ça. Au moment
où ça va, c'est fini, tant pis. Voilà,
c'est fini. C'est rapide et rien ne
vient. Rien ne vient. Et euh et
j'entends j'entends après qu'on me dit
ha qui en ve dire tiens tiens et je
comprends pas. Et
comment tu dis en arabe ?
En arabe je sais pas. En Tamashek c'est
roda roda
roda. OK. Bon là c'était c'était du tamc
et tiens tiens comme si on tendait
quelque chose. J'ai les yeux bandés et
puis je sens le contact la peau, l'outre
l'eau fraîche et je peux pas la prendre.
J'éclate en sans l'eau. Là, je me je
mefie sur le sable.
On me on me prend comme un paquet, on me
met derrière une moto, on part vraiment
très vite. Je je manque de tomber de la
moto. Je pense que là, ils étaient super
énervés, ils en avaient rien à [__]
Et je me demande si on m'amène à la
mort. Mais je me dis en même temps parce
que c'était quelque chose, ça j'ai
oublié d'en parler, mais évidemment
quand on fait une tentative d'évasion,
on essaie d'estimer à peu près les
chances qu'on a. Et bien sûr, le pire,
que se passerait-il si je me fais
attraper ? C'est ce qui m'arrive là. Et
je me dis mais mon raisonnement c'était
OK, tu as de la valeur, ils veulent te
monayer, ils veulent faire quelque chose
avec toi et cetera. Est-ce qu'on tuerait
quelqu'un qui vaut ? Ils m'ont dit 100
millions. Est-ce qu'on est-ce que vous
tueriez quelqu'un que vous avez kidnappé
qui vaut 100 millions ? Bah moi, j'ai
envie de dire non, mais j'en sais rien
parce que en même temps, j'ai travaillé
leur confiance et tout et cetera. Et ils
vont me ramener au camp, ils vont me
balancer dans la tente. J'ai plus une
chaîne mais deux chaînes qui vont
sceller avec de la colle glue et du
sable. On m'enlève, j'ai plus de
chaussures. Faut faut se rappeler que
sous les les sous-bois, c'est que des
épines. Impossible de marcher si vous
avez pas de godasse he dans ce trucl.
J'ai plus d'eau. Euh j'ai j'avais une
tente qui m'a permis de faire mes
préparations sans qu'il me voit. Il
dépilote toute la t, je je suis central,
on ne voit que moi. Et puis le le le le
traitement va totalement changer. Là, je
les ai trahis. Surtout, je crois qu'ils
m'en veulent parce que ils s'y
attendaient pas. Ils s'y attendaient
pas. Je pensais pas que j'étais capable
de de de voilà, j'étais plutôt voilà, je
je faisais l'échange, je posais des
questions, j'étais curieux, je faisais
ce qu'on me disait de faire et ils sont
été trahis. Ils ont été trahis par un
coufard, par un infidèle. Et ça ça c'est
je pense que c'est ça que les amis
vraiment rognent. Et on va très vite me
signifier que si je refais quelque chose
comme ça, on me le dit, c'est c'est je
suis zigouillé tout de suite là, il y a
pas de seconde chance.
Et bon, évidemment que je prends ça en
considération. Je suis très en colère
aussi en même temps d'avoir échoué
encore de de me retrouver pire encore
pire au même point mais dans un une
situation pire
et euh
ouais je me souviens d'une grande grande
colère et ils me mettent deux chaînes
aux jambes. Je me souviens pour que
éviter que je m'entraîne. Maintenant ils
veulent plus que je m'entraîne, il y a
plus de sport, il y a plus de passe
droit, il y a plus rien. Et je prends un
malin plaisir à m'entraîner avec les
deux chaînes. Ça je me souviens de ça.
Gling gling gling gling.
Le bruit de la chaîne.
Ouais, le clicit de la chaîne. Ça, je
connais bien le clickit de la chaîne. Et
euh
tu sais comment tu reconnais un homme
libre ?
Ben, il a pas de clic avec lui, je
pense. Non,
reconnait un
Il a pas de chaîne en fait.
Euh et là, je rentre dans ce que
j'appelle une période où où il y a il y
a beaucoup de méfiance, de défiance
envers moi. En fait, je suis je suis
vraiment je suis très mal vu. On me
laisse on me sert au cordau. Vraiment,
on voilà, ils me font plus du tout
confiance. On vient me visiter deux à
trois fois dans la nuit avec une lumière
dans la gueule pour voir si je suis
toujours là. Euh
avant avant tout ça, tu avais intercepté
une lampe de poche pour faire des
signaux dans la nuit.
Alors ouais, j'ai passé un peu parce
qu'il y a énormément de choses tout ça
énormément pr des notes sur des
bouteilles de lait. Comment ça se passe
? Alors, il y a beaucoup de choses.
Ouais, la lampe de poche, je l'ai eu euh
Ah oui, la lampe de poche, ça vient de
la bouffe parce qu'ils sont réglés euh
au niveau du temps et le soleil se
couche tôt à 18h30 tous les jours, le
soleil se couche et sort de la bouffe à
à 19h. Donc, non seulement la bouffe est
dégueulasse, mais en plus vous mangez
comme un animal dans l'obscurité
et ça semble rien comme ça. Mais le
problème c'est pas la bouffe est
dégueulasse, vous mangez dans
l'obscurité très bien mais après il faut
vous séparer. Faut mettre de la distance
entre l'euge dans laquelle vous avez
mangé et l'endroit où vous dormez. Parce
que vous êtes en pleine nature, ça
grouille d'insectes. Si vous si je dors
là et que je mets une assiette là, je
suis un casse-croûte. Et donc laver une
assiette dans le dans le noir, c'est pas
possible. à tel point et tellement
dormir relativement bien est important
pour moi, je refuse de manger. Donc au
bout d'un moment, ça devient un
problème. Il dit "Mais donnez-moi une
lampe de poche que je puisse bouffer. Au
moins je peux laver, balarguer le truc."
Enfin voilà, je vois ce que je fais
quoi. Puis même au-delà de ça, vous
faites tomber des miettes, c'est pareil.
Il faut vous faites tomber des miettes
de pain, des miettes de riz ou je sais
pas quoi, de semoule, machin et cetera.
C'est pareil, ça fait venir des fourmis.
Il y a toutes sortes de trucs, toutes
sortes de fourmis là-bas, toutes sortes
de machins. Donc ça devient vraiment un
problème pour moi. C'est pour ça qu'il
m'offre une de poche. Et c'est l'OM de
poche, ça va me permettre, c'est vrai
parce que j'ai fait quatre évasions,
mais j'ai fait aussi après des
tentatives de reconnaissance. Je
m'évalais pas sèchement comme ça. Je Il
y avait il y avait une un système, c'est
des dormeurs, il dormait. Donc le soir,
j'avais la possibilité à force de faire
du sport, petit à petit, le boulon où
j'avais à la chaîne se dévissait. Donc
au bout d'un moment, par surprise, je
suis capable de me délivrer à volonté
quoi. Donc le soir, j'allais faire mes
reconnaissances et qui dormait. Je
montais sur la colline pour voir aux
alentours avec l'idée que j'aurais
peut-être vu des feux, un village, un
campement, que ça aurait été mon ma
boussole quoi. Puis il y a rien, on
était en plein désert donc il y avait
rien du tout. Donc je faisais des
reconnaissants, je sortais la nuit et
avec ma lampe de poche une fois quand on
était planqué, il y avait des
patrouilles pendant toute la nuit euh de
drones, je pense de d'avion dans le
ciel. Donc je me suis éloigné du camp,
j'ai pris ma lampe de poche. Je connais
pas le morse mais je faisais des
signaux.
Ben non, tu le connais j'espère.
Non, toujours pas. C'est marrant ça. Je
m'étais promis je m'étais promis de la
prendre en plus.
Comment on va te la prendre ? Comment tu
fais SOS en morse ? Ah
je sais pas, je savais pas.
Trois petits coups, trois grands coups,
trois petits coups.
Trois petits coups, trois gros coups.
Trois petits coups. Bon ben si jamais ça
se reproduit, j'auraiis ça en tête. Et
euh
et après tu cries Macron destination.
et euh et je fais ces signaux et
bizarrement comme quoi j'avais vraiment
pas de chance, j'avais la la chouon
comme on dit au moment où je l'ai fait,
il y a plus rien, il y a plus rien dans
le ciel, il y a plus aucun briller. Donc
j'essaie de faire des signaux machin.
Bon, je rentre euh sous sous sous mon
abri, c'est sous un arbre et et au
moment où je me mets sous l'arbre,
évidemment, ça repart
comme la pêche.
Ouais. Ouais.
Et euh et euh ce que je faisais la
journée aussi, c'est donc faut faut
savoir, on a je crois que ça s'appelle
des borax si je me souviens bien, c'est
ces grands arbres à épine. Vous êtes
carrément, ils vous mettent sous l'arbre
et vous êtes carrément sous un toit
d'épine, hein. C'est comme un parapluie
d'épines. Et donc moi je me je me forais
la journée parce qu'on a que ça à faire.
Moi j'étais toujours dans tourner vers
l'évasion, la préparation d'enlever
toutes les épines pour me forer un
passage pourir sortir de l'autre côté de
l'arbre, paf, sur du sur du sable,
l'étend du sable, puis me barrait puis
je rentrais par ce petit tunnel. Mais il
fallait qu'il y ait aucune épine qui qui
me transpers, qui machin et cetera. Donc
ça ça a été un ça me fait penser à ça.
Ça a été un gros focus. Je sais plus
quel était un
J'ouvre une parenthèse. Donc toi ça fait
combien de temps que tu travaillais au
Mali à l'époque ? Ça faisait quoi ? 8
mois, 1 an 6 ans ?
Donc tu es tu es déjà tropicalisé, la
bouffe locale te fait plus peur, tu
manges dans la rue.
Ça rien à voir avec la bouffe que
j'avais là-bas.
D'accord.
C'est le sud. Moi je suis dans je suis
dans le je suis dans le sud, je suis à
Bamco.
Et donc là tu te retrouves avec la
bouffe du désert.
Ouais. Tu as été malade une fois chèvre
la dicentie. Ils t'ont donné des
médicaments, pas de médicament.
J'aurais pu écrire, je l'ai pas fait
parce que
se torcher dans le désert.
Ah non, même pas. C'est pas torcher, on
se torche pas dans le désert. On fait ça
à la tourg hein. C'est soit avec de la
flotte, si on en a, soit avec du sable.
Mais euh non, on aurait pu, on en a
parlé en plus avec mon codétenu, avec le
le Sud-Africain, on j'aurais pu écrire
un chapitre rien que sur euh couper les
ongles,
non sur les déjections, sur le fait
d'aller d'aller chier dans le désert et
surtout le parce qu'on sa
qu'il y a un bouquin qui fait la même
chose en forêt hein et c'est vendu à des
millions d'exemplaires. C'est vrai he je
savais pas du tout parce que on ce qu'on
mange évidemment a des effets sur nous.
On a été malade incalculable de fois par
le gras. Moi quand je dis c'est moi et
mon codétenu, mon compagnon d'infortune
Rert Jacobus Vivent, le citoyen
sud-africain que je rejoindrai dans une
prison, on en parlera peut-être après,
une prison dans le désert. Et donc ça
c'est un effet sur nous cette bouffe.
Évidemment, moi j'ai enfin je n'ai
jamais défqué de la sorte dans ma vie.
Vous voyez des trucs de dingue avec des
couleurs et enfin c'est c'est c'est
dingue. C'est vraiment dingue. Et ça
nous étonnait à chaque fois. On on com
c'était c'était fou. C'était fou.
Tuas jamais fait l'Inde ?
Non.
Tu devrais essayer. C'est pas mal.
Ouais. Alors ça doit être un peu pareil
parce que c'était vraiment très très
spécial. Vraiment très très spécial. Non
non, on est malade. On est malade. Et
quand ça devient un peu important, quand
ils sentent que c'est important parce
que c'est eux qui le jugent, ils vont
chercher des médicaments. Mais ça met un
certain temps. Les médicaments viennent
d'Algérie généralement ou alors c'est
peut-être quelqu'un, un chef qui en a.
Puis on vous amène pas des médicaments
spécifiques, on vous amène un sac de
médicament avec plein de trucs dedans et
il faut trouver son petit bonheur. Euh
l'amoxicyine, c'est le truc, je pense le
médicament
antibiotique, l'un des médicaments qui
utilise beaucoup et qu'on qu'on a que
j'ai pu avoir. Moi, j'ai eu des
problèmes de peau, j'ai eu des problèmes
gastriques assez dingues. Je j'avais la
la chaîne qui tapait sur le la cheville.
Donc ça me crée des vous savez des
boutons qui deviennent des gros boutons
pu quand vous c'était une des peurs
d'ailleurs que si si on est malade si on
est blessé si on est mordu par un
serpent si on est piqué par un scorpion
et cetera, c'est c'est pour vous comme
on dit he c'est pour vous et Allah donc
il y avait pas que la peur d'être avec
eux de s'en sortir et cetera, c'était
aussi survivre par par rapport à cet
environnement qui était qui était
hostile. Donc en terme en terme euh de
maladie, tu amènes un un sac de
médicaments,
tu as regardé ce qu'il y avait dedans,
si c'est écrit en français, pas en
français, comment ça se passe ?
Non non, on a bah c'était avec un
paramédique euh je dois le dire.
Rertobus RERT Yobus Vy Venter est un
paramédique sur l'infirmier quoi. Donc
il connaissait les médicaments, il avait
des notions de soin et cetera et lui à
chaque fois il lisait puis on avait
envie de lire, il lisait les posologies,
il lisait tout quoi. Donc on savait d'où
venait mais on faisait ça pour tout
hein, même pour le lait, pour la bouffe,
d'où ça vient et cetera. Donc on on
lisait tous les médicaments, tout toutes
les la notice des médicaments.
Il y avait rien pour les faire dormir ?
Non, mais une fois parce que moi je ce
que je cherchais dans les euh dans les
sacs de médicament, c'est s'il y avait
du tramadol
et euh
tramadol genre en mode captagon ou en
Ouais. Ouais. Enfin le quelque chose,
une sorte d'analgés, quelque chose qui
vous fait aussi tenir. Voilà. Et euh et
j'en ai alors j'en ai parlé, j'ai parce
que je vais interviewer des toujours
dans cette idée des journalistes, je
vais arriver parvenir à interviewer des
diadistes et je demandais mais est-ce
que vous prenez du tramadol ? Parce que
nous, c'est ce qu'on se dit à Bamaco,
c'est ce qu'il se dit. Voilà, il me dis
non pas du tout. Écoute, on boit pas
d'alcool, on fume pas, c'est pas pour
prendre des des médicaments. Mais
pourtant, une fois après, un an après,
je trouverai dans un de ces de ces sacs
du tramadol. Et je dis "Ah, c'est
marrant mais alors vous prenez du
tramadool." Et je me souviens que le
dijihadis qui était là l'a pris avec
non, il l'a pris tout de suite. Alors,
je sais pas, peut-être que c'est pas ça
n'est pas euh voilà, ils ne doivent pas
en prendre mais peut-être que certains
d'entre eux ils ont recours, je n'en
sais rien. Mais il y a eu voilà ces deux
ces deux choses.
Donc ton codétenu, tu veux en parler ?
Ouais. Grande rencontre euh
août août 2021 après la mauvaise
réputation, après les après les
évasions.
Je peux te couper ?
Ouais.
Le fait que tu sois noir, est-ce que ça
t'a aidé sur place ou pas ? Le fait
qu'il te mettent des chaînes tous les
matins, tous les soirs, est-ce que ça
t'a rappelé l'esclavage et ainsi de
suite ? Alors ça c'était Ouais. Ça c'est
ça t'a ça t'a
donné de la force.
Ça m'a plombé. Ça m'a plombé. Oui. Oui.
Ça m'a plombé. Ça m'a plombé parce que
j'avais j'ai été kidnappé euh en y
allant hein. J'ai j'ai été kidnappé, je
suis enchaîné, j'ai l'impression donc
déjà fait une belle connerie et en plus
je me débrouille pour me mettre
peut-être dans la situation des ancêtres
amants ont dû connaître un siècle ou de
et je trouve ça totalement Guadeloupéen.
Moi je suis je suis je suis Martiniquet.
Martiniquet. Ouais, mais tout ça c'est
la même. Enfin, je veux dire, j'ai
l'impression de revivre ça. C'est ça
c'est dingue. Et d'ailleurs c'était un
c'est un point
de bras fort à la Martinique.
C'est un point d'honneur que je me
mettais de pas m'enchaîner moi-même
parce qu'au bout d'un moment, au départ,
ils viennent de vous enchaîner puis
après bon, on commence à se connaître
donc ils sont un peu de vibant. Ils vous
balancent les clés comme ça. Et je me
suis jamais enchaîné. Jamais jamais
jamais jamais jamais jamais jamais. Et
c'était par rapport à ça.
Le fait que tu sois noir, ça les a ça
leur a posé des problèmes ou pas ? Non,
j'ai pas en tout cas je l'ai pas
ressenti. Ça a pas été un avantage. Ça a
pas été un désavantage. Si on les
écoute, eux, ils me disent "Mais noir
blanc, on s'en fout. C'est musulman."
Voilà, cétait musulman. Les musulmans,
ils ont pas c'est pas une question de
couleur, c'est question de religion.
Avant qu'on parle de ton codetu, on va
parler religion.
Il priait quatre fois, cin fois, six
fois, h fois par jour. Les fois par
jour.
Il priait en quelle langue ?
Ah, en arabe.
Comment ? Comment ça fait ? Oh,
bismillah. Alors,
bismillah. Al hamdillah. Voilà, la
prononciation, je l'ai pas. Ils vont
essayer d'ailleurs de me faire
de me faire prier aussi. Oui. Oui. Priq
fois par jour. Ce qui est assez
intéressant là-dedans, c'est que le
savoir du Coran est très important. On
pourrait croire que c'est le savoir
guerrier, savoir tirer aux armes et
cetera. Non, non, c'est surtout ce qui
est important, c'est connaître le Coran.
Ils savent lire ou il l'an non parce
qu'on leur a répété 25 fois sous
l'arbre.
Alors, il y a les deux. Il y en a qui
qui connaissent les textes mais ils
veulent lire au bout d'un moment. Moi,
j'ai vu des jeunes des jeunes
djihadistes enseignés à des djihadistes
plus âgés, quoi. Ça c'est marrant. Et
d'ailleurs, l'autorité peut être comme
ça conférée à celui qui connaît le
Coran. Donc, vous avez un jeune Talibé,
un jeune djihadis qui a 18 ans mais qui
sort de la Brasa, qui connaît le bouquin
quasiment par cœur. Et alors lui, il est
très respecté. C'est lui qui mène la
prière, met la calik en face de lui. Il
est devant, les autres sont derrière et
c'est lui qui mène la prière
vers la mec.
Ouais. Ouais, la mec.
Est-ce que ça prend d'autres forme ?
Est-ce qu'il y en a un qui est venu un
jour avec un Coran en lui disant "Vas-y,
mon frère, je vais t'apprendre, je vais
te mettre sur la bonne voie. Comment ça
se passe ?"
C'est arrivé, c'est arrivé à l'automne
2021 la première fois. J'ai un
Tu as sorti du saucisson, on va faire un
apéro
seulement.
J'ai un un dhadiste qui vient sur le
camp et il vient me voir moi et il me
dit comme ça tu toi toi tu vas te
convertir, toi je vais arriver à te
convertir. Et il me donne le Coran en
m'expliquant bien parce qu'on est en
pleine nature hein, comment je dois
faire. Je dois le mettre sur des
branches en haut. Je dois me laver les
mains, faire des ablutions avant de le
toucher. Enfin, j'ai tout un rit à à
effectuer avant moi, l'infidèle de
toucher ce livre. Et il me dit, "Tu vas
le lire et je reviendrai te revoir."
Tu vas le lire en quelle langue ?
En français. On me l'amène en français.
On va toujours amener des corps en
français.
Et alors, c'est un Coran en deux parties
euh que j'ai eu cette fois-ci, donc j'ai
que les 35 premières sourates. Il me
dira qu'il me ramènera il m'amènera les
autres après et qui va repasser et qu'on
va discuter et qui me dit "Toi, tu vas
toi tu vas te convertir."
Tu as donné un nom musulman ?
Oui, on va me donner un euh
ça disparaît, ça s'efface.
J'ai eu dans les premiers jours la
caucase dont j'ai parlé, le caucasien va
me donner un nom musulman. J'ai plus le
nom là trop.
Mais on va m'en donner. Ouais.
Après, ils vont t'appeler Zitoun.
Alors, Zitoun c'est spécial. Zitoun
c'est Zitoun c'est spécial et c'est
c'est quelque chose d'important parce
que c'est un grand déclencheur pour moi.
Ils m'ont ouvert une porte en fait. Ça
m'a donné une une possibilité de vivre
cette captivité mieux.
Mon nom est Olivier et eux ils le
prononcent mal. C'est Olifieux, Olivia,
Olivier. Enfin, c'est c'est au bout d'un
moment, c'est c'est agaçant, quoi. Et
puis ils ont toujours ce enfin, ils
comprennent pas ce nom, ils comprennent
pas qu'on s'appelle comme ça, comme si
c'était je sais pas comme si vous
disiez, je sais pas, je m'appelle merde
ou je sais pas quoi. Enfin, donc c'est
agaçant. Et euh et au bout d'un moment,
je me souviens quand j'étais au lycée,
j'avais un pote marocain qui me
surnommait Zitouni. Zaitoun et je me
souviens que ça veut dire Olivier. Je
dis "Mais tiens, mais non, Zaitoun." Et
là, ils sont tous étonnés. "Ah, Zaoun !
Zaitoun ! Zaoun ! Et ça c'est et au
moment où je dis ça, je comprends en
même temps que je me suis offert, je je
me suis donné la possibilité
de de comment dire ça ? De créer une
sorte de d'altère ego. C'est-à-dire à
partir de ce moment-là, ils vont que
m'appelerun qui n'est pas mon nom. C'est
comme si je vous appelle Henri alors
vous appelez un autre nom. Donc il parle
à quelqu'un d'autre et ce quelqu'un
d'autre ça va être pour moi, je vais le
déterminer l'otage en fait. Et moi je
vais être ça ça me donner une position
d'observatoire par rapport à Zetoun qui
est Zetoun est la personne qui est qui
est retenue. C'est la personne qui
estage et Olivier Dubois est caché
derrière Zetoun et peut voir ça donc
avec une sorte de décalage. Et ce nom
qui est rien comme ça, ça va permettre
ça et ça va ça va renforcer ma
résistance pour le reste de la captivité
foncièrement.
La première année, tu as fêté le premier
de l'an le 14 juillet Noël. Comment ça
s'est passé ?
La première année ? Le premier Noël, je
le passe avec donc Rert, le sud-africain
dans les sables. On est dans un wadi
sous les bois. Il fait très froid dans
le désert. Et oui, ouais, on va je vais
mettre un point d'org à à fêter Noël et
le nouvel an. Quand quand je dis fêter,
c'est-à-dire que les pâtes, les
macarons, les macarons macaronis sont un
peu meilleurs que la veille et qu'on a,
je crois qu'on peut boire un peu plus de
thé ou qu'on a un peu plus de café. Mais
on voilà, on on se je me souviens qu'on
a organisé un pique-nique quoi. On a
pris les nates, on s'est mis sur le
sable rayon de soleil où il faisait
chaud et puis on a essayé de de pas
penser à tout ça et de passer un bon
moment.
14 juillet.
Non, alors ça je non non non mais j'ai
rien contre le 14 juillet. Mais alors,
j'ai pas pensé hein. Le le Noël, ça me
faisait penser à ma famille hein. Ça me
faisait penser à mes enfants, ça me fait
penser au sapin, à la bûche. Moi j'adore
bouffer, j'adore cuisiner et ça ça
raisonnait en moi. 14 juillet un peu
moins quand même.
C'est quoi ton pl signature maintenant ?
Oh, j'en ai tellement actuellement là,
c'est des ramenes. J'appré faire des
ramenes il y a peu de temps. Très bon.
ton j'allais dire ton colloque de Wadi
les présentations ensuite se retrouver
quelqu'un qui peut parler anglais avec
toi.
Qu'est-ce que tu as pensé tes émotions ?
Qu'est-ce que tu as ressenti ?
La première fois que j'ai rencontré, bah
je suis super étonné en fait parce que
j'arrive alors il faut faut bien
comprendre ça. Je passe des différents à
au bout d'un moment on vient me chercher
en voiture de gros djihadistes. Les
premiers gros des gros djihadistes
gros enfin
obèse.
Obès ouais.
Tu connais le proverbe africain ? Non,
méfie-toi du gros.
Ah bah pour le coup, j'ai pas eu de
problème avec eux. Quoi que j'en aurai
avec d'autres après. Mais ils sont Je
suis assez étonné parce que pour moi,
ils sont voilà, ils sont plutôt fites,
ils sont plutôt mainres, mince. Et eux
me transportent, sont chargés de venir
me prendre pour m'amener, je le sais pas
encore, dans ce qui sera une prison dans
les dunes de sable. Et on n'est pas
seul, on sera 11. Donc moi, je ne le
sais pas encore, le sud-africain et puis
des des toeg des Tamaschek.
Des toarg prisonniers.
Ouais. Ah ouais. et euh prisonnier euh
moins bien traité que nous. C'estàd que
nous on a une tente, eux ils ont des
morceaux de toiles et des morceaux de
bois des bruittois. On est dans les
dunes hein, donc on est sous le soleil.
Nous on a une tente genre tente euh euh
tente humanitaire voyez on peut rentrer
à h dedans. On a ce gen heure de tente
là avec des
coû plus cher.
C'est limite c'est luxueux hein. Au
milieu de ce désert quand on voit eux
les conditions, eux ils ont un look je
dirais Guantanamo. C'estàd qu'ils sont
enchaînés pour certains autour du cou.
La taille, ça rejoint les poignets, ça
descend au aux chevilles.
Est-ce que qui ils connaissent le coin ?
Est-ce que ils connaissent le coin ? Ils
sont plus apt à se bar.
Non, je crois que c'est c'est par
rapport à ce qu'ils ont fait rapidement.
On va nous dire quand j'arrive dans
cette prison, donc on on va nous dire
que ce sont des jazzous, des
informateurs et ça c'est vraiment très
très mal vu. Des gens qui ont qui ont
renseigné Barcan, qui ont trahi, qui ont
parlé. Et puis il y a aussi semble-t-il
des contrebandiers et aussi nous diton
des gens de de l'État islamique.
J'arrive dans cette prison euh je sais
pas où me mettre et l'un des des
diadistes me dit "Est-ce que tu parles
anglais ?" Je dis "Ouais, un peu." Et il
me dit "Pece que lui aussi." Et puis il
me désigne un justement une toile avec
quatre pauvres bâtons comme ça, un m de
haut avec un mec qui est glissé que je
vois pas qui est dans l'ombre et et euh
il me dit "Va voir, il parle anglais."
Donc je vais voir, je excuse me, excuse
me, you speak English ?
Et j'ai une sorte de géant qui s'extirbe
comme ça du du du du de de sa couche de
dessous cette toile faire plus d'un80
barbu yeux bleus enfin un nordique au
beau milieu du désert quoi. Et je le
vois je le reconnais pas je le reconnais
pas dans le sens où je me souviens quand
même des des des otages que détient
Al-Qaïda à cette époque et lui je le
remets pas, je sais pas qui c'est.
et euh il se présente, c'est Rertakobus
Vivent, le sud-africain et c'est la
première fois que je le rencontre. C'est
comme ça que je le rencontre. Donc je
suis super étonné. On n pas beaucoup le
temps de parler. On n pas beaucoup le
temps de parler. On en gros on me dit où
il faut que j'aille dormir lui on le
renvoie à sa couche sous sa sous sa
bâche et c'est le lendemain matin
vraiment qu'on va pouvoir échanger et
discuter et on le charge parce que
j'arrive dans ce camp il y a moi et puis
il y a la tente avec
et on le charge de monter cette tente.
Alors, on monte une tente qui est très
grande au milieu de ce camp de
prisonnier, étonnant un peu quand même
les autres. Et puis on arrive à
convaincre les gars pour que lui arrête
de dormir dans dans ce qu'il ce qu'il
avait là et qu'il vienne dormir dans la
tente avec moi. Et là, on va commencer à
se connaître.
Il va m'expliquer donc que il a été
kidnappé le 3 novembre 2017 en Libye en
se rendant parce qu'il travaillait pour
une station électrique. Lui, il est
infirmier. Donc, c'était l'infirmier de
la station en fait. Et sur la route, le
menant à la station électrique, il va se
faire il va y avoir une embuscade, il va
se faire kidnapper, il va rester 8 mois
à peu près avec une bande mafieuse, des
bandits qui vont pas réussir à le le
monayer. Il était avec des Turcs qui eux
vont être monayés et puis après ces
bandits l'ont vendu avec des armes à
Elkaida donc auim groupe de soutien à
l'islam aux musulmans qui vont le
ramener au Mali. Et il savait il savait
quasiment rien quand je je le rencontre.
Il savait un peu qu'il était au Mali
mais savait pas qu'il détenait.
connaissait pas ce pays et posait pas de
questions. C'est ça qui m'étonne moi qui
me qui me stupéfie quand je le
rencontre, c'est qu'il a accepté son
sort et euh et qui veut s'en sortir
comme ça. Il se dit bien qu'un jour
quelqu'un viendra le chercher, qu'un
jour il sera libéré et il attend. Il est
docile, il fait ce qu'on lui dit. Et moi
je suis dans une dynamique tout autre.
J'ai tenté de m'évader, je me suis fait
attraper, on m'a menacé de mort. Je je
je veux leur foncer compagnie mais ça va
même plus loin. Je veux leur foncer
compagnie à 8 du mois
parce que je me suis fait kidnapper le
le 8 avril 2021.
Tu pousses le bouchon un peu loin Mais
non, mais il fallait fallait que je
rende le je qu'à l'époque c'est c'est
Zaun, c'est un autre personnage vraiment
ça me fait froid dans le dos quand j'y
pense mais il fallait que je leur rendre
leur modé de la pièce, c'était ça le
truc. Et donc j'avais j'étais j'avais le
cerveau en ébullition, observer,
regarder, trouver les failles et cetera.
C'était ça tout le temps. Et ça va être
contagieux. Je vais alors ça va pas se
faire facilement mais je vais le le
l'amener à penser un peu comme ça et
être un peu plus proactif et moins moins
moins attendre.
Quand tu discutes en anglais avec lui,
c'est un soulagement pour lui ? C'est
pas un soulagement
soulagement de de qu'il est quelqu'un
enfin
qui parle autre chose que
Ouais. Si si si il me le dit rapidement.
Bah oui puis il parle pas en fait. Enfin
il parle assez joli quand il va chercher
à bouffer quand
il parlait la langue locale ou pas du
tout. Il avait fini par apprendre
il avait une trousse de secours pour
parler arabe un peu tchèc. Ça a beaucoup
m'aidé d'ailleurs parce que moi je
continue à vouloir leur poser des
questions. Je continue
Comment on dit comment ça va ?
Oh est-ce que je m'en souviens comment
ça va ? Non je m'en souviens même pas.
dit bonjour.
Euh marhaba, on disait maraba ou balire.
Maraba Ouais, c'est baler aussi je
crois. Ouais. Ouais. Enfin, on voilà, on
avait moi au bout d'un moment
d'ailleurs, je vais me faire un lexique
quand j'aurai du un stylo et du papier,
je vais me faire quelques mots comme ça
que je peux dire.
Et donc voilà, il on
il est là depuis longtemps, il connaît,
il sait comment ces gens-là fonctionnent
et il peut leur parler. Enfin, bon, il
peut tenir une conversation simple.
Et moi, je vois tout de suite la
possibilité de via son entreprise
pouvoir poser des questions non
seulement évidemment à nos joliers, mais
aussi surtout aux gens qui nous
entourent, aux autres prisonniers.
Les autres prisonniers en dehors des
Toirg, il y avait d'autres nationalités
?
Ça, on a pas réussi à le savoir. La
plupart des gens avec qui, je pense que
la plupart des gens qui étaient avec
nous étaient des toeg sauf un qu'on
pouvait pas parler qui était le fameux
10-on de l'État islamique qui avait des
rapports très orageux avec eux. Pour
expliquer un petit peu, on a une
distribution de bouffe deux fois par
deux fois par jour et en plus de ça,
vous avez le lait le matin, le lait en
poudre, une sorte de grande en caclon là
comme ça et puis ils font la ronde comme
ça et à chaque fois qu'ils allaient voir
un mec qui est derrière qui avait la
radio, c'est pas rien d'avoir la radio,
vous êtes un otage privilégié quand vous
avez la radio, il avait la radio, il
écoutait le réfil le matin, c'était le
premier à prix avant tout le monde. Et à
chaque fois qu'ils qu'ils av elle lui
amené à bouffer, il s'engueulaiit avec
ses joliers. Il y avait des discussions
mais ça t'empêtait vraiment quoi. Et
nous on nous a dit celui-là missis
mauvais lui. Il est mauvais mauvais.
C'est état islamique pas bien pas bien
mauvais. Et on l'a jamais vu. On a
jamais pu lui parler parce qu'on va se
faire on va organiser ça euh essayer de
parler à à tous les gens qui est autour
de nous et qu'on a en visuel.
Tu as repéré des profils qui pourraient
eux être militaires ou pas ?
Alors moi je ce qui m'intéresse enfin
très rapidement en m'entraînant le
matin, je me rends compte que ces
gens-là discutent entre eux, ils se
parlent euh ils ont un système assez
élaboré de de sign et ça évite ça ça
éveille tout de suite quelque chose dans
ma tête quoi. Je me dis mais de quoi
parle-t-il ? Et et je me dis mais
imaginons qu'en se parlant il se
coordonne pour s'évader comme moi je
veux le faire. Que ferait-il de nous
dans ce cas-là ? et on en sait rien. Et
je pose la question à R, je dis "Mais
est-ce que tu les connais un peu ?
Est-ce que tu me dis ah non non surtout
pas. Les gardes m'ont dit de ne pas leur
parler, je leur parle pas." Et là je
dire écoute écoute, on va totalement
changer ça. Faut qu'on parle avec eux,
faut qu'on communique avec eux, qu'on
sache ce qu'ils ont dans la tête parce
que imagine qu'ils veulent qu'ils
veulent faire quelque chose. Enfin, il
faut qu'on soit au courant de ce qui se
dit quoi, ne serait-ce que pour notre
sécurité. Et donc, on va rentrer en
contact avec eux. On certaines personnes
seront du MNLA, le mouvement national de
libération de la Zawad, un groupe
rebelle, ceux qu'on qui vont lancer
l'insurrection avec les djihadistes en
2012. Il y a des membres du MNLA, il y a
des contrebandiers mais on comprend très
vite que oui, en effet, ils discutent
avec des signes parce qu'ils ont
l'intention de de s'évader. Ils sont
nombreux hein, ils sont cinq à vouloir
s'évader. Les gardes qui nous qui nous
gardent sont quatre. Ils dorment la
nuit. Le seul obstacle à leur plan,
c'est la clé de serrage. Il leur faut
une clé de serrage et la seule personne
sur le camp parce qu'il est totalement
docile, il est pour eux non agressif et
il fera jamais rien, c'est RERT qui la
journée n'est pas enchaînée et qu'il
peut se déplacer partout dans le camp.
Il peut se déplacer. Moi, je je me suis
évadé, je suis enchaîné à une roue de
camion, une jante de camion. Donc je
n'ai pas je n'ai pas sa faculté de
mouvement. Et donc ils veulent que RERT
il nous voilà, il nous demande, il
demande à RERT. En gros, quand il y a la
fameuse ronde du lait, donc ils vont
disparaître à un moment derrière les
dunes. Nous on est alors pour bien
expliquer, il y a le leur tente à eux
qui est arriimé comme ça avec des grands
câbles et nous on n'est pas loin, on est
on est vraiment à côté. Donc pendant que
sont dans les dules en train de de
distribuerles, les bah RERT pourrait
courir, aller sous la tente, trouver
cette clé de serrage, revenir et puis on
les on la lancerait, on les ferait
passer, il se la ferait passer. À la
nuit, tout le monde se lève, on subjugue
les gardes et puis et puis et puis
bastard. C'estàd vous les butez enf.
Non non non non pas. Alors ça c'était je
me souviens une grande discussion avec
lui parce que je dis mais attends OK on
les aide parce que ça tient sur nous en
fait leur plan. C'est pour ça que ça
nous donnait un peu de de pouvoir. Leur
plan tient sur nous puisquon est les
seuls tu es le seul en fait free agent
la seule personne qui peut se déplacer
quoi. Mais le problème c'est qu'il faut
qu'on ait des garanties. La première des
garanties c'est de savoir ce qu'ils
veulent faire. Moi je tiens pas même si
c'est les je tiens à tuer personne. Et
deuxièmement qu'est-ce qu'ils vont faire
de nous ? Faut qu'on ait des garanties
par rapport à ça. Non, il faut faut
qu'on ait des garanties par rapport à
ça. Et on essaie d'en avoir. Il y a la
barrière de la langue, c'est pas c'est
pas compliqué mais nous disons vous
viendrez avec nous, on partira, on se
rend compte rapidement qu'il y a que
deux motos. On sera donc sep c'était ça
à peu près 7 se sep 7 sur deux motos. Il
y en a qui vont rester qui qui vont
rester à l'heure
et à l'indienne ça charge hein.
Ouais bon je sais pas mais en tout cas
c'est voilà c'est pas c'est pas clair et
et donc on on est on est vachement en
discussion avec eux pour essayer de de
voilà de savoir quelles sont vraiment
leurs intentions.
Euh
donc il y a ce plan sur la clé de
serrage, on commence à déclencher un
plan, on est prêt à le faire, RERT est
OK pour le faire et au moment le la
journée où ça doit se passer, le matin
ça doit se passer, la veille, ils
arrivent avec les jihadistes arrivent
avec trois pickup parce que évidemment
ils sont pas ils sont pas bêtes. Ils ont
vu que ça discutait, il ils pensent pas
qu' qu'on discute avec eux. Ça c'est
cool. On a eu peur de ça et ils prennent
tout le monde et ils changent tout le
monde. Ils éparpillent tout le monde
derrière des dunes. Ils éparpillent tout
le monde. Donc le plan tombe à l'eau.
Mais malgré cela, au bout d'un moment,
ça va recommencer de façon très
éloignée, mais ils vont reprendre le
truc et cetera. Et un événement aussi
qui qui arrive à ce moment-là, c'est
qu'il y a 12 hommes, on est fin août
2021, 12 hommes patibulaires qui
semblent revenir d'un long séjour dans
le désert. Quand on croise leur regard,
ces gars-là sont sérieux. Enfin, je
vraiment je on a l'impression qu'ils ont
euh je je suis pas dans des petits
gardes du cru qui sont là machin et
cetera. Ceux-là, ils viennent faire le
coup de feu, ça se sent. C'est c'est une
une chose de constitué. Une douzaine
d'hommes qui arrivent, on les on les on
les surnommera d'ailleurs, je r les a
nommé en anglais de Phil C12,
excusez-moi, le Phil C12. et ils
viennent sur le camp et se mettent non
loin du camp derrière les dunes. On sait
pas pourquoi ils sont là, on sait pas ce
sont des renforts, mais eux déjà ils
vont amondruir toute véléité de vouloir
de vouloir s'évader et partir dans la
nuit.
En terme de libération
de RFI, des messages de ta famille à la
radio, comment ça se passe ? Tu as
commencé déjà par entendre des messages
à la radio ? Pas à la radio ? Comment ça
s'est passé ?
Moi, je demande très vite la radio. Euh,
je la demande très vite. Je vais la voir
pendant un moment quand je suis gardé
justement par ce chef djihadiste dont je
te parler qui a qui est d'accord enfin
qui me dit qui me donne la réponse de la
à la lettre que j'ai envoyé. C'est trop
tôt, faut attendre 5 6 mois et c'est lui
qui va déclencher en me disant ça le
la lettre que tu as envoyé sur le fait
qu'il soit planté.
Voilà. OK. Euh lui il il écoute RFI, il
parle français, il écoute RFI, il écoute
aussi des radios arabes, il me dit "Bah
si tu veux, moi j'écoute RFI à partir de
18h avant tu peux écouter la radio."
Donc j'ai la radio pendant 15 jours où
je serai avec lui. Après plus rien, je
demande la radio, ils veulent pas. Et
puis après quand je me suis évadé, il y
a même pas question d'avoir une radio.
Bon mais il y a il y a il y a un un
point faible, je dirais, je sais pas si
je peux dire ça un point faible, mais il
se relève, c'est pas les mêmes mecs qui
sont tout le temps là. Donc vous pouvez
faire la même demande. Ce sera la même
chose pour le papier, pour le stylo.
Vous pouvez faire la même demande à à
différents gardes. Les premiers le la
première équipe de garde vous disent
non. OK, Clan Lanten 15 jours après,
même question. Non, non, puis un jour
c'est oui quoi. Hop, vous avez un stylo.
OK, deux trois fois comme ça, hop, vous
avez du papier. OK, donc c'était une
sorte d'usure comme ça. On redemandait,
redemandait, redemand. Et moi je faisais
ça quand j'étais dans cette prison pour
la radio jusqu'au jour où il y a un diad
qui vient sous ma tente, il me dit "Etu
as eu la radio ?" Je suis super étonné.
Je dis "Piens, il doit pas être au
courant." Je dis bah non non non non ok
tu vas la voir cet après-midi. Tu vois
la radio et part et en effet dans
l'après-midi, j'ai une radio, je sais
pas du tout pourquoi et il y en a un
autre qui revient après avec des piles
et on se retrouve avec Rert sous notre
temps à pouvoir écouter la radio. Je
comprendrai plus tard qu'ils ont ils ont
eu des messages de ma famille
certainement sur voilà dans les médias
et qui se sont dit OK dans ce cas-là
l'otage doit avoir une radio pour savoir
que que sa famille tente de communiquer
avec lui. Donc c'est comme ça, c'est
comme ça que je je vais commencer à me
reconnecter avec le monde à pouvoir donc
écouter évidemment les informations du
monde, avoir des messages pour la
première fois c en octobre le 8 octobre
2021 de ma famille. Donc j'entends
qu'ils sont mobilisés, j'entends qu'ils
sont là, qu'ils sont au courant
évidemment et surtout des des
informations de ce qui se passe dans le
pays à leur niveau.
Les les les combats des djihadistes
contre les forces internationales, entre
eux aussi entre l'État islamique et et
Al-Qaïda. Donc on est renseigné, c'est
comme si on était un peu renseigné de
l'intérieur et je peux essayer, ça
nourrit justement ma fonction de
journaliste, je peux essayer de
corroborer ça avec eux et je ne je me
gêne pas pour le faire. Et c'est là où
je me rends compte qu'il y a deux euh
comment dire ça ? Deux fluxes
d'information. Il y a le fluxe de la
radio normal et puis leur fluxe de leur
radio des Toky Walky qui est très
différent de ce qu'on entend évidemment
dans nos radios et qui désinforme pas
mal parce que l'idée c'est pas que les
troupes sachent qu'une une unité s'est
fait décimer par la force barcane ou par
les FAMAS dans tel endroit du nord du
Mali par exemple. Donc c'est c'est
intéressant pour ça aussi.
Les Russes là-dedans.
Les Russes alors les Russes ils viennent
plus tard, ils arrivent donc à partir de
nous, on en entend vraiment parler.
Ouais. décembre 2021 début 2022 et on
comme eux on prend passe trop ça au
sérieux des mercenaires qui vont arriver
comment ils vont faire enfin bon eux ils
en rigolent un peu quoi. Ils rigolent
déjà beaucoup de l'armée malienne. Euh
mais là il
l'armée française il rigolent un peu
aussi.
Non l'armée française il la prennent au
sérieux. Moi je me souviens que c'était
quand même quelque chose. L'armée
française il la prennent au sérieux.
L'armée malienne parce qu'ils ont
l'habitude d'attaquer des camps et ces
camps sont rapidement désertés quand ils
passent à l'attaque hein. Il y a pas
réellement de combat, il y a pas une je
dirais une posture hein agressive. Donc
pour eux, il voilà, il considèrent que
si c'est une cible malienne, un malien,
c'est facile. Les Russes euh c'est
nouveau, c'est nouveau, mais petit à
petit, l'année qui va suivre, on va
commencer à comprendre que bon, ça
devient inquiétant pour eux notamment
parce qu'il y a eu des exactions, qu'il
y a eu des choses comme ça.
La prison dans les dunes,
c'est une prison en dure, pas en dur, en
temp ?
Non, il y a pas de dur. Je n'ai pas été
Ah si alors une fois sinon je n'ai
jamais été dans un bâtiment dur
quasiment 2 ans. Juste une fois avec ce
fameux djihadis qui me donne la réponse
pour la lettre que j'ai envoyé, on va
stationner pendant 2h 3h dans une
maison, une construction dans un
village. Je pouvais voir à travers les
fenêtres des femmes voilées. Je pouvais
entendre des enfants. Il y avait du
monde autour dans un un village
certainement. C'est tout. Sinon, c'est
toujours à l'extérieur, sous les arbres,
dans les rochers, dans le sable qui
vent, qui les tempêtes, qui qui pleuvent
à l'extérieur.
Tu as jamais cherché à savoir après par
où tu étais passé, quel camp où tu étais
? Si
si, on en parlait beaucoup et il se
trouve que Rert avait une mémoire assez
phénoménale. Il a été capable de
m'expliquer de la Libye, la route qu'il
avait pris pour venir jusqu'ici avec des
détails et tout. Je dis "Mais hom de
Dieu, si on avait Google Maps, ce serait
fantastique de pouvoir retracer."
D'ailleurs, si jamais tu t'en sors,
pense bien à retenir tout ça et à
essayer de toi-même faire la recherche
et cetera. Mais euh chaque déplacement,
on on regardait le soleil, on savait où
était l'est, l'ouest, le nord, le sud,
on calculait le temps approximativement,
on essayait toujours de de de d'essayer
de s'orienter comme ça. Et puis on va
commencer, on va s'enardir un peu, on va
commencer à poser des questions autres
que journalistique, mais des questions à
nos joliers quoi. Et moi au bout d'un
moment, il me semble parce que c'est
vrai que quand on se déplace, on va on
va vers l'est beaucoup, on monte, on va
vers l'est et tout. Je dis je me
souviens sur une une carte quelles sont
les fiefes des djihadistes dans le nord
du Mali. Je dis mais nom de Dieu là au
bout d'un moment si on continue on va
débarquer en hiver quoi. Donc en gros on
doit être peut-être allez Tin et sao hop
je dis ça et ils viennent un matin pour
voir comment ça se passe sur le camp et
cetera. Je dis ah Tinako, on est à
Tinako puis là je vois une grande
surprise. Ils sont super étonnés et puis
il reprennent après non pourquoi tu dis
ça Tin Sako ? Comment tu connais Tinako
? n'importe quoi et c'est voilà on
comprend qu'on est dans après comprendre
qu'on y est c'est un petit point grain
de sable dans un une immensité mais
voilà on essayait on essayait évidemment
de savoir où on était
est-ce que tu as fait murir ou germer
l'idée d'aller les dzinguer en pleine
nuit
ouais
ah alors je me souviens pas de la nuit
spécialement mais en journée comme je
disais il y avait en tout cas dans la
première partie même c'est arrivé un peu
après mais il y avait des armes, il y
avait des possibilités enfin laisser les
armes, ils faisaient la sieste, enfin
bon, ils allaient pisser, laisser le
truc et tout et cetera. Et j'ai
visualisé, j'ai imaginé plusieurs fois
comme dans un film d'action, faire une
roulade, prendre un fusil, me rétablir,
tirer une rafale, tuer tout le monde.
OK, déjà foir il veut le faire, vous le
faites, qu'est-ce qui se passe ? Vous
faites quoi ? Vous êtes en plein désert,
c'est eux qui assurent votre
subsistence. Je ne conduis pas, je n'ai
pas de permis de conduire. Il y a un
pickup. Bon,
tu conduis pas ?
Non, je conduis pas. Je ne conduis pas
de moto non plus, mais bon, je conduis.
Je sais pas où je vais, je démarre, on
trace, on trace, on trace, on trace. Le
premier camp, je l'apprendrai plus tard
que vous tombez, c'est des sympathisants
de ces gens-là. Vous faites pas de pas,
enfin je veux dire, c'est et et en plus
vous avez commis euh vous avez commis
vous avez tué dès l'heure. Donc là euh
enfin l'entreprise euh toute séduisante
qu'elle puisse être quand on y pense et
quand on fantasme dessus, déjà elle est
pas elle est pas c'est pas c'est quelque
chose qu'au dessus de mes moyens, c'est
quelque chose que je ne peux pas faire
et que je ne saurais pas faire.
Tu es quelqu'un ?
Ouais, tu es quelqu'un. Tu vises entre
les deux yeux ?
Mais est-ce que je vise bien ? Si si tu
rates, ça se passe comment ? Le coup est
parti, ça a fait du bruit, les gars
appliquent.
Comment on fait ?
Compliqué. Compliqué.
Ça devient super compliqué.
Ton colocataire Sudf, il est devenu quoi
?
Alors, c'est intéressant justement sur
tirer et cetera. Pour la petite
histoire, mon colocataire comme tu dis
sud-africain est un militaire. C'est un
ex militaire euh 10 ans d'armée B comme
médique. Donc c'est les les troupes de
soins dans l'armée. Il s'est tiré en
quelle année ? En quelle année ?
Euh il est sorti de là si je me souviens
bien. Oh là là la question.
Il est plus vieux que toi je crois. Non
non, c'est moi qui suis plus vieux que
lui mais de quelques années. On a 3 ans
de différence. Euh je veux pas dire de
bêtises. Je crois que c'est la fin des
non 94 c'est la fin d' début des années
2000. Je je je plus de j'ai plus de j'ai
plus la date exacte. Mais il a 10 ans
d'armée en tant que médique après 8 ans
d'Afghanistan, il a fait la Somalie,
c'est quelqu'un qui sait conduire une
moto qui sait conduire un pickup, qui
s'est charger une arme. Il me détaille
toutes les armes, il me dit ce qui va ce
qui va pas enfin il sait faire tout ça
et pourtant il passe pas le pas. Parce
que moi au départ quand il me dit ça
très vite sous la tente quand je le vois
dans la prison, je me dis mais le gars
va voilà j'ai j'ai le compagnon idéal.
Moi j'ai foiré j'ai foiré mes évasions.
Je suis pas capable de tirer un coup de
feu, machin et cetera.
Tu as pas foiré tes évasions.
Bah la dernière c'est c'est plutôt mal
terminé.
Ouais mais il faut il faut être quand
même sacrément burné pour pouvoir faire
ça.
Ouais enfin moi c'est plus au niveau du
résultat que je me situe en fait. C'est
c'est plus si ça marche parce que tu es
dur avec toi-même en général. Non
euh
non j'ai la remise en question facile
mais après dur je dirais pas ça mais
là-bas je l'étais forcément parce que
les conséquences elles sont euh Et euh
ton pote Sudf
et ben lui il a une formation militaire
et euh et pourtant non.
Pourtant non, il voulait même que je le
cache. Eux non, on ne savait pas qu'il
avait une le voyait comme un infirmière
médique mais il savait pas qu'il avait
une formation militaire. Et lui n'a pas
passé le pas dans les occasions qu'on
aurait pu avoir et cetera parce que il y
a l'après, si vous arrivez à faire ça
déjà, c'est énorme. Et après, vous êtes
chez eux, on est à peut-être 60 70 km du
premier petit village ou campement.
Qu'est-ce que vous faites ? Qu'est-ce
que vous faites ? Et non,
non, non, non, non.
Donc donc voilà. Donc non, j'ai pu le
fantasmer. Ça va durer un temps et puis
après ça ça va disparaître.
Deuxème année.
La deuxème année c'est différent. La
première année on découvre, on teste, on
n'est pas au courant, on n pas
l'habitude. La deuxième année, on a
testé, on a découvert. Euh
tu es plus malade, tu es moins malade.
Comment ça se passe là ?
Non non, ça ça dépend de la bouffe. Le
gros problème, c'était les les moutons
très gras. La graisse nous rendait
malade, elle nous faisait gerber. Vous
avez des moutons qui étaient très très
grailles, vraiment beaucoup de graisse,
rien que l'odeur nous nous nous mettait
en osé. Euh la deè année, je je
comprends mon environnement, je
comprends ces gens-là, je connais leurs
habitudes. J'ai tenté de m'évader, ça
n'a pas marché. Euh j'ai pas de porte de
sortie, je peux plus m'évader, mais il
faut que j'en crée une autre. Et cette
porte de sortie, ça va être déjà
d'observer beaucoup, mais d'avoir un pas
de passe droit, mais que les choses se
passent mieux pour moi. Et c'est là où
va arriver le Coran justement. Je vais
accepter ce je vais pas le lire parce
qu'on me dit de le lire. Je vais le lire
parce que ça me donne énormément
d'informations sur eux. C'est leur mode
d'emploi, il s'y réfèrent tout le temps,
c'est leur guide, c'est leur code de
vie. Le connaître, c'est d'une part déjà
mieux les connaître et puis pouvoir
aussi parce qu'il y a des débats
possibles, des discussions possibles
avec le un peu le haut niveau ceux qui
parlent français. Et je je me rends
compte que je me fais baller dans ces
débats là. Je suis aussi que bon j'ai
pas lu, j'ai pas lu la Bible, rien. Je
suis un savoir vraiment basique et même
si j'essaie d'argumenter, je vois que ça
tient pas quoi. Et en lisant le Coran,
je lis la même chose que et je peux
c'est mon but au départ trouver des
failles. J'ai voilà générer des débats,
des questions couper.
C'est tu as enquêté, tu as fait du
reportage sur du djihadiste, tu avais
pas lu le Coran.
Exactement.
Non mais tu es un touriste, toi.
Je l'étais.
Non, déconner.
Non, non, c'est vrai, je pas j'avais pas
eu le Coran de tout. Mais limite c'était
pas moi j'étais là pour rapporter les
rapports de force sur le terrain, le
village qui avait été qui avait été
envahi, les exactions, le nombre de
victimes, ce genre de choses-là. Mais je
pense qu'il y a
Tu t'es dit en face c'est une armée
comme une autre. Tu t'es pas dit c'est
une armée religieuse.
C'est pas une armée, c'est un groupe
armée. C'est un groupe armé. Eux ils se
considèrent pas comme une armée
euh alors
l'armée de Dieu.
Oui. Les soldats de la foire. Oui.
Ouais, c'est vrai.
Comment ils disent ? Les soldats
soldats de la foire. Ah ouais
bah ils sont sur le sentier d'Allah. Ils
ont pris les sur le sentier d'Allah. Euh
ouais. Non mais j'avais pas lu le Coran.
J'en avais pas Non, j'avais pas lu le
Coran du tout.
Et là j'ai l Tu l'as lu parce que tu
avais que ça à faire et que tu t'es dit
c'est une bonne clé pour les infiltrer.
Je le lis alors ouais c'est vrai. Je le
lis d'abord. Je le lis parce que je veux
être pas au même niveau queeux, mais je
veux comprendre ce qu'ils disent et je
veux pouvoir objecter, je vais pouvoir
argumenter, je vais pouvoir trouver des
failles. Euh et parce qu'au bout d'un
moment euh parce que je veux lire aussi
mais je me rends compte rapidement qu'en
le demandant parce qu'on a j'ai passé un
peu ça mais j'ai eu un premier Coran qui
j'ai été dépossé ce Coran parce qu'il y
a des alertes, on bouge, on laisse les
affaires telles qu'elles sont, vous
partez et cetera. C'est moi qui vais
demander cette fois-ci le Coran. Et en
demandant le Coran, il y a un changement
de leur côté dans leur tête. Quelque
chose s'active du style bah tiens, il y
a peut-être peut-être qu'on peut le
sauver celui-là. Peut-être qu'il va
prendre la bonne voie. On va peut-être
aussi l'accompagner dans cette voix làà
donc forcément on n'est plus voilà ça
c'est c'est ils sont ils sont contents
de ce qui se passe. Ils veulent m'aider,
ils veulent me guider ce que j'ai besoin
et cetera. Il y aura d'ailleurs un cadit
qui viendra souvent. Je passerai des
heures avec lui me montrer des vidéos,
m'expliquer et cetera et cetera. Et moi,
je vais lire le Coran. et je vais euh je
vais me m'absorber dedans. Surtout dans
la partie avant les textes religieux, il
y a la biographie du prophète, il y a le
contexte euh politique, les relations
entre les différents euh dans dans
l'Arabie de l'époque. Enfin, ça ça me
passionne. Je trouve ça génial. C'est
comme si je disais un livre d'histoire.
Cette partie-là va beaucoup m'intéresser
et je trouve qu'elle donne aussi à
comprendre ce qui se passe après dans
les textes, notamment dans la vie du
prophète, le fait qu'il ait perdu euh
tous les enfin, il a eu des filles et à
chaque fois qu'il y avait des garçons,
ces garçons l'amour. C'est c'est ça
précède le le moment où il va comme ça
er où il va devenir une sorte de par
quelqu'un qui voilà et je trouve ça très
intéressant. Moi je le connecte
évidemment mais voilà ça enfin tout ça
pour dire que ça suscite des questions
chez moi et que je que je leur pose
quoi. La musique par exemple, j'ai pas
j'ai pas lu dans le courant.
Cheval sur la lune séparé en deux choses
comme ça.
Ouais enfin le paradis aussi beaucoup
les Vierges.
Voilà les Vierges. Mais
alors il y a combien en fait ? C'est
combien de Vierges ?
Euh il y a pas de nombre non. Bah pas
dans le Coran. Il y a pas marqué 77 ou
je sais pas quoi. Il y a pas il y a pas
de nombre. Bah
je sais pas. Bon, en tout cas, moi je
pose des questions de ce que je n trouve
pas. Il y a pas l'interdiction euh sur
la sur alors sur l'alcool, c'est spécial
euh l'alcool au départ ou pas ?
Bah euh c'est spécial. Au départ,
c'était autorisé et après ça a été
interdit. le Coran le dit quoi. Donc
c'est je crois devant voilà
en fait ce que je comprends rapidement
c'est qu'il ne faut pas qu'il y ait un
quelque chose qui qui puisse vous
écarter de la voix voilà de la foi quoi.
Et l'alcool évidemment est un est un
quelque chose qui peut vous écarter de
la foi.
Quoi d'autre ?
Euh sur les femmes beaucoup j'ai posé
beaucoup de questions sur les femmes,
sur le paradis notamment, c'est-à-dire
queon a une description de comment ça se
passera au paradis. Donc les les hommes
seront comme ça habillés en verre, on
leur viendra leur des femmes de regard
chasse avec des longsux viendront leur
apporter des boissons. Il y a les les
rivières de lait et cetera le date.
Et moi je me suis demandé mais comment
ça se passe quand on est marié de son
vivant ? C'est une question que j'avais
par ex mais ils étaient ils étaient
super étonnés de de ces questions. Tu
vois ça trop
toi tu es pratique toi. C'est ça.
Ben ouais mais je me demandais je me
demandais mais comment ça se passe ?
Est-ce que les ceux qui ont été mariés
de leurs vivants se retrouvent sur ses
sur ses sièges et sont service par les
ouristes ? comme ça qu'on les appelle
voilà à côté de son mari, c'est il y a
le mari évidemment qui est servi par
cette femme au regard chasse et sa femme
est à côté ou est-ce qu'il y a un
paradis alors est-ce qu'il y a un autre
endroit pour les femmes où elles ont le
pendant masculin peut-être pas avec les
cheveux longs enfin bon je chercher des
tas de trucs comme ça je chercher des
tas de des tas de failles pour voilà
des failles chez eux ou dans le Coran
des des failles non le Coran étant la
référence ils disent des choses faut que
je les trouve dans le Coran ou quand je
comprends pas ça me semble un peu
orienté dans le Coran il faut qu'il
m'explique C'était surtout ça. Et euh et
vous il voit rapidement que j'ai
beaucoup de questions, certaines
questions, les collent, ils ont pas de
réponse. Ils disent "Mais bon, au bout
d'un moment, OK, on va t'amener
quelqu'un, on va t'amener un grand imam
du djihad et puis il va il va être
capable de répondre à toutes tes
questions."
Alors, je te pose une question entre les
deux.
Est-ce qu'ils ont essayé de retourner ?
Ils ont essayé de pas de me retourner
mais de de faire en sorte que je me
convertisse. J'appellerais pas ça
retourner. J'ai pas
que tu te convertisses ou que tu te
convertisses avec leurs objectifs
pour pouvoir ensuite te réenvoyer en
Europe.
Ça c'était un sujet de débat par
exemple. Je dis mais c'est très bien
parce que je sentais qu'il voulait que
je me corrige mais moi je dis je voilà
il y a il y a il y a le Coran, il y a
l'islam. OK, pourquoi pas ? C'est une
décision que je prendrai moi. Je
pourrais pas la prendre. Tant que j'ai
une chaîne he c'est impossible. Enfin la
conversion ça va être très très
compliqué si j'ai une chaîne mais
justement si tu te convertis la chaîne
c'est finie tu es comme nous tu mange
comme nous tu es tu es accepté c'est
fini
et leur dit non non non moi je vais y
aller de mon plein de mon plein gris si
je fais un pas vers Dieu c'est moi qui
le fait et pas parce que j'ai été
kidnappé et parce que ça peut être une
sorte de porte de sortie comme ça et
cetera. Donc ça c'était le c'était le le
premier point. Et l'autre chose aussi
qui était
qui me
qui me posait problème, c'est qu' comme
je disais au bout d'un moment, il
pouvait pas répondre à mes questions. Il
y avait pas ça s'arrêtait quoi. Jusqu'au
bout qu'à un moment où je vais
rencontrer quelqu'un, une éminent, je
sais pas encore qui c'est dans le
désert. Ça c'est le début de l'année
2022 et qui est là pour répondre à mes
questions et je le sais pas encore quand
je lui parle. C'est le numéro 2 de
l'organisation qui s'appelle Sédana
Guitar et qui est d'abord là pour
répondre à mes questions et puis après
pour euh pour sur les questions
religieuses et pour après euh répondre
aux questions plus larges que je
pourrais avoir par rapport à ma
captivité.
Sur les questions religieuses, c'est
parce que ils te l'ont fait venir parce
que tu commençais à mettre le doute chez
tes joliers. Ils te l'ont fait venir
parce que il allait avoir des réponses à
ton questionnement.
J'ai pas mis le doute chez mes jeuners.
J'ai pas mis le il y a un moment ça me
fait penser la question me fait penser à
ça avec R on était sous la tente il y
avait Abdou Jabar je me souviens le nom
il venait souvent nous voir le matin et
on a eu un débat sur les dadosis sur ce
qu'ils font sur la croyance et cetera
il parlait français
euh il se débrouill en français et et au
bout d'un moment on sait pas pourquoi il
se lève et quitte la tente et sort
parce qu'on argumentait on argument et
je crois que ça je sais pas il voulait
plus nous entendre Il fallait plus qu'il
nous entende, c'était la parole des
coufards devenait trop, je sais pas,
trop intense, trop forte et il quitte.
Il a ça nous avait super surpris quoi.
Comme si ça ça avait été trop loin, il
pouvait plus écouter ce qu'on disait.
Le numéro 2, l'iminence grise.
Elle se reconnaît, elle se reconnaît
pas. Elle se reconnaît par rapport à la
différence de tes jolies autour. Elle se
reconnaît parce que l'accoutrement est
différent.
Elle a un petit livre avec un chapelet.
Comment ça se passe ? Non, il y a tout
un il y a tout un processus pour
m'amener là-bas. D'abord en moto, après
on prend un pickup, on arrive dans une
zone, je me souviens des articles, je
vois qu'il y a il y a pas les renforts
mais ils sont ils sont plus nombreux. On
met au milieu comme ça un tapis et on me
dit que quelqu'un va venir, on me met
une bouteille d'eau et on me dit de
patienter là. Et cette personne arrive.
Alors moi j'étais quasiment sûr parce
qu'on en avait parlé avant c'était ce
grand imam du djihad qui venait répondre
à mes questions. Je reconnais pas la
personne puis j'avais vu très peu de
photos à l'époque. Je viens de c guitar
puis je l'ai pas
cabar qui va bien.
Oui, il y en a une mais pas l'hyperatose
ou pas ?
Non non des lunettes aviator ça m'avait
marqué un basin lila couleur lilèche
gris.
il s'assoit et puis c'est après les la
séquence religieuse, les questions
religieuses qui me dit "Bon, tu as
peut-être entendu parler de moi, je
m'appelle Sédita et puis là alors là
évidemment le nom dit quelque chose.
J'ai écrit là-dessus, je je le situe
dans la hiérarchie de l'organisation et
je suis super étonné que ce soit lui le
grand imam et qui vient répondre à mes
questions. Et ça en suscite évidemment
chez moi sur ma captivité, sur beaucoup
de choses. Et on va euh on va converser
un peu. il va m'apprendre des choses qui
sont assez euh
qui qui m'ont fait Ouais. qui m'ont fait
tomber sur les sur le cul à l'époque.
Ouais. Ouais.
Genre
alors il faut faut revenir à l'avance.
C'est un peu compliqué. C'est expliqué
dans le bouquin. C'est un peu d'ailleurs
comment il s'appelle le bouquin ? Un
prisonnier du désert 700 jours au main
d'Alqedaïda. Et j'ai été gardé pendant
15 jours. La fameuse le fameux
djihadiste. Alors il y a plusieurs
choses avec ce djihadiste qui va déjà me
donner une réponse négative par rapport
à la lettre que j'ai envoyé qui va me
dire faut attendre un délai de 5 6 mois.
se trouve va être en fait l'assassin des
deux journalistes de RFI, la personne.
Moi, c'est une question que je pose à
beaucoup de deadistes qui me qui me qui
me gardent et et c'est un sujet que j'ai
voulu aborder avec lui et c'est le sujet
sur lequel il veut pas répondre. J'ai
été proche, j'ai vécu pendant de
semaines avec cette avec l'assassin sans
savoir que c'était lui en fait. Et ça,
je l'apprends donc un an plus tard dans
le désert de de la bouche du numéro 2 de
l'organisation parce qu'il a été tué
quelques semaines après qu'il m'est
laissé un autre groupe. On est resté 15
jours ensemble. euh par les forces
françaises et euh et puis donc là c'est
le choc quoi. C'est comme si j'avais une
quête et que j'étais à côté de la
solution, à côté de la la personne même
qui a été impliquée et que il
il les a tué comment les journalistes en
question ?
Ils ont été ils ont été fusilés. Ils ont
été fusilés. Ils ont été exécutés. Et
donc déjà il m'apprend ça, il m'apprend
qu'il est mort. et m'apprend ça. Euh, il
y a un autre personnage complexe aussi
qui aurait conduit le véhicule lorsque
j'étais à Gao, le véhicule qui qui va me
kidnapper euh qui lui aussi a été tué.
Je la prends quelques semaines
auparavant avant le rendez-vous avec ce
numéro 2. Et puis j'ai quelques
informations sur des tractations avec
les Français et pour moi et pour RERT.
Et j'ai aussi, il me donne à ce
moment-là une photo de de mes enfants
qu' a eu comment ? Euh alors il sépend
pas là-dessus, il l'a eu et il me dit
"On va faire une vidéo rapide pour
répondre mais cette vidéo n'est pas pour
ta famille, elle est pour ton
gouvernement et on va faire une vidéo où
tu vas"
C'est le gouvernement français qui a
filé la photo au djihadiste.
C'est pas ce qu'il dit mais il me dit
"On va pas cette cette vidéo n'est pas
pour la famille, elle va être
La photo en question, elle datait de
longtemps. Elle était sur quel support ?
photo photo papier hein, tu as dû être
imprimé sur un papier photo, une vraie
comme comme du papier photo quoi. Euh
photo que j'avais pas vu, c'était mes
enfants après euh après que j'ai été
kidnappé et euh et donc je fais une
vidéo en plein désert avec lui je crois.
Donc on est en Ouais, c'est la tr avant
novembre. Ouais, c'est ça. C'est la
trisème vidéo. Il en aura quatre.
Combien de temps la vidéo ?
Oh, c'est c'est jamais plus d'une
minute.
Une minute ?
Ouais. Ouais, faut dispenser le message
qu'il faut dispenser. Je m'appelle
Olivier Dubois, je suis détenu par un
tel. Euh il faut s'il vous plaît faire
quelque chose pour moi et cetera. C'est
toujours à peu près le même message.
Disp 90 secondes, une minute maximum.
On a vu la vidéo du moins une.
Tu trembles, du moins tu gigotes de la
jambe.
Ouais. Des non des mains ou de la jambe
peut-être, je sais plus.
La première c'était Oui. Oui. C'était un
c'est un un moment marquant parce que
c'est
à partir de cette vidéo, je sais que
tout ça devient voilà, ça devient c'est
ça va être diffusé partout, ça devient
public. mon erreur euh ce qui se passe,
quelle erreur ? Bah
l'erreur d'être tombé là-dedans,
te faire goer.
Voilà. Et puis ça va entraîner ma
famille, ça va entraîner le
gouvernement. Enfin, on rentre dans un
truc qui me dépasse moi. Limite je
m'en sortir de mon côté, ça va. Mais là,
ça prend ça ça dépasse à mesure. Ça
prend des proportions de dingue qui me
qui me dépassent totalement. Et c'est
vrai que j'étais très très anxieux à ce
moment-là, même si j'essayie de pas le
montrer lors de cette première vidéo.
Revenons sur ta conversion. ou du moins
l'envie qui te qui te du moins leurs
envies de te pousser vers les bras de
Allah. Tu as penser à te convertir après
? Pas du tout. C'était une lecture.
Moi moi j'ai moi j'ai pensé évidemment.
Bah oui, c'est bien. Euh il faut faut
revenir peut-être aux évasions, enfin et
aux discussions que j'ai pu avoir avec
me dit "Nous, on tue pas les musulmans."
Alors je leur donne ça. C'est arrivé
dans le cadre des interview que j'ai pu
avoir avec certains et je leur dis "Mais
non c'est fou, j'ai des exemples. Vous
avez tué des t musul ah oui ? Mais ceuxl
ce sont, tu parles certainement de
soldat, tu parles d'un mère, d'un
village, un truc comme ça. C'est des
gens qui ont épousé la constitution
malienne, qui sont du côté du
gouvernement malien, qui suivent les
lois maliennes. Il y a que la loi de
Dieu. Donc pour nous, ils sont hors
islam. Donc nous pouvons les tuer. Bon,
OK. Et mais sinon, ils me disent, on n'a
pas le droit de tuer les musulmans. Donc
moi, dans les évasions, je m'évade, je
me fais attraper. On me dit qu'on va me
zigouiller. Donc je me dis peut-être que
après avoir observé, avoir bien voilà,
être bien prêt à m'évader, faut
peut-être que je me convertisse. Comme
ça, si je m'évade et que je me fais
attraper, je meurs pas. Ça me fait une
sorte de bouclier. Je pense par exemple
comme ça.
Tu perds un pied quoi.
Voilà. Je me dis aussi euh si je suis
vivant et que la chose s'éternise 5 6
ans 7 ans, bah peut-être que je me
convertis pour pouvoir être libre. Et si
si je suis libre, ils me disent "Tu
auras une tante, tu auras des bêtes, tu
auras même une femme si tu veux, tu
auras un véhicule et un cascof pour
protéger ça." Bah peut-être que dans ce
moment-là, alors je pourrais me faire la
belle plus facilement. Donc la
conversion, elle arrive pas avec une
volonté de se convertir parce que je je
je sucombe au discours. Elle vient comme
possibilité soit de protéger ma vie,
soit de faciliter une une évasion.
Revenons au tout début. Le monsieur qui
pensait que tu étais un agent secret ou
un honorable contributeur, il t'a posé
quoi comme question ? Avec quelle
fréquence, quelle cadence ? Il est
revenu combien de fois de poser les
questions ? Il est venu avec des choses
étayant sa position. Pas du tout.
Comment quand ça s'est passé ?
Ça a dû durer trois fois. C'était pas
des questions mais des accusation. Je
sais que alors le bureau la des photos
de moi avec des leaders euh de groupe
armé euh et puis tout ce qu'on pouvait
lui dire de qui pour désinformer. C'est
arrivé trois fois comme ça des c'était
des accusations, c'était sûr, une
certitude puis avec un regard de voilà,
on t'a percé à jour quoi. Euh il va y
avoir cet épisode où l'insulte part
malgré moi. Là, il va y avoir un froid à
partir de là, il m'a dans le nez, il me
parle plus. Enfin bon, voilà. Et c'est
lui qui va m'amener d'ailleurs à
l'assassin des des des journalistes de
RFI qui s'appelle Bay Gagbo. C'est lui
qui va me transporter à eux 15 jours. Je
suis resté combien de temps ? 3 semaines
3 semaines 15 jours après. Mais voilà,
il m'adressera plus la parole et ce sera
très très dur. On aura un échange
d'ailleurs assez assez acerbe, assez dur
dans la voiture au bout d'un moment où
il me dit, je me souviens très bien, il
me dit "Mais toi tu as un souci ?" Je
dis "Comment ça ?" Il me dit "Ouais, tu
as un souci ?" Je dis "Mais quel souci
?" Il me dit "Tu tu es pas un musulman,
ça c'est un souci." Je bah écoute euh
très bien, OK, pas de souci. Euh et euh
et je lui dis "Et toi, qu'est-ce que le
fait d'être un tu vois, d'être musulman
et d'être un djihadiste, comment comment
tu vis ça au quotidien par rapport à
enfin je lui rends le truc quoi.
Tu cherches la merde."
Voilà. Enfin, j'essaie de
Quand tu étais jeune, tu t'embrouillais
souvent à l'école ?
Pas plus que ça, mais enfin normalement.
normalement, mais l'idée c'est de
je c'est d'avoir un peu de contrôle
quoi, un peu de domination quand on peut
en avoir et c'est euh moi je tiens euh
parce que je fais du sport, parce que
j'ai d'être un journaliste, parce que je
j'ai des victoires, je fais une
meilleure tente. Voilà, j'essaie de me
mettre des challenges que je que je
résous, que je remplis et le soir quand
je reviens sur Manat, ça me conforte, ça
m'aide à traverser tout ça. et on essaie
d'avoir des phases de contrôle avec eux.
Euh, on en a pas parlé là, mais par
exemple une de ces phases de contrôle,
c'est l'humour. Euh, avec mon mon
codétenu, au bout d'un moment, on
comprend rapidement que ceux les
nouvelles les équipes qui arrivent,
elles ne elles ne vous connaissent pas.
Elles ne savent pas qui vous êtes, elles
connaissent pas mon nom. Donc, à partir
de là, on peut jouer avec le nom. Donc
c'est plus, c'est plus Olivier, c'est
plus tout ça. Alors, ils veulent du fric
pour moi. C'est un moment, je suis assez
plutôt en colère. Ils veulent du fric.
Donc, je me je dis que je m'appelle
Griezby, que je m'appelle Jean Larc, que
je m'appelle Anglais. Voilà, je leur dis
voilà je je leur dis n'importe quoi et
ça passe et tuappelles comme ça et ça
génère donc derrière chez nous sous cap
et on a l'impression d'avoir un petit
peu de contrôle.
Tu as pas ici je m'appelle Emmanuel
Macron ?
Non non non, il y aura il y aura des
discussions sur Macron qu'ils aiment pas
du tout
du genre. Pourquoi ils aiment pas ?
Ah bah Macron c'est le c'est le c'est le
chef le chef in commande c'est celui qui
a envahi la force française
l'envahisseur dans la région de K chez
eux c'est l'ennemi à combattre. C'est
l'ennemi numéro 1 et il y en a beaucoup
qui se gêneront pas pour me dire on va
on va aller le déloger, on veut le tuer
machin et cetera. Et dans cette notion
dans cette notion de contrôle justement,
moi j'imagine quand on me dit ça que ben
bonne chance quoi. Ouis. Et j'imagine
des scènes où sont éclatés par le
service d'ordre de Macron et cetera et
cetera. Il faut avoir un petit coup de
parchoc du GIGN quand même. Non,
bah ça devrait le faire mais je me dis
dans dans tous les cas, je le visualise,
je me le dis et ça me voilà ça me ça ça
me fait sourire intérieurement et j'ai
l'impression que parce qu'ils disent ça
pour me déstabiliser
quoi qu'il vont désinguer Macron.
Ouais.
Et toi tuéclates de rire et
ben allez-y je peux liser c'est là. Go.
Attends, tu l'auras pas fait au bout du
doigt. Les mecs c'est par là donc les
lissé c'est par là. Non non, j'ai pas
fait ça comme ça. Mais l'idée c'était de
OK, tu me dis ça. Enfin,
vous avez parlé de la mec,
fallait que ça rooche.
Vous avez parlé de la mec ?
Euh, pas plus que ça. Non,
ils ont pas fait le pèlerinage.
Ah, les c Non, alors le pèlerinage,
c'est compliqué. J'en ai pas rencontré
qu'on fait le pèlerinage. Alors, j'ai
pas posé la question à des haut niveaux,
mais le pèlerinage, ça coûte quand même
vraiment cher.
Comment tu sais ça
que ça coûte cher ? Oh, j'ai écris des
papiers là-dessus. Euh oui oui, on était
à Bamaco parce qu'il y a tout un
business avec les agents sur Bamaco.
Enfin pas qu'à Bamaco d'ailleurs qui
prévoit tout, l'hôtel, les prière où
vous allez aller, la bouffe, le
téléphone avec le for qui ça ?
Les agences
pour opérateur. Ouais.
Ah c'est c'est du privé hein. C'est du
privé ça. C'est du privé mais ils se
font énormément d'argent. Énormément
d'argent. Donc c'est pas de l'argent
qu'on ces gens-là dans le désert. Ils
ont pas l'argent pour faire ça. Mais ils
font limite plus. Ils sont sur le
sentier d'Allar. Ils ont pas voilà, ils
sont sur le sentier d'Allah, ils
contribuent
au rayonnement d'Allah autrement et puis
de façon de la façon la plus la plus
dure, ils combattent
la psychologie. Tuas alors même si tu
n'es pas psychiatre ou psychologue, tu
as essayé de voir l'arborescence de leur
raisonnement, ce qui les animait autre
que Allah, s'ils avaient des frères, des
sœurs, si maman était testé beaucoup de
fois parce que l'idée c'est d'essayer de
les comprendre. Moi, je voulais
comprendre comment un parce que c'est
des jeunes, c'est un peu des jeunes
comme les nôtres hein, ils écoutent de
la musique, ils adorent la musique mais
c'est pas la même musique, ils vont pas
écouter, je sais pas moi, Britney, ils
ont pas décalage quand même.
Oui, enfin, ils vont pas mais ils
adorent la musique. Ils écoutent
beaucoup de musique islamique, de champ
islamiques, de champ djihadistes. On
était saturé de ça. Ils ont des
speakers, ils écoutent ça. Ils se
comportent comme des jeunes. Donc moi ça
je voulais comprendre comment on peut on
peut basculer comment à cet âge là, moi
je me souviens d'avoir eu cet âge là,
comment on peut prendre les armes,
comment on peut être amené à tuer
quelqu'un pour une idéologie, pour un et
j'ai posé beaucoup de questions
là-dessus.
Moi ce que je comprends, c'est que ce
que j'ai compris en tout cas, c'est
qu'en gros,
c'est comme des super-héros.
Il y a pas de super-héros dans le
désert, c'est comme des super-héros.
C'est-à-dire que c'est mieux que d'être
un commerçant, que d'être un bandit, que
d'être un je un mercenaire, que de
vendre du lait de chameau, de la viande
de chameau. Déjà au niveau financier,
c'est mieux hein par les rançons, par le
par différentes voilà autres captation
financières et ils sont ils travaillent
pour Dieu. Ce côté soldat de la foi,
c'est reconnu par eux, mais c'est
reconnu aussi par
quand on est dans les campements, tu as
les gamins qui courent derrière les
motos, ils saluent, c'est comme des
stars
parce que ils donnent l'omone, parce
qu'ils ils assurent de la sécurité,
parce qu' ils redonnent du pognon des
rançons au village du coin. Quand
bah alors là, c'est remonté un petit
peu, faut remonter un petit peu en
avant. Faut pas oublier que le Mali
c'est un c'est un territoire qui est
énorme et le gouvernement n'a pas la
souveraineté. il peut pas fournir les
services de base sur tout sur tout le
pays. Donc vous avez des endroits dans
le nord, dans le centre, enfin loin de
Bamaco, vous n'avez pas de policier,
vous n'êtes pas de justice, vous n'êtes
pas de médecin, vous avez très peu de
choses et quand c'est là ça peut être
prédateur des fois. Donc c'est c'est
très compliqué. Donc il y a une sorte de
vide d'état et ce vide, il est comblé
par les groupes armés, il est comblé
notamment aussi par les jihadistes qui
eux se substituent par exemple à la
justice qui amène voilà, c'est concret
quoi. Donc ils ont pas la même image
qu'on peut en avoir nous. C'est pas la
même chose. Là où il y a rien, ils sont
là. Et c'est vrai que il y a pas il y a
beaucoup moins d'insécurité, c'est tenu
beaucoup moins de trafic aussi dans ces
zones-là. Euh donc ils sont Oui. Oui.
Ils sont restants.
C'est rassurant. En tout cas, ça vient
combler un manque. Il y a de la sécurité
pour eux.
Voilà. Et il y a une justice. Et cette
justice, elle est peut-être plus
expéditive, peut-être plus brutale, mais
elle fonctionne. On n'est pas tombé sur
un juge par exemple qui est totalement
déconnecté, qui vient de Bamaco et qui
va demander à un décamp de lui filer, je
sais pas moi, 100000 francs CFA ou plus,
enfin 100000 français C. euh je sais pas
un demi millillion de francs CFA ou plus
pour plaider sa cause et pour le rendre
le bon jugement et à l'autre va demander
deux fois plus pour il y a pas de ça
vous voyez il y a une voilà il y a c'est
c'est la loi islamique et elle est elle
est la même pour tous elle est rendue
comme ça et donc elle est elle vient
combler un manque et elle est acceptée
par ceux qui qui n'avaient pas de
justice qui en étit dépourvus avant
l'objectif leur objectif final il t'en
ont parlé
oui bah il est clair c'est l'objectif
d'Alqaïda global mais déjà eux en local,
c'est d'imposer la charia au Mali et
puis après
au Sahel et puis après encore plus.
C'est de toute façon,
il y a un seul dieu pour eux. Il y a un
seul dieu, une seule croyance. Il faut
la charia d'abord en Afrique, d'abord au
Mali, d'abord au Sahël et cetera. Mais
c'est que la la charia soit partout. Il
y a qu'un seul Dieu. Il faut que la
planète se rende compte qu'il n'y a
qu'on ne révère qu'il n'y a qu'un seul
Dieu.
Et Mahomet son prophète.
Et Mahom est son prophète.
Comment ils sont financés ? Mis à part
avec les rapines d'otage ? Il y a la
zacat. Euh alors c'est le une sorte de
taxe d'impôt on va dire qui prélève
notamment sur les sites d'orpaillage par
exemple. Il y a le
de béton
le vol de bétaille
dans les sites de béton aussi. Non la
taxe
de béton
non vois pas. Et
c'est plus vers la Syrie.
Ah d'accord. Et et voilà. Bon pour pour
ce que j'en sais c'est ça
principalement.
Là, on arrive 2e année.
Ouais, on est début de la 2è année.
2è Noël.
Euh
ouais,
35000 games chiass
euh il y en a eu pas mal. Il y en a eu
pas mal. Tu t'es pas fait piquer par les
scorpions ? Pas de morce.
Les petits ou les gros ?
Alors, les plis, c'est c'est les plus
les plus douloureux.
Ouais.
Et il y a le les ados. C anneaux, ça va.
Six anneaux, c'est mortel. Le mieux en
avait cinq.
euh douleur infemme et puis ça remonte,
c'est comme un pic de glace. J'ai
l'impression d'avoir un pic de glace qui
progressivement remontait à l'épaule et
on m'avait on m'avait dit que quand le
pic de glace si s'il atteint le cœur,
bon ben c'est fini quoi. Donc vous
passez une nuit voilà graduellement
estimer l'avancée sans compter la
douleur et vous espérez que ça s'arrête.
Je s'arrêter à peu près là. Mais vous
avez un bras totalement kilosé,
douloureux avec une sorte Ouais, c'est
ça. Une sensation de glace douloureuse à
l'intérieur de moi.
Tu parles les anneaux de la queue ou les
anneaux du ventre ? Non, les anneaux de
la queue. Les anneaux de la queue et des
scorpions, il y en a partout comme des
serpents. C'est un miracle que j'ai été
d'ailleurs piqué qu'une seule fois parce
que je vais dormir dans des endroits où
euh je les vois, je les entends puis
c'est une c'est une rapidité le scorpion
c'est très très rapide quoi. Et euh ça
va ça va m'empêcher de dormir des nuits,
des nuits, des nuits entières. Après, on
développe des contesures. C'est pour ça
que je parle d'adaptation. Enfin, je
dire c'est que ça les contesures au bout
d'un moment parce qu'il y a pas que les
scorpions. Là, on parle des scorpions
mais des tas de choses sur le sol et
dans l'air. Et les contesures, c'est par
exemple retrousser son pantalon assez
serré, mais vraiment très serré au
niveau du moulet, au niveau des bras
et puis bien fermé au niveau du cou,
mettre la couverture jusque là pour pas
que ça rentre et que si quelque chose
vous grimpe dessus, le fait que vous
ayez les pantalons retroussés, vous
allez sentir sur votre peau et vous
pouvez intervenir tout de suite quoi. On
était des vrais détecteurs, on était
ultra sensibles aux infrarouges. Je veux
dire, un truc nous montait dessus. On
était tout de suite tout de suite en
réflexe. Tout de suite.
Il y a eu des morts pendant que tu étais
séquestré. Donc
de leur côté. Ouais,
de leur côté. Mais
ouais. Des gardes qu'on a eu, des
joliers qu'on a eu. Il y en a un que
j'appelle Trench Coach qui avait
toujours un long trench coach genre
Colombo qui va mourir dans la zone de
Talataille dans des combats contre
l'État islamique. Ouais. Euh oui oui, il
y a eu il y a eu des pertes. Il y a eu
des pertes parce que
niveau otage. Non.
Alors nous on est deux euh nous on est
deux. pas pas nous en tout cas et on on
commence à comprendre en 2022 justement
qu'il y a d'autresages autour de nous
par quand les les rations viennent le
pickup est encore plein quand il repart
donc on n'est pas loin on comprendra
après par des discussions qu'on est pas
loin du chef qu'est-ce que ça veut dire
pas loin soixantaine centaines de
kilomètres du chef qu'on est autour de
lui en fait hein euh ouais voilà
2è Noël
bah 2è Noël la la même volonté de de
marquer le coup en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne
et puis un événement un peu un peu
différent euh pour le deuxème Noël euh
une volonté de la part de Rert parce qu'
commence commence à en avoir gros sur la
patate, ça fait longtemps qu'il est là
et lui contrairement à moi, il n'a pas
il reçoit pas de message à la radio de
sa famille et ça ça ça porte sur le
moral et au moins je lu dis écoute il
faut créer l'événement quoi. Il faut
créer l'événement, c'est-à-dire qu'on
va, il faut leur demanderement, faut
inventer une stratégie pour que tu
puisses être amené quelque part et
passer un coup de fil et avoir ta
famille ou du moins communiquer. Et
l'idée qui se met en place, c'est de se
dire de leur dire "Écoutez, ça fait
longtemps que je suis là, vous n'avez
pas été capable de négocier ou de me
vendre. Laissez-moi vous aider,
laissez-moi passer des coups de fil, je
parlerai aux personnes qui seront
capables de rassembler de l'argent pour
que vous puissiez me libérer. C'est on
part sur ce postulat là, sur cette ce
scénario là et et ça va marcher. Ça va
marcher. Ça va mettre un peu de temps
mais ça va marcher. On veut dire "OK, il
va être amené, c'est prévu dans un coin
où il pourra passer." Il en a passé
trois de coup de fil. On avait répété
ça. On a fait des jeux de rôle. Il y
avait le coup de fil à l'ambassade, je
me souviens, parce que c'est dans un
c'est dans un c'est pas c'est pas on
parle pas pendant une heure hein, il a
une minute pour exposer un un discours
pour pour dire ce qui se passe. Donc
c'était l'appel à l'ambassade, l'appel à
sa femme et puis les scénarios
l'ambassade répond pas, sa femme n'est
pas là avoir d'autres numéros. enfin
essayer de voilà euh de de parer à à
tous les obstacles qui pourraient
arriver et de déployer un discours euh
clair clair et euh voilà clair et
précis.
Tu l'as revu ce monsieur ?
Ouais, on s'est revu après sa
libération. Il a été libéré en décembre
2023 et on se verra en c'était en avril
je crois juste avant que je rentre dans
l'écriture du livre. Je voulais le
revoir parce qu'on en a rêvé qu'il
vienne en France que moi j'aille le voir
en Afrique du Sud et puis pour voilà
échanger sur ce qui nous est arrivé
parce qu'il y a ma perception il y a de
la sienne
un bouquin à deux mains.
Je il voulait non lui il voulait pas
forcément écrire puis il avait
l'impression je pense que c'est ça que
mon bouquin était un peu le sien dans le
sens où c'est une histoire commune sur
un an et demi hein. J'étais que 5 mois
tout seul. Donc en gros, alors je sais
pas si le livre sera traduit en anglais,
je pense pas mais il a il a toujours pas
lu le le livre, même si jeen ai parlé,
même si on a vécu l'histoire ensemble,
donc il sait ce qu'il y a dedans. Mais
mais j'aimerais beaucoup qu'il le lise.
Si le bouquin est traduit en anglais.
On arrive vers la fin de ton ta
détention.
Ça se réchauffe, ça se réchauffe pas.
Ils te font comprendre que
ça arrive de façon euh totalement
impromptu. Enfin, je veux dire, je je
moi la veille
la veille euh le 6 mars, si je me
souviens bien au soir, j'écoute la radio
comme tous les soirs et j'entends que le
journaliste Wassim Nastre a interviewé
Alanabi, chef d'ACMI, grande voilà et
bon très bien et qui pose la question.
Il lui pose la question, il dit "Mais
alors quitte d'Olivier du Bois,
qu'est-ce qui va se passer ?" Et Annab
répond à ce moment-là, la balle est dans
le camp des Français. Moi quand je
reçois cette cette information, je me
dis merde, alors il y a pas euh il y a
rien ou alors il y avait des
négociations mais ça s'arrêtait mais il
y a rien qui est engagé quoi. Je prends
ça plutôt mal. Le lendemain matin,
quelques heures après, il y a un pickup
qui arrive sur le camp avec le le chef
de zone et deux autres jihadistes qui me
prennent à part et qui me font écouter
un document audio sur leur téléphone
portable. Et c'est dans ce document
audio que j'apprends qu'on me dit écoute
inchallah dans 14 jours si tout va bien
tu vas être libéré. C'est la voix de
Sona Guita, le numéro de l'organisation.
Le
dit en français.
Le dit en français et euh alors faut que
je rétriale un peu. L'autre truc qui me
faisait tenir aussi c'est d'obtenir
quelque chose qu'on peut pas obtenir
c'est-à-dire et que j'ai demandé dans ma
première lettre. C'est une interview du
chef de l'émire du grand chef. Et je
m'accroche à ça et je reviens à la
charge pendant 2 ans là-dessus. Et ça se
débloque qu'en novembre 2022 via un
message dont je ne sais pas au départ
que c'est le message du chef. Je pense
que c'est le message du chef de zone et
ce message dit écoute si d'aventure tu
es libéré avant ta libération nous
accepterons de répondre à tes questions.
Et euh et donc la fin du message c'est
la Nagita de l'audio, c'est bien sûr
nous allons respecter ce que nous avons
dit prépare peu de questions. Pas de
questions longues sur vous les français,
les journalistes français vous faites
des questions super longues, des
questions courtes, une dizaine, pas plus
et nous y répondrons.
Je je demande à réécouter le message que
j'y crois pas. il il
bouleverse le j'ai envie de dire la
carapace, l'armure que je me suis je me
suis créé aussi dans le sens où c'est
formidable. C'est c'est c'est un rêve
qui se concrétise. Et en même temps, je
sais pour avoir lu ça, pour avoir traité
de ces sujets que de nombreux otages ont
dit qu'on leur avait on était venu les
voir et qu'on leur avait annoncé mais
écoute jeudi prochain mon coco, tu sors
tout va bien. Et je me demande si c'est
mon tour là. Enfin, je veux dire en gros
est-ce que ça m'arrive pas à moi ? Et
ça, c'est le genre de truc qui peut me
m'ébranler totalement. Je peux j'arrive
bon moment là à traverser ça et à
résister et un truc comme ça ça peut me
me mettre un coup à la mâchoire et je
tombe au sol ou quoi. Donc je vais y
croire sans trop y croire et c'est très
compliqué. Et il rajoute ça à la fin. Il
me dit "Écoute ce qu'on vient de te dire
là, ce que tu as écouté, tu n'en parles
surtout pas à ton compagnon et tu n'en
parles aussi, ça m'étonne un peu plus,
surtout pas aux gardes des gardes. Ils
ont pas à savoir ça." OK ? Et la
troisème la troisième chose tout de
suite qui me pose comme question, c'est
"Est-ce que tu vas rentrer en islam ?
Tout de suite ?"
Rentrer en islam en conversion,
est-ce que tu vas te convertir ? Et euh
je ressors mon mon excuse que j'ai déjà
sorti auparavant qui est non, j'ai
encore des questions euh la chaîne,
voilà. pas pour tout de suite. Non. Et
euh bon, je suis une déception, il me
regardent, regarde lourd, tout ça. OK.
Et ils partent. Donc c'est comme ça que
vient l'information. Et selon moi, je je
ne vais pas euh pouvoir interviewer le
chef. Je
par que tu étais pas converti.
Je pense que ça a joué parce que
plusieurs fois quand je demande à
interviewer le chef, on me dit "Mais
écoute Olivier, tu es pas musulman,
c'est impossible, il faut être
musulman." Et moi, je trouvais ça
totalement. Je dis "Mais alors n'importe
quoi si je fais euh euh si je fais un je
sais pas moi un reportage sur les
homosexuels, est-ce que je dois devenir
homosexuel ?" Enfin c'est c'est idiot.
Je peux poser ça.
Ah oui enfin je j'essayie de donner des
exemples. J'essay de donner des
exemples. Je c'est pas voilà mais bon
pour eux c'était une condition puis moi
ça me posait problème enf qu'est-ce
qu'on aurait dit d'un journaliste qui se
convertit et qui interview enfin c'est
n'importe quoi. Enfin voilà et donc ça
ça passait pas. Donc euh je pensais je
pensais que ça ne se ferait pas et puis
après il y a eu ce message et en gros
quand je leur dis que je me convertis
pas, je çaaborde mes chance de
l'interviewer. Mais ils vont avoir quand
même à cœur de répondre à mes questions
et c'est le numéro d'eau qui va le faire
et qui va venir avec une sorte de
surprise inattendue. Il va venir avec le
le chef d'adit que je devais interviewer
pour lequel j'ai été kidnappé. Abdallah
Galbaka qui sera là lors de cette
interview.
Tu poses toutes les questions que tu
veux ?
Non. J'avais une trentaine de questions.
Toute la partie Glen du Poncou de
Verlon, les deux journalistes de RFI
Sabré veulent pas il veulent pas en
entendre parler. La partie on va dire
les questions qui parlent un peu trop de
leur organisation, de comment ils sont
organisés et cetera et cetera beaucoup
sont sabrés. Les questions plus
génériques, ils y répondent. Ce qui a
l'avantage qui a pu avoir, c'est le off.
C'est-à-dire que ces dernières guitare
parle français mais pas très bien. Abdah
Gbakal ne parle qu'arabe. Donc en gros,
je dois dire lentement les questions à C
guita qui les dit en arabe à Abdah
Gabaka qui les écrit quoi et eux après
partiront, ils répondront, ils me
donneront ça sur une carte une carte SD.
Donc OK, très bien, j'aime pas du tout
le procéder mais je dit très bien ce
qu'on va faire pour être sûr que vous
répondez aux bonnes questions, on va se
dire je vais vous donner les questions
et cetera. Et le fait de donner des
questions comme ça avant, ça permet de
de faire l'interview, de faire une sorte
de préinterview euh nature avant qu'il
ait le temps de réfléchir et de
l'écrire. Donc j'ai euh j'ai eu des
réponses sur certaines des questions que
je n'avais pas le droit de poser lors de
ce off, on va dire, ou des
confirmations, on va dire. Ouais.
Quel DIP ? Bah moi c'était c'était
beaucoup de les questions que je voulais
le gros en fait le noyau de mon
interview c'était ce qui sait comment
pourquoi
les deux journalistes de la fille ont
été tués. Voilà c'était c'était vraiment
savoir ça et j'avais des questions
autour
meublé
pour chauffer comme on dit on balance
jamais ses ces meilleures question
qu'est-ce qui t'a qu'est-ce qui t'a
sorti ? Qu'est-ce qui t'ont sorti ? il a
il a confirmé mais là cette fois-ci donc
venant d'un d'un haut niveau, ce que
j'avais entendu un peu en posant la
question durant ces ces les derniers
mois, les les deux dernières années.
C'est-à-dire qu'en gros une intervention
française les a poussé les aurait poussé
euh à supprimer à supprimer les deux
ootages.
Donc donc voilà donc on a pu j'ai pu
comme ça voir et puis moi j'écrivais des
notes, je prenais des notes en secret
donc dès qu'on s'est séparé je écrit ce
j'essayé d'écrire en maximum ce que je
pouvais. Tu as fait des notes pendant
tout ton
Ouais ouais
sur n'importe quel type de support
quand il alors le coup de je peux avoir
un stylo parce que je peux avoir du
papier quand ça marchait pas bah c'était
sur du support des emballages des choses
comme ça tout ce que je pouvais trouver
pour écrire du carton
c'était ça quoi.
Tu es libéré ? Il te l'annonce la veille
le l'avant veille. Non non, je suis je
il m'annonce alors oui voilà c'est ça.
Il m'annonce 14 jours avant que je vais
être libéré par un message audio.
Commence un décompte un compte arbour
qui est qui est comme une torture parce
que je sais pas si je dois y croire ou
pas et je dois rester à flot le jour. Je
fais quand même le décompte. Le jour le
14e jour où ils doivent sont censés
venir me chercher. Ils viennent au
matin. Il y a une moto qui vient le
matin mais c'est pas moi qui viennent
voir c'est mon collègue Rert à qui on
dit de prendre une couverture et une
bouteille et puis il partent. Et à ce
momentlà, je me dis non de Dieu, ils se
sont peut-être trompés quoi. Ils se sont
peut-être trompés. Je reverrai par Erte.
La dernière fois où je l'ai vu
d'ailleurs, je l'ai vu 24 heures avant
moi-même d'être vier c'est le lendemain.
Lend matin, il y a une moto qui vient
pareil pour moi cette fois-ci. Et là, on
va rentrer dans le processus qui va
m'amener à la libération, qui va durer 4
jours euh où il y a des déplacements, on
est rejoint par une trentaine de gars en
armes, prêt à en découdre. C'est des
placements longs. Ils suivent une sorte
d'itinéraire sur leur téléphone. Il une
carte avec des points rouges, je me
souviens. Et on attend, on continue.
Voilà, ils sont sur le qui vivent
beaucoup. L'un d'eux me dira d'ailleurs
ouais, on sait pas, on est quasiment sûr
qu'on peut t'amener au lieu de
rendez-vous, mais on sait pas comment
nous on repart après. C'est dans le sens
où on sait pas si notre sécurité ne va
voilà quand on repart après
et ça va durer 4 jours. Je vais être je
vais être mis en présence. Je vais je
vais rencontrer pendant ces 4 jours
l'otage d'un otage américain qui lui est
là depuis 6 ans qui s'appelle Jeffrey
Woodki qui a été cassé par sa captivité
euh physiquement mais aussi mentalement.
On va passer ces ces ces 3 jours 4 jours
ensemble avant d'être libéré du côté
nigérien
le 19 mars le 20 mars 2023. 19 mars
2023.
Donc ça se passe comment ? qui t'emmène
dans un camp, il y a une tente, il y a
les Français de l'autre côté, il y a les
ballons qui t'attendent avec Salut
Olivier. Comment ça se passe ?
On monte dans un il y a deux pickup. un
un pickup qui nous amène à la frontière,
un autre qui traverse à toute à toute
allure
et on on file on file et au moment nous
avent prévenu, au moment où le mec nous
dit de sortir, on doit s'éjecter du
véhicule et puis lui il fait d'embarder,
il repart tout de suite. Et c'est ce qui
se passe. On se retrouve on se retrouve
dans le désert et tout de suite au loin
à quelques centaines de mètres, on
aperçoit des uniformes de militaires
français et c'est le le premier symbole
de la liberté, hein. Alors, avant que tu
continues cette description,
l'Américain était cassé
intellectuellement, physiquement,
émotionnellement parlant. Il avait
il avait des tocs. Comment ça se passe ?
Non, il boit, il est pas en bonne santé,
il peut pas s'asseoir tout seul, il a
coutume de faire la greffe de la fin
pour avoir ce qu'il veut. Donc il a
recours souvent. Euh, il s'est pas mal
fait péter la tronche.
Il il est cassé, il est cassé dans tous
les sens du terme. Il a pris un vrai
coup de vieux et euh il a plus trop
d'espoir non plus au moment où on se
voit, il jusqu'au bout euh jusqu'à ce
que l'avion, le transporteur vienne nous
chercher dans le désert, il ne croit
pas. il pense que tout peut s'arrêter,
que les jihadistes peuvent revenir nous
attaquer et il va euh il va réaliser
qu'il est libre quand on s'envole, quand
on est dans les airs en route pour Niamé
et puis là il y a les émotions qui vont
sortir et il va il va pleurer pendant
une bonne partie du du du trajet.
Donc revenons un petit peu à Romobinon.
Là tu es éjecté de ton de ton 44 avec
barbu 1, barbu 2 qui fait demi-tour pour
éviter de te faire désinguer la tête.
Tu vois des des
uniformes français en face, ils te font
passer dans une tente.
Non non, il y a pas de tente, ça se fait
à l'extérieur.
Tu dois te déshabiller, pas déshabiller.
Est-ce qu'il vérifie que tu portes du
plastique sur toi ? Pas du plastique.
Tu dois mettre tes affaires dans un sac
poubelle parce qu'il y a de l'entrax sur
toi, pas d'entrax. Tu pues tellement la
mort que vaut mieux mettre ça à brûler.
Alors puer, ça c'est clair. Euh on a
juste avant ça, pendant 2 ans, Pugnette
ou pas Pougette la étoile ?
Non, il faut garder les questions de
fond. Les questions de fond, je
comprends.
Ouais, question de fond toujours.
Euh non, non, pas de poette. On est
entouré de mecs, on a rien qui qui il y
a il y a rien d'excitant. Je donne une
petite anecdote comme ça. On avait donc
des boîtes de lait qui venaient
d'Algérie la plupart du temps. Sur cette
boîte de lait, vous avez une famille
tout sourire qui est heureuse de prendre
son petit- déjeuner euh ensemble et dans
les paquets qu'on nous qu'on nous
donnait, il rayit la tête de la femme
pour donner une idée
pour éviter la père.
On on était on était entre mecs. On
était entre mecs tout le temps. Tout le
temps. Il y a une scène d'ailleurs. On
va on est on est avec Rert,
on est on est allongé sur le sable. Et
je sais pas. Bon, il y avait beaucoup de
bergers autour de nous et puis on voit
une une femme voilée orange avec un
voile orange comme une bourcame orange
qui se lève comme ça. Elle nous voit, on
la voit, on est interdit, on est
stupéfait parce qu' c'est pas quelque
chose qu'on voit souvent, on quasiment
jamais. Bon, moi j'en avais vu une dans
un petit village quand j'étais dans
cette petite mesure dont j'ai parlé et
je me souviens qu'elle elle nous voit
semble pas du tout choqué, elle se
tourne
et elle part au ralenti. Enfin, dans ma
tête, elle part au ralenti quoi. Elle
disparaît comme ça au ralenti comme un
comme un mirage c'est tellement enfin
c'était tellement enfin tellement
imprévu, tellement dingue. Euh donc
c'est pour dire donc on n pas il y a pas
il y a pas de
Ouais. Euh non, il y a pas de pignett.
Revenons revenons aux uniformes
français. Donc de loin, ils te disent
"Levez les bras, pas lever les bras."
Salut Olivier, est-ce que tu es chargé ?
"Tu es pas chargé ? Il y a du plastique
sur toi ? Tu t'as une bombe ? Comment ça
se passe ?"
Non, nous par réflexe évidemment, on les
voit. Donc je dis "Ça y est, on est
libre. On voit des uniformes français,
on se dirige vers eux." Donc
là, tu as la bebarde de 3 m de long.
Ah non, moi j'ai pas de bear, ça on en a
pas parlé.
Rert il l'a. Moi, je la coupais et je
prétextais que j'étais quelqu'un qui
avait pas beaucoup de poils et que ça
poussait pas.
Alors ça c'est ça aussi c'est aspect
contrôle
et donc on les voit et eux nous arrêtent
direct il nous nous crie non stop stop
et puis on on avait pas remarqué il nous
montre une plateforme
une plateforme avec une sorte de
séparation et deux sacs poubelles dans
chacun des coins. C'est comme une sorte
de box mais c'est pas couvert quoi. Et
il nous dit vous allez là vous vous
déshabillez et vous mettez toutes vos
affaires dans le premier sac. à côté du
premier sac, il y a un second sac avec
des fringues neuves et vous vous prenez
les nouveaux fringues, vous vous
habillez et vous venez vers nous. Donc
on fait ça là il te surveille ou il te
surveille pas ?
Ah ben il nous surveille bien sûr, ils
nous disent de le faire et puis nous
voit. Enfin, je veux dire c'est le
désert, c'est plein. Vous avez ce truc
là un peu artificiel comme ça qui est
planté au milieu. Donc on est un peu
surpris, on y va, on se on se dessape.
Moi, j'ai mes j'ai mes j'ai mes notes
sur moi que j'ai réussi miraculeusement
à faire sortir et je dis mais c'est pas
possible, je vais pas laisser ça dans le
sac. Je j'étais quasiment enfin je
pensais pas pouvoir les sortir
miraculeusement. J'y arrive et je dis
non non mais j'ai un truc à apprendre
avec moi. Il me dis c'est quoi ? Je dis
c'est des notes, c'est des choses que
j'ai pris des photos de mes enfants. Ils
hésitent et tout puis je me dis mais
merde j'ai réussi peut-être à sortir ça
de là-bas et jeis peut-être ne pas
pouvoir les amener avec moi. Et bon ok
euh voilà viens avec on change donc on
se dessappe, on met les nouveaux
vêtements. Les nouveaux vêtements sont
trop petits évidemment ils connaissaient
pas nos mensurations. Moi j'avais un
pantalon qui m'arrivait à mi cuis
renseignement français.
Ouais. Alors, je sais pas si on peut
dire ça comme ça, mais en tout cas
vêtement trop petit. C'est l'ambassade.
Je crois que c'est passé par
l'ambassade. C'est quelqu'un d'ambassade
qui avait fait les courses la veille ou
quelques jours avant. Et euh donc on on
marche, il faut imaginer quand on a des
vêtements petits en dans leur direction.
On est dans le désert, ils sont deux. Il
y a un dispositif, c'est clair. Il y a
des des 44 qui cadrent. C'est vraiment
des 44 qui sont là comme si on était au
centre d'un carré en fait, je me
souviens de ça. Et il y a un médecin qui
est là, je pense un médecin des forces
spéciales, il a un appareillage qui
permet de d'écouter le cœur, de de de
l'attention, tout ça. Enfin, on a une
sorte de checkup comme ça rapide dans le
dans non non
non pas ce checkup là. Euh, on a on a un
checkup rapide dans le désert.
Coprologie.
Non non non, pas du tout. Non non non
non. tous les jours et euh et on fait ça
après. Je me souviens, ils ont ils ont
été très sympathiques, ils nous ont
donné des cacahuètes, ils nous ont donné
à boire. Voilà. Euh
attends attends attends, ça fait 2 ans
que tu es en prison avec Barbu Barbu et
les gars, ils te filent des rations de
combat de cacahuète avec du Tang
de Ouais, c'était du enfin des jus mais
c'était fantastique. Enfin
ouais, c'était fantastique.
Cit fantastique. Et puis
même pas une petite bouteille de dompé
frappé.
Faut bien comprendre qu'on est on est
bêté. On est voilà, c'est c'est on passe
d'un monde à l'autre quoi. C'est c'est
vraiment spécial.
Et euh bon mon compagnon Jeffrey lui
comme je disais, il croit pas, il
regarde, il est à la fu il regarde
autour de lui et puis on leur dit mais
comment on part ? Moi je pensais qu'on
allait partir en voiture, je savais pas.
Il me dit non non, il y a un avion qui
va venir nous nous chercher. Je dis mais
un avion mais il va atterrir où ? Et
montre là ah je sais pas je sais pas 150
m 200 m de nous.
Et on attend 45 minutes, ils nous
mettent sur à l'ombre d'un d'un des 44
et en effet, il y a un gros porteur qui
arrive qui se pose alors comme une
tranquillement dans le désert. Ça crée
une véritable petite tempête de sable.
Le ventre s'ouvre, des militaires
sortent en armes et puis et puis c'est
bon, on monte à l'intérieur.
Euh l'avion nous engouffre et puis et
puis c'est parti, on s'envole. C'est la
fin.
C'est pas la fin. Ah c'est la fin pour
moi. C'est la fin.
Mais non
tu arrives à Véizi Villacoublé.
Ouais mais ça ça compte pas pour moi ça.
Non non attends. Tu arrives à Vilisi
Vila Coublé tu as été pris en charge
quand même.
Oui oui. Quand je dis c'est la fin pour
moi c'est la fin de la captivité. Je
sors du désert.
Ah oui bah oui je suis mais la captivité
dans ta tête elle est tout de suite
passée une fois que tu étais dans dans
le Transalpe.
Comment ça ?
Une fois que tu étais dans l'avion c'est
passé tout de suite. Où est-ce que tu as
traîné ? Tu as fait des cauchemars après
?
Ah non non.
bien quand je dis c'est fini pour moi,
je suis extrait de là. Je je suis dans
les mains de la France, je suis libre.
Je je vais je vais arriver dans une
ville dans un endroit qui est sécurisé.
Je vais certainement voir dans quelques
jours, dans quelques heures ma famille.
C'est la fin d'une d'une séquence qui a
quasiment voilà qui a duré quasiment 2
ans. Je suis en sécurité. Contrairement
à mon compagnon, je sais que je suis en
sécurité. Je sais que c'est fini. Je
sais que c'est fini.
Tu arrives à Visi ?
Alors pas tout de suite mais le
lendemain. Ouais le lendemain.
Qui est-ce qui t'a fait ton débrief ?
On le fait pas le premier jour. C'est
pas le premier jour. Ça arrive quelques
jours après.
Qui ? Comment ? Où ?
Ah le débrief, il a lieu avec les
services français évidemment
dans leurs locaux je sais pas 3 qu jours
après. 3 qu jours après ou à chaud. J'ai
encore tout ça est très très clair dans
ma tête. Ils sont à combien ? Ils t'ont
demandé quoi ?
Ils sont à combien ?
Il y avait encore des cacahuètes à deux
balles sur la table.
Non, pas des cacahuètes à de balles. Euh
là aussi très bien reçu. Un véritable
repas, une sorte de une sorte de buffet.
Puis on s'installe et puis les les cass
futes évidemment ils sont ils sont vides
de connaître un peu ce qui j'ai vu, ce
que j'ai vécu, les endroits où j'ai été.
On essaie de passer ça au crible. Il y a
la fatigue mais les souvenirs sont là.
Ils sont encore bah ils sont encore
vivaces dans mon esprit et j'essaie
d'être d'être clair évidemment dans dans
ce que je leur dis quoi.
Est-ce qu'ils sont ils sont venus avec
un trombinoscope ?
Oui, évidemment vous avez le
trombinoscope. Euh il y a Oui, oui,
évidemment. Évidemment parce qu'on vu
passer en autant de temps, on voit
passer énormément de gens quoi.
Combien de temps tu es resté dans leur
bureau ?
Je crois que la première fois ça a été
toute une après-midi.
Euh ouais. Je suis arrivé un peu avant
le déjeuner puis j'ai dû partir en fin
d'après-midi. Ouais.
La deè fois. Ouais, la deuxième fois
pareil, ça a dû être je crois deux
après-midis, je crois qu'il y a eu trois
fois comme ça où vraiment voilà, il
fallait dégorger tout ça hein puis
revenir parce que forcément ça suffit
des questions, des compléments
d'information, des choses comme ça.
Vous avez un doute sur ta stabilité ? Ma
stabilité mentale, je en tout cas je
l'ai pas senti.
Est-ce qu'il t'ont est-ce que tu as
senti des questions intrusives du genre
ils t'ont retourner tu t'appelles
machin machin d'après le Coran, d'après
ce que tu nous as dit ? Est-ce qu'ils
t'ont donné un objectif à faire péter en
France de recruteur de par recruteur ?
Non non non non, il y a pas il y a pas
eu de question de direct comme ça mais
il y a
alors je sais pas si la valeur je sais
pas si on peut dire ça valeur de test ou
quoi mais quand j'arrive il y a
l'hôpital il y a a les médias et puis
après je me retrouve dans la la
résidence de France enfin dans
l'ambassade de de France au Niger et se
trouve que c'est euh l'anniversaire
c'est le jour ma libération coïncide
avec le jour d'anniversaire de
l'ambassadeur en place à l'époque. Donc
il y a du gâteau,
des rochers
aussi et du champagne. et du champagne
et on me tend une coupe de champagne et
je bois une je bois une ou deux coupes
de champagne ce jour-là. Je suis très
rapidement pété parce que j'ai pas bu
d'alcool depuis très très longtemps. Il
y a un mec de la DG qui arrive
sa valeur enfin sa valeur en tout cas ça
montre que j'ai pas voilà.
Non ça montre rien du tout.
Mais ça montre que je bois de l'alcool
donc déjà je suis pas musul les mecs ils
sont fait péter le 11 septembre ils
buvaient de l'alcool il se niifaiit ils
avaient des buts. Ça s'appelle la takia.
Alors c'était pas mon cas pour le coup.
J'ai juste vu ça comme un bon gâteau et
puis et puis du et puis du champagne,
quelque chose qui change, du lait en
poudre, la tadila et de la viande
séchée, c'est surtout ça.
Revenons au débrief.
Ils t'ont dit combien on a payé pour te
faire sortir ?
Non mais non, ça ça reste totalement
opaque.
Tu as demandé au moins ?
Bah j'ai pas j'ai pas demandé parce que
c'était pas vraiment ce qui m'obubilait
hein. Moi c'était plus voilà. Moi je
quand je suis sorti cette histoire, je
l'ai mise dans un petit coffre, je
voulais plus entendre parler. J'avais ma
famille, il fallait que je me consacre
totalement à eux. J'en avais tellement
rêvé. Alors après les je les les les la
négociation, évidemment que ça va
m'habiter mais plus tard. Évidemment que
c'est des questions, il y a pas mal de
questions d'ailleurs que je me pose.
Mais à ce moment-là,
quelles sont les questions que tu te
poses
à ce moment-là ? Mais il y en a des tas
évidemment. Pourquoi ? Comment, via qui
j'ai été trahi, comment les choses se
sont faites. Enfin, c'est c'est des
questions évidemment. Moi, j'ai un
puzzle qui est pas complet. Le récit du
bouquin, c'est le récit de la captivité.
C'est pas le récit d'avant. Euh et
d'après quoi. Donc il y a il y a desah
après je connais je dire mais d'avant
évidemment qu'il y a des tas de
questions qui restent en suspend. On en
parlait un peu au début.
Qui c'est qui t'a balancé ? Tu sais pas
?
Ah je pense que c'est je pense que c'est
mon fixeur mais c'est c'est des
questions qui restent ouvertes. Je ne
sais pas. On sait pas
ton fixeur parce qu'ils ont fait
pression sur le fixeur ou le fixeur
voulait prendre du pognon.
Je pense qu'il voulait prendre du pognon
mais ça c'est pas
com depuis combien de temps tu le
connaissais ?
Ça arrive 2018.
2018.
Tu connaissais sa femme ?
Non, je n'ai entendu pas. Je connaissais
pas. J'ai pas vu son enfant. Il a un
enfant, j'ai pas vu sa femme.
Tu es déjà allé chez lui ?
Non, lui est venu chez moi.
Et et euh et donc
et donc c'est quelqu'un qui pouvait
venir chez moi, qui pouvait repartir sur
Qu'est-ce qui te l'a présenté ?
Euh, je l'ai je Il y a pas eu de
présentation. C'est quand on quand on
fait on fait ce métier, évidemment, on
suit les réseaux sociaux, on suit des
comptes et tout et cetera. Puis je vois
c'est une photo en fait. Je vois une
photo sur Facebook, quelqu'un dans le
nord du Mali qui prend des des malades
sous un arbre. Il y a des intraveuses,
des poches de sérum et puis tu as des
malades sous un arbre comme ça, comme un
hôpital sous un arbre. Et la photo me
saisit, j'ai nom de Dieu et puis j'ai
pris tout de suite la personne qui a
envoyé ses photos et je trouve que c'est
lui. Je dis mais comment ça se fait ?
C'est c'est ça, on le voit souvent.
C'est il a oui, c'est plutôt fréquent.
Puis on commence à discuter. Je dis mais
tu es où ? Tu es basé où ? Ah ouais, tu
vas dans ces zones-là. Alors très bien.
OK. Est-ce que je peux me permettre de
te rappeler machin ? Est-ce qu'on peut
et puis commence petit à petit
à une relation des échanges qui vont
faire ça va devenir petit à petit une
sorte de de capteur, quelqu'un qui me
renseigne sur ce qui se passe
et et vu différemment si si tu devais
penser contre toi-même,
tu as connu un brouteur sur Facebook qui
postait sur les réseaux sociaux des
trucs qui pouvaient faire marrer ou lui
donner de l'importance. Euh
euh tu t'es fait fixer mais pas dans le
bon camp. Hm
hm.
Parce que tu es
ça va mettre du temps tout ça.
Ah oui,
c'est pas c'est pas un bon de ce de
cette photo à on a on a vécu des choses
ensemble.
Fait hamçonner par ton broteur.
Est-ce que en école de journalisme ils
t'apprennent à un petit peu à être
méfiant ? Euh
tu as grandi dans quelle ville ? Il y a
beaucoup de questions là. Moi j'ai j'ai
grandi dans le sud de la France. Enfin,
d'abord à Crété et ensuite dans dans le
sud de la France. Mais pour revenir sur
ce que tu disais, est-ce qu'on nous
apprend en école de journalisme à
détecter et cetera ? Moi, j'ai pas fait
de d'école journaliste, j'ai fait un
mentorat. J'étais directement formé par
un par un journaliste
qui s'appelait
Claude Marcilin euh recherchier
journaliste canadien québécois. Euh
c'est quelque chose qu'on apprend au fur
et à mesure ça euh à pouvoir voilà
détecter quelque chose, sentir ensuite
son instinct quand on fait ce métier là
et puis quand on est sur le terrain. Euh
après, il y a il y a une relation qui
est plutôt longue. Il y a des échanges
longs. C'est quelqu'un qui j'ai déjà
travaillé, c'est quelqu'un qui m'a
ramené des informations de qualité
aussi. Euh
donc il y a pas la méfiance. Combien
temps ? En combien de temps ? C'est de
2017 jusqu'à
2018 jusqu'à 2021 puisque c'est en 2021
que
18 19 20 21 3 ans 100 millions d'euros
sur 3 ans ça fait combien par an ?
Ça fait un peu plus de 3 millions mais
euh
c'est un investissement le brouter hein.
Est-ce queil y a est-ce que tu as
prévenu tes tes copains journalistes que
lui était potentiellement vérolé ou
qu'on a fait pression sur lui ? Est-ce
que est-ce qu'en sortant de ta
captivité, tu as placardé euh sa tête
sur ton ta page Facebook en disant euh
il va peut-être pas bien ou tu as essayé
de le reconacter ?
Alors il y a il y a beaucoup de choses.
Il y a dans cette histoire de toute
façon un excès de confiance. Un accè
un excès de confiance. Mais oui, de ma
part concernant mon mon fixeur, je l'ai
carence de doute.
Ouais, enfin bon, tout les pens mais je
veux dire en gros euh en gros voilà je
je ne pensais pas pour être ha par lui,
je lui faisais confiance quoi, hein. Et
c'est pour ça d'ailleurs que je lui fais
confiance pour organiser ce rendez-vous
et cetera. Enfin voilà.
Tu fais des sports de combat mais est-ce
que tu fais des sports extrêmes ?
Non.
Tu as déjà fait du parachute ?
La plongée sous-marine en profonde ?
Non.
La couture
à mardi soir ? Ça arrivé
entre une soirée torware et et un un
meeting journalistique.
Exact. Exact. Non non, je suis pas de
sport extrême mais pourquoi la question
? Quel rapport quand même.
Bah tu confies ta vie à un gars que tu
connais à peine que tu as rencontré sur
Facebook de en 3 ans.
Tu es journaliste
h
tu travailles dans une zone de
pseudoerre ou de guerre.
Tu as jamais été chez le gars. Tu
connais pas sa femme ? Tu sais pas où
crèche son gamin pour pouvoir le
kidnapper et le couler dans le béton ?
C'est pas c'est pas ça. C'est pas
Ah si ça d'un point de vue et c Je me
fais l'avocat du temps. Oui
oui. Non mais je comprends mais moi je
répond quand je t'écoute quand je
t'écoute mais c'est un c'est un touriste
de bleu bit.
Ouais. Alors là tu là là
avant avant ta captivité.
Non, c'est pas peut-être mais c'est une
relation qui s'est bâtie en 3 ans. On a
on a vécu une histoire qui était assez
compliquée dont j'ai parlé dans trois
articles dans le point qui est une une
tentative de libération de Sophie
Patronin qui je pense est le ferment.
C'est ça qui soude le truc. Et oui oui
certainement il y a mais de toute façon
si on pouvait prévoir à l'avance quand
est-ce qu'on va être trahi la personne
qui va nous être qui va nous trahirir ce
serait fantastique si on savait tout à
l'avance. Au bout d'un moment, quand
vous décrétez que vous faites confiance
à quelqu'un parce qu'il y a eu des
événements, parce que voilà, il y a des
échanges, bah vous lui faites confiance.
Euh
tu veux pas avoir un un un autre une
autre perception du genre si lui il me
trahit, je coule sa femme, son gamin,
son grand-père, toute sa famille dans le
béton puis je le fais doucement.
Mais c'est marrant, tu vois quand je
quand je me rends là-bas,
tu t'es tu es retourné là-bas ? Non,
quand je me rends là-bas, quand j'y vais
pour cet interview, je me pose pas du
tout la question de la trahison de de
mon fixeur. Je suis pas du tout
là-dedans. Je suis omnibilé par toute
autre chose. Je suis omnibelé par le
fait de pouvoir réussir cette interview,
de faire de revenir avec les
informations que je veux ramener. C'est
ça qui m'omnibule. C'est pas tellement
le le truc. Après évidemment, il y a des
considérations par rapport à la
sécurité. Évidemment que je me dis que
ça peut mal, ça peut ne pas marcher et
cetera. Il y a un moment de bascule mais
du moment qu'on le fait, on peut pas se
triturer. Mais si, on peut pas, c'est où
on le fait à fond, on refuse de le
faire.
Je lui fais confiance, j'accepte de le
faire, je le fais
et se passe ce qui se passe. Je me pense
pas à sa fille, à une vengeance ou quoi
que ce soit. Sinon, ça veut dire que je
suis pas dedans. Je le fais pas. Si si
je me dis ça, je reste à Bamo, je bouge
pas. Ça m'est déjà arrivé de partir avec
des fixeurs. Je leur fais confiance.
Quand quelques mois, moi avant, je fais
la même chose dans une milice. Euh,
évidemment que ça passe par des fixeurs,
çaon.
Ouais, ça passe par un fixeur. Ça passe
à quelqu'un qui les connaît. Ça passe.
On doit en plus. Enfin, c'est dangereux
d'aller là-bas et euh mais je je je fais
confiance à la personne, il y a un
facteur risque. Personne ne m'oblige à
aller là-bas. Maintenant, si je veux
ramener cette information, si je veux
faire ce reportage, je le fais. Après,
c'est moi, je le fais ou je le fais pas.
Mais je pas durant tout le processus où
je le fais me triturer l'esprit, euh
angoisser machin et ca on peut pas
bosser comme ça. Personne nous demande
de le faire. Je peux le faire au
téléphone alors
c'est après le risque zéro n'existe pas.
On va pas dans ces coins là si on pense
qu'il y a un risque zéro. Enfin, le
risque zéro dans ce type là n'existe pas
et la preuve, il s'est passé ce qui
s'est passé.
Donc Visi Villacoublet, le débrief de la
DGSE,
tu les rencardes un petit peu sur ce que
tu as vécu, tu leur as dédicacé ton
bouquin depuis.
Évidemment, je dois dire ici quand même
que euh
voilà, je suis très reconnaissant à ces
services, à la France en général, au
gouvernement de m'avoir sorti de là,
mais très très reconnaissant.
Et euh
bah oui ou oui c'est c'est enfin
est-ce que tu vas dire merci Macron ?
Mais on peut dire je peux dire merci
Macron je peux dire merci au service
parce que c'est réel il faut il faut il
faut faut faut bien
il y a aucune j'ai pas d'étiquette
politique. J'ai pas c'est pas une excuse
que je vais trouver ou c'est pas mon
paravant pour pas dire merci c'est pas
possible. J'étais prisonnier de
djihadistes. Ça a duré quasiment 2 ans.
Mon gouvernement, le président en place,
les fonctionnaires qui sont sous ses
ordres, les services me sortent de la
l'armée. Le Niger aussi, il y a pas que
Je ne peux que dire merci. Je peux que
dire merci. Je suis là devant vous. Je
suis vivant. Je peux voir mes enfants.
Évidemment.
Tu es retourné au Mali ou ils t'ont dit
"Tu vite ?"
Non, non, je pas retourné au Mali.
Non, ils t'ont dit "Tuvite."
Bah, évidemment qu'on pas
t dit "Tuvite l'Afrique."
Ouais. Puis moi, je savais que je devais
je devais l'éviter aussi. Enfin, je veux
dire pour moi déjà quand je reviens
enfin je dire vous imaginez quand même
je revois mes familles, je revois mes
parents, je je revois ma mes enfants, je
dis bon ben ok ciao dans 2 semaines j'y
retourne. Non non
ta mère elle te tue ?
Bah je sais pas si elle me tue mais
enfin elle a pas eu besoin de me tuer en
tout cas parce qu'il y avait déjà une
conscience. Enfin je sais d'où je venais
quoi. C'était pas l'urgence du moment.
L'urgence du moment c'est de se
reconstruire c'est d'être avec sa
famille puis essayer de
Tu as essayé de reconacter ton fixeur ?
Non
même pas.
Non, j'ai pris des renseignements
évidemment. J'ai pris des renseignements
parce que j'ai
Tu as pris des renseignements par quel
intermédiaire ?
Bah par les miens, par mes contacts.
J'ai des gens qui connaissent. Qu'est-ce
qu'il fait ? Où il est ? Et cetera et
cetera.
Il y a Olivier qui te cherche. Non.
Tu as demandé s'il avait changé pas
s'il avait changé de voiture, s'il a
fait un de plus à sa maison. L'idée
c'est au départ, enfin l'idée c'est pas
c'est même pas une idée. Le réflexe
c'est quand on sort de ça, c'est
derrière nous.
le bouquin, le fait d'écrire le livre,
évidemment ça remet l'histoire sur scène
et on l'a dépi et on l'a des cryptes et
tout pour pour pouvoir écrire mais
c'était que sur la captivité donc elle
le concerne pas. Évidemment, c'est une
conséquence de ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est que sur la captivité donc non
maintenant comme je l'ai dit c'est un
puzzle qui n'est pas complet. Il y a des
pièces qui manquent et j'ai l'esprit
assez chagrin évidemment pour pour
vouloir en savoir plus parce que les
questionnements restent là et je veux
qu'il partent ces questionnements.
Tu en as vendu du coup de bouquins.
Je sais pas, j'ai pas le retour des
chiffres mais
marqué ton compte en banque
c'est important ou
ça se passe pas comme ça. On a une
avance et puis après on règle ça un an
après la sortie. Donc
la valoir combien ?
Ah ça je vais pas le dire. La valoir
combien ? une certaine somme, une somme
certaine
10000 balles, 12000 balles, 30000 balles
proche de la fourchette dont tu as
parlé. Peut-être la première
10000 balles,
je sais pas.
Est-ce que la DGSE t'a demandé de tenir
ta langue un certain nombre de mois
après ta sortie ?
Tenir ma langue sur quoi ?
Sur ta captivité. Si tu si tu avais
dessigné des des désigné des cibles le
temps de leur laisser faire le ménage.
Est-ce que ils sont repartis chercher
les djihadistes qui t'avaient
Non non non.
Il est clair que
les services sagent qu'on va aller
devant les médias et qu'on va raconter
ce qui nous est arrivé. Ils t'ont pas
dit surtout tu dis pas qu'on a lâché 100
millions.
Mais non, on a pas parlé du sous
d'argent mais ce que je veux dire par là
c'est que c'est vrai qu'il faut pas non
plus il faut voilà tout tout engarder.
Il faut pas non plus trop en dire parce
que il y a pas que le il y a pas que le
public français qui regarde.
Donc ils peuvent voilà. Bon après il y a
un livre qui est sorti. Alors
évidemment, je raconte exactement tout
ce qui s'est passé, mais voilà euh ils
se corrigent aussi. Euh donc évidemment,
ils sont voilà, c'est une recommandation
plus un conseil quoi.
Quand tu te retrouves à discuter avec
tes collègues qui ont un peu plus de
bouteilles ou un peu moins de bouteilles
qui connaissent la région, nous nous on
a un pote qui est reporter de guerre
américain.
Ouais. qui a fait le
Morovia à la belle époque, tu sais, là
où il y avait des crânes qui roulaient
un peu partout, des mecs qui avass la
méchette tout le temps,
qui a qui a bourlingué un peu partout en
Afrique.
Toi, est-ce que tu as eu des mentors
bourlingueurs ? Bon, ça on le sait. Mais
maintenant que tu as un peu plus de
bouteilles, est-ce que tu discutes avec
les jeunes ? Je leur dis bon bah la
prochaine fois ton fixeur tu essayes de
repérer où il habite, combien il a
d'enfants.
Mais OK sur le je vois que tu es très
focus sur la famille comme si c'était
une sorte de paravant à danger.
Non mais la famille du fixeur.
Oui. Non justement
le mec qui te présente son gamin,
il va réfléchir à deux fois avant de te
[__] dans la merde.
Je suis pas sûr.
Non mais pas du tout. Je peux je peux
avoir rencontré sa femme, je peux avoir
je sais pas partager du coca ou un
gâteau, être à l'anniversaire et cetera.
C'est pas ça le truc. Du moment c'est
c'est crapuleux. du moment qu'il veut me
traduire pour de me me trahir pour de
l'argent, il le fait, c'est tout. Il le
fait, c'est tout. Il se dit pas d'après
moi, hein, il se dit pas donc je vais le
trahir, donc il va être kidnappé mais il
va être libéré donc il reviendra me
siment la gueule. Non, c'est pas ça du
tout.
Non non non. Mais non mais non, il un
peu pas de compte. Ça rentre pas de
compte.
Il va faire un virement western unionon
de 3000 balles et il va mettre un
contrat sur la tête.
Moi je pense que c'est plutôt une pensée
à court à les maximum moyen terme. Je
vais me faire de l'argent. en le en
permettant à notre groupe de le prendre
qui va me c'est ça. On est on est dans
un truc comme ça.
D'accord. C'est c'est je pense que c'est
juste ça. Après que j'ai vu son cousin,
son machin et cetera, du moment qu'il a
envie de le faire la je sais pas si tu
t'es déjà pensé sur les les autres
otages. C'est des histoires comme ça qui
se sont passées. C'est une trahison des
gens qui connaissaient très bien. Ça
s'est souvent passé comme ça.
Qui connaissait très bien comme toi avec
ton fixeur.
Oui. Ou alors Ou alors quelqu'un avec
qui travaillait, quelqu'un qui était un
ami de la famille. Je pense aux Italiens
qui ont été kidnappés quasiment la même
période que moi. C'est c'est crapuleux.
c'est il y a il y a de l'argent, il y a
quelque chose et entre
euh ouais entre sa vie, sa famille et et
un occidental, un français, ben c'est
vite fait, c'est vite dit. Je sais pas,
peut-être que ton fixeur, il s'est fait
euh il s'est fait menacer.
Et menacé par qui ? Bah par les mecs qui
lui ont dit voilà tu freilles trop avec
le français là qui parle beaucoup qui
pose beaucoup de questions. Soit tu nous
dis ou tu nous le mets dans le bon 44 à
la bonne heure soit parce que nous on
sait où tu habites, on sait comment
s'appelle tes gamins.
Attention.
Bah c'est possible. Peut-être qu'il a
été sous présent, on s'en sait rien.
C'est c'est les pièces du puzzle dont je
parlais qui sont manquantes. Je ne
connais pas sa version. Je ne sais pas
pourquoi il l'a fait, avec qui, comment
ça, je ne sais pas.
Donc après, c'est la porte ouverte. On
peut dire "Oui, c'est possible."
les jeunes journalistes, tu tu as dû
forcément aller dans des écoles de
journalisme pour prêcher la bonne
parole.
Tu as dû aller voir ton syndicat pour
prêcher la bonne parole et ainsi de
suite. Tu les as trouvé comment les
gamins en face et tu les as trouvé
comment dans ton syndicat ? Ils sont ils
sont un petit peu affutés ou il ils
sortent tous c'est des léou ils ont des
des physiques de bad boy ils ont des
têtes de bad boy ils ont envie de couler
des gens dans le ciment comment ça se
passe
aucun de tout ça ils sont ils sont
évidemment rien de tout ça ils sont ils
sont évidemment à l'écoute évidemment
que bah c'est c'est une histoire qui est
peu commune. C'est quand même assez
assez spécial ce qui m'est arrivé. Euh,
ils sont plutôt à l'écoute et ils ont
des ils ont des tas de questions.
Euh,
si je compromets ta question, c'est par
rapport à aux bonnes méthodes après sur
le terrain ou comment mieux se comporter
ou partir de cette histoire pour c'est
ça ? Si je je suis dans le sens
Non, évidemment que moi je peux
témoigner ce qui m'est arrivé.
Après euh
c'est c'est bête à dire, mais quand on
on quand on couvre ce type de sujet,
quand on est dans ce genre de pays et
qu'on veut euh
aller au plus près pour amener une
information de qualité, ça peut arriver.
C'est c'est pas systématique. On peut
évidemment se essayer de se préserver de
tout, de se garder tout, mais ça peut
arriver. Ça peut arriver. Et on est on
n'est pas je connais pas de de de
détecteur inférieur de trahison. Alors
évidemment qu'il peut avoir des signaux
avec le recul. Les signaux, on les voit
quand on est dedans. Il y a des choses
qu'on voit pas. Et moi, il y avait des
signaux avec le recul. J'écris ce
bouquin, je me suis repassé de
l'histoire. Il y avait des signaux. Il y
avait des signaux. Il y a eu des deux
trois choses. J'en ai parlé d'un, on en
a parlé en préambule quand on a commencé
l'interview. Le fait que mon fixeur me
dise "Écoute Olivier, je devais venir,
c'était prévu. C'était même quelque
chose de voilà euh je ne viens plus."
Là, à ce moment-là, je peux dire bah
stop euh on s'arrête.
Bah, j'ai pas pu le dire.
Ça veut dire quoi ?
C'était quoi ? C'était euh l'excitation
du sujet, c'était tu tu confies ta
chance à ta bonne étoile. Tu as pas vu
venir le truc.
Le mec, il t'appelle Elle est
inéressante ta question. Le mec, il
t'appelle quand même, dit "Bon écoute
mec, euh vas-y hein, je suis occupé euh
mais vas-y."
Bah il le dit pas comme ça parce que là
là évidemment là c'était un arrêt comme
ça.
Mais mais pour répondre à ta question
euh
sur quoi ça tient ? On est je suis sur
place, ça doit se dérouler dans une
heure.
Et tous les mecs tous les mecs qui sont
sur place depuis 6 7 8 ans,
ils sont fleurs bleu comme toi pareil
tous.
Ah, je sais pas pour eux, je pas parler
en leur nom mais je pas parler, je sais
pas, je peux pas te dire
combien de journalistes se sont fait
kidnapper au Mali ces 10 dernières
années. Bon, journalistes occidentaux
parce que des journalistes maliens, il y
en a eu. Bah, je crois qu'il y a que moi
pour le coup. Donc, OK. Mais
tu as pris quoi comme pays un peu crado
avant ?
J'avais pas fait de pays crado avant.
J'ai pas fait de pays
Somalie.
Non, non, non, j'ai pas fait Somalie.
Moi, j'ai voyagé dans des dans des ce
que tu peux appeler des pays des pays
dit conflictuels un peu,
les pays en temps, l'Asie centrale, le
Yémen.
J'ai fait des terrains comme ça. Mais au
niveau travail,
le Yémen, combien de temps ?
Yemen, j'ai fait quoi ? J'en ai passé
pas un mois. J'ai passé un mois au
Yemen.
Mais tu avais un tour opérator, ça se
passait comment ?
Non, tour opérateur, non. Moi je voyage
en sac à dos en backpckers, je pars et
puis je rencontre les gens, je rencontre
la culture, je voyage. C'est ça. C'est
ça que j'adorais. un guide du routard
dans la poche quoi.
Euh à l'époque c'était plus le planètes
mais enfin bonus poom pas guide du
routard aussi mais euh mais voilà
c'était ça. Mais euh sur pour pour
revenir à ta question là par rapport au
euh
ce moment les signes avantcoureur euh
précurseur
Ouais. Ouais. Euh moi je suis et c'est
ça l'erreur, elle est aussi là. Je suis
obnubilé par le fait de que ça se passe
bien et que ça se fasse. Je peux pas,
j'ai pas les yeux partout. J'aurais
peut-être dû avoir les yeux partout,
mais je les ai pas partout. Je les ai
sur l'interview. Pour moi, c'est voilà,
je suis plus, si tu veux, pour te donner
un exemple. OK, il vient plus. Comment
on va se comprendre ? Comment je vais
lui faire comprendre ce ce dont je vais
lui parler ? C'est c'est ça en fait
parce que j'ai une fenêtre de tir qui
est très courte et que je suis en
confiance avec mon fixeur. Tout ça est
lié hein. On peut le dépioter après, se
dire "Mais oui mais non non non
évidemment mais sur
les mecs de la DGSE, ils t'ont pas dit
ça. Ils t'ont dit "Mon mec, tu t'es fait
emballer par un roublard, ça nous a
coûté 100 millions.
Bon 100 millions c'est rien parce que
comme ça Macron il t'a attendu sur le
tarmac de Visi Villacoublé, il a fait
quatre photos. Ça vaut bien une
couverture de Paris match.
Il faut peser le le pour et le contre sa
non ils m'ont pas dit ça mais t'ont pas
dit ça la partie avec Macron ils te
l'ont pas dit mais
non non mais c'est même pas ça c'est ils
m'ont pas dit ça déjà d'une part et
deuxièmement le roublard qui est mon
fixeur s'il faut l'appeler comme ça
quelqu'un sous pression
et quelqu'un de très fort de très bon
c'est pas
c'est quelqu'un de très fort
mais qui est très fort pour être fixeur
ou qui est très fort pour te la mettre à
l'envers.
Qui est très fort pour la mettre à
Tu es sûr de ton coup ? Ah oui oui, je
suis sûr de mon coup. Ouais ouais.
C'est quelqu'un qui
Est-ce que tu as repensé pendant ta
détention à comment il te l'avait mis à
l'envers ?
Oui oui oui exactement c'est ça. C'est
quelqu'un qui sait euh emballer euh le
mensonge dans un beau filet de vérité.
Il faut pour être un bon menteur, il
faut qu'il y ait qu'on puisse se
raccrocher à des choses véridiques. Il
sait très très bien faire ça.
Tu as donné tu as donné son adresse à
des GSE. Mais je l'ai pas son adresse
moi. Tu tu connais un peu l'Afrique ?
C'est difficile des adresses dans
certains pays africains à
côté de chez le chrétien est toujours
bon club. Voilà un peu vague. Puis je
pense qu'à la rigueur, ils ont peut-être
pas besoin de ce que je donne d'adresse
particulièrement mais voilà
tu les as senti en demande les mecs de
la DGSE. Ils sont dit [__] chouette un
mec cortiqué qui est journaliste qui a
pu faire le trombinoscope étudier leur
mode opératoire.
Chouette chouette. Bah,
est-ce qu'ils t'ont proposé d'être
honorable contributeur la prochaine fois
?
Non, mais euh dirait pas ce que tu avais
proposé.
Bah voilà, déjà mais euh
je pense que tous les hôtistes qui sont
revenus et qui ont passé du temps avec
ces gens-là sont euh voilà possèdent des
informations très intéressantes pour ces
services. Évidemment, évidemment, c'est
évident.
Tu les as senti serein sur le Mali ou
pas ? C'est ration. C'est-à-dire
euh la France, on est bien.
Non mais on n pas eu ce type de
conversation en fait. C'est c'est pas
j'ai pas puis moi j'étais pas
Tu as cherché à les cuisiner les mecs de
la dégation ?
Non mais non faut faut faut
Oh mais tu as perdu nos cas de faire un
bon pap. Mais certainement mais il faut
remettre ça dans son contexte. C'est
quelques jours après que je revienne de
2 ans dans le désert. J'ai pas envie de
cuisiner les gens. J'ai pas l'idée de
cuisiner les gens. Je suis fatigué. Je
suis déboussolé. Euh,
tu as perdu combien de kilos ? Ah
moi j'étais j'étais futé quand je suis
revenu. Combien j'ai pris ? Je sais
après mais combien j'ai faut pas je
devais faire dans les allez
avant 85
et après en quelques mois je suis
repassé à 95 à 96.
Et avant avant tu étais à combien ?
Ah bah avant j'étais plus gros Paris que
je me suis mis à faire du sport. Je
devais être dans les 92 93 avant je
pense. Ouais. Ouais. Donc ouais, on
n'est pas je suis pas je suis pas du
tout là-dedans. Moi quand je reviens, je
suis pas du tout là-dedans. Je
suis
Et maintenant par rapport à quoi ? À les
cuisiner ou je sais pas quoi ? Bah
maintenant, par rapport à ton fixeur,
quand tu t'es repassé le film, comment
il t'avait emballé, euh comment tu as
passé, il t'a volé 2 ans de ton temps,
que tu as failli caner, que tu as été
obligé de courir euh à la lumière de
même pas la lune dans la nuit avec les
serpents, les gerbilles, les scorpions,
les épines dans les pieds.
Moi, j'aurais été à ta place mec. Je
reviens en France, je me refais une
santé, je redescends là-bas, je le
découpe en morceaux le mec mais
gentiment. On va prendre son temps.
Écraser gentiment.
Non non non non non. Écraser non.
Mais pourquoi dans quel but faire ça ?
Bah dans le but tu fais pas ça à Sky
sans assumer les conséquences mon pote.
Moi je dis qu'on fait ça quand on est
suffisamment informé de ce qui s'est
passé. J'ai des pièces de puzzle
manquantes. Attendons qu'elle soit là.
Après moi c'est pas mon style de
défoncer et cetera, c'est pas trop le
truc. J'ai pas cette rancune tenace. En
fait, je sais pas si c'est pas mon
style, mais sur cette histoire là, j'ai
pas de rancune tenace. La seule chose
qu'on me doit, je pense qu'on me doit,
c'est des informations. C'est répondre à
mes questions sur les questions que je
peux avoir. Après, voilà.
Combien tu gagnes maintenant ?
Combien je gagne maintenant ? J'ai pas
Tu es dans une tu es dans une salle de
Redc, on t'a proposé de faire des J'ai
pas le travail. Je sur des projets
personnels.
Quel type ?
Quel type de projet ?
Documentaire, un projet documentaire.
Puis j'aimerais bien écrire un nouveau
livre. On m'a fait cette proposition et
j'aimerais bien sortir un nouveau livre.
Ton métier de journaliste, ça a évolué à
cause de cette expérience là ?
Je pense que oui. Euh,
pourquoi tu as fait journaliste ?
Ça c'est un métier qui m'a fait rêver
depuis que je suis gamin.
Pourquoi ?
P la télé non la télé des événements des
événements des grands événements
géopolitiques comme la suite du mur de
Berlin la suite d'héoccou des grands
journalistes comme je me souviens Morozi
je me souviens de Cyril dieu leveux je
sais pas si les gens s'en souviennent il
y avait une émission aussi enfin bon
j'avais l'impression que c'était voilà
des témoins de l'histoire des témoins
des moments clés de basculement du monde
et je me voyais bien j'ai toujours rêvé
d'être à leur place et de faire ce
qu'ils font c'est-à-dire pouvoir
témoigner de ça pouvoir aller dans des
dans des endroits où les gens ne peuvent
pas aller et rapporter pour eux enfin je
veux dire prendre de l'information pour
eux et faire comprendre ça. Ça remonte à
Ouais, je sais pas, j'avais 10 ans, 11
ans.
Après, après tu as mûri et après tu es
devenu journaliste.
Je suis revenu journaliste sur le tard
en plus pour le coup, mais c'est
toujours resté là. C'est toujours un
truc qui m'
Et maintenant quand tu te tu regardes
au-dessus de ton épaule,
ta perception du journalisme du mec qui
est là, qui plante la plume dans la
plaie, qui fait Alberlandre, la main sur
le cœur, informer le public en son âme
pour qu'il puisse prendre des décisions
en son âme et conscience
là draper dans l'étendard de la vertu et
de la niche fiscale. Bon, maintenant que
tu regardes ta profession les yeux dans
les yeux,
h
quel regard tu portes sur la profession
de journaliste ? Tu penses que les piou
piou qui pensent la même chose que toi
quand tu avais 12 13 ans et qui se
lancent en tant que journaliste, tu leur
dirais quoi ? Tu leur dirais 95 %
finissent avec une paille lancepierre où
tu seras obligé d'être d'un soumis en
autocensure par rapport à ton grand
touou de la la salle de rédaction ou si
tu décides de réellement être un vrai
journaliste, prépare-toi à t'en prendre
plein la tête physiquement,
intellectuellement, te faire neutraliser
par x ou y. Tu tu leur dirais quoi au
piou piou journalistes qui font euh la
lettre les lettres et qui font la blab
bla ? Tu leur dirais quoi ?
Je sais pas si je leur diraiis quelque
chose de pas enfin comme ça. Mais moi
c'est un métier c'est un métier passion.
Moi je pense si on a envie de le faire,
on commence piou les petits oiseaux et
puis on devient bon. Moi j'étais piou
piou et et j'ai commencé petit à petit à
devenir expérimenté. Tu es
propriétaire de ton appartement ?
Euh non.
Continue non.
Et euh donc évidemment c'est un métier
enfin surtout comme je le faisais moi en
tant que pist et cetera, c'est un
métier, il y a beaucoup de précarité
mais c'est un métier passion. On fait
pas ça.
C'est quoi beaucoup de précarité ?
Bah la pige je c'est pas combien la pige
? C'est 300 balles.
Tout dépend tout dépend du média. Mais
sur sur un article évidemment
sur libération par contre c'est combien
sur libération ? C'est je sais plus 150
170 € c'était je crois que ça baissé en
plus. Pige qui va te prendre 3 semaines.
Bah on essaie de faire en sorte que ça
prenne pas 3 semaines hein. Alors c'est
vraiment voilà mais euh mais c'est c'est
un métier formidable. C'est un métier
formidable. Mais c'est un métier
formidable. C'est un métier formidable.
Attends en France ce qu'il y a de plus
détesté c'est quoi ? C'est homme
politique, croquement et journaliste. Ah
mais l'indicateur c'est pas l'indice de
détestation, c'est ce qu'on peut faire.
Pourquoi ? Pourquoi le journaliste est
détesté d'ailleurs ?
Il avoir beaucoup beaucoup de raisons.
Il y a plein de raisons.
Vas-y. Alors s'il y a beaucoup et plein
de raisons, donne-mois en trois.
Pourquoi il les a testé ? Parce que
c'est devenu peut-être maintenant une
sorte de de de de maître à penser,
quelqu'un qui qui euh
qui donne peut-être un peu trop son
avis. Je pense qu'on on on notre boulot,
il est là. que ce soit un reportage, que
ce soit un article, que ce soit un un en
radio, en reportage audio, euh ça c'est
pour le public. Après tout ce qui vient
après, le commentaire, tout ce qu'on
aime bien beaucoup réagir parce qu'ement
plus on parle, plus on parle, plus on
donne ses goûts plus on donne ses voilà
c'est peut-être ça le problème au bout
d'un moment je pense aussi. Puis on
s'est rendu compte aussi que bah
certains journalistes pouvaient passer
de l'autre côté, enfin quand je dis de
l'autre côté, c'est
biaiser un peu l'information ou être un
peu un journaliste de commande et
cetera. biaiser un peu l'information
biaiser et un peu. C'est une
information, elle est soit vrai, soit
c'est un peu plus compliqué hein. On
peut faire des omissions.
C'est quoi des omissions ?
Bah des omissions comme son nom
l'indique, c'estàdire on a met de parler
de quelque chose. Il s'est passé ça
aussi mais on on éclaire un peu plus t
ça.
Regarde, regarde par là. Regarde par là.
C'est ça.
Moi je pense qu'il y a des il y a des
travers, il y a un peu dans tout dans
tous les métiers quoi.
Sauf que quand tu es le 4è pouvoir,
quand tu as un travers que tu es censé
être le phare dans la nuit pour la
population qui trime,
qui est exposé à des décisions
pourries de politiciens.
Toi quand tu es censé être le phare dans
la nuit en tant que journaliste, c'est
une question que je pose souvent aux
journalistes.
Mais tu mets ça haut déjà, tu mets le
phare dans la nuit, tu vois. Donc c'est
tu mets ça très haut mais dans la plie,
le phare dans la nuit.
Ouais, le phare dans la nuit quand même.
OK.
Quand tu as une population qui souffre,
que ta corporation fait de la merde,
toi en tant que journaliste quand on a
chié, qui a découvert les trucs et ainsi
de suite, tu as envie de dire quoi ?
Moi, je parle pas du fait, attention,
moi je sais pas de sac, je pars pas du
fait que la corporation est à chier.
Euh, je pars pas de ce fait là. Moi je
trouve qu'il y a des choses qui sont
superbes au niveau du journalisme. Très
très bons journalistes, il a des très
bons reportages. Ça continue.
Trois exemples.
Trois exemples de quoi ? De bons
reportages. Il faut lire la presse, faut
regarder.
Trois bons journalistes. Trois bons
journalistes.
Tu veux des noms
? Je vais pas en donner.
Pourquoi tu vas pas donner ?
Mais non, j'ai pas donné de nom.
genre juste trois trois journalistes.
Par exemple, moi quand je pense à un
journaliste
en territoire difficile, je pense à Bob
Cohen, je pense à Paul Morera, je pense
à des gars à des gars qui savent dire
mini personnel.
Mais le il y a il y a une sorte de
distinction que je sens là être un bon
la distinction que tu fais toi, je pense
c'est quoi entre le 12e arrondissement
et et Moged ? C'est ça.
Être un bon journaliste, c'est pas
forcément être parce que les
journalistes que tu cité sur le terrain
dans une zone de conflit là où c'est
dur, là où il faut tri, c'est pas ça
forcément c'est pas c'est pas enfin je
c'est pas la distinction que je fais he
c'est pas l'indicateur que la jungle
parisienne c'est sensiblement les mêmes
intrigues
mais il y a des tas de choses à dire sur
Paris faut juste bien le faire
d'accord
c'est pas le le localier qui parle de je
sais pas moi qui parle du vin qui parle
du fromage qui parle de la dernière il
informe les gens que ça intéresse là où
il se trouve pas besoin qu'il y ait des
coups de feu qui a une situation
politique un peu tendue. Ma
donne-moi trois journalistes. Trois noms
journalist.
Je donnerai pas de nom. Je sais qu'il y
en a. Il y en a beaucoup. Les gens le
savent mais je veux pas donner je veux
pas mettre. C'est pas mon style de
mettre toi toi oui toi non. Toi c'est
pas intéressant.
Je te demande pas non je te demande oui.
Oui bah justement oui. Ni oui ni
ni oui ni toi tu es journaliste toi. Non
mais il y a il y a je suis pas d'accord
sur le le grand sac. la corporation est
à chier. Enfin, c'est pas recevable et
puis c'est pas vrai.
Non, mais c'est juste c'est pas vrai.
Non, mais pour le coup, je pense
il y en a encore qui font il y en a
encore qui font correctement leur boulot
pour aller déterrer les ramorts derrière
les placards pour aller informer
correctement les gens. Je suis d'accord
avec toi.
Et la majeure partie,
c'est quoi la majeure partie ? Toi qui
dois pas chiens les chiens les merdes
sur les trottoirs, le le notes de
Fredaggou. Est-ce que ça quoi ?
On a la presse qu'on mérite, on a les
médias qu'on mérite. C'est moi je le
pense, tu vois. Donc c'est c'est bien
beau de tirer sur les journalistes, mais
en même temps, il y a des spectateurs
d'avant, il y a des lecteurs et voilà.
Et il faut pas croire que tout ça est
déconnecté. Un patron de journal c'est
très bien ce que ces lecteurs veulent
lire.
Un patron de chaîne du journal, c'est
très bien aussi.
C'est très intéressant ce que tu viens
de dire. Ce que ces lecteurs veulent
lire.
ce qui va plaire au lecteur les papers
qui vont marcher. Tu
connais le vieil adage lequel ?
On ne donne pas au public ce qu'il veut
mais ce qu'il pense.
C'est c'est le rôle d'un journaliste de
confronter l'opinion publique dans un
sens ou dans l'autre.
Oui, c'est c'est son rôle de lui donner
en tout cas des éléments d'information
pour pouvoir aiguiser son sens critique
pour pouvoir faire en sorte qu'il puisse
C'est le rôle d'un journaliste d'être
sous le robinet du pouvoir et surtout de
ne pas avoir de réflexe de Laurence.
réflexe de Laurence
de déglir.
Je sais pas, je sais pas quoi répondre à
ça. Si si tu veux pointer des dérives ou
des Il y en a maintenant après c'est la
lorniette. Quelle lorniette tu prends ?
Si ta lorniette elle regarde que ça, il
y a pas de souci. Maintenant, le scope,
il est beaucoup plus large. Moi, je
regarde le scope très large. Je regarde
pas juste "Ah oui, il a fait ça." Je
dis, il y a des mauvais boulangers, il y
a des restaurateurs. Peut-être que je
sais pas, il coupent le vin avec de la
flotte. Il y a il y a de tout partout.
Il y a du bon, il y a du mauvais chez
nous aussi. Mais quel beau métier ! Et
il y a des gens qui le font bien, il y a
pas de souci. Le boulanger s'il fait un
pain de merde,
bah personne va l'acheter.
Bah non, tu vas l'acheter. Tu vas te
rendre compte que c'est de la merde.
Le mec qui fait qui coupe son pinard
avec du des grains qui viennent de de tu
sais pas.
Le journaliste
qui peut planter des graines dans les
têtes des gens.
Hm hm.
C'est autrement plus délétaire qu'un
sagouin de boulanger.
Alors, je suis pas tout à fait d'accord
là-dessus.
On défendler un peu là. Non non mais
j'ai pas à défendre la seconde la
seconde fond de rupteur et la trè
derrière.
Je te donne mon avis euh parce que c'est
c'est un peu aussi facile. On n' jamais
eu autant d'accès à l'information
qu'aujourd'hui. Mais bien sûr le il y a
pas de journaliste qui met des graines.
C'est c'est chaque journau ça a toujours
existé. Même un journau la presse
écrite, ils ont une ligne éditoriale,
ils ont une inclinaison politique et
cetera. Maintenant, c'est aux
spectateurs dans la diversité
d'informations qu'ils ont à ne pas
rester sur un seul truc. On a maintenant
des gens qui sont abonnés à un truc
parce qu'ils aiment bien le présentateur
ou parce qu'ils aiment bien la signe.
Non, il faut une diversité mais cette
diversité, elle existe pour qui veut sur
un fait, sur un événement connaître
différent voilà connaître
qu'il y a de la diversité dans le
spectre de la presse française.
Ah oui oui oui, je trouve. Ouais.
Tu trouves qu'il y a de la diversité ?
Bah c'est il y a beaucoup de reprises.
Est-ce que tu as pas l'impression que
celui qui est un peu diverse par rapport
au stream général, soit il se fait
démonter, soit il est pas payé, soit on
lui fait comprendre que s'il va pas dans
le courant, bah il oublie de il oublie
de venir travailler dans la bonne salle
de rédaction. Tu as pas l'impression que
le stream c'est toujours dans un sens ?
Je te donne un exemple.
Covid-19,
je te donne un exemple qu'on a vécu
nous.
OK.
Covid-19
c'est une ville de Tos.
Nous, on est une chaîne de Tos. Les mecs
qui nous suivent depuis un certain
nombre d'années nous disent "Les gars,
nous on est sur place information de
première main. Donnez-nous les
consignes. On en a rien à faire du
couvre-feu et des Chinois. On parle
chinois.
On va vous ramener de l'information de
première main puisque nos débiles
mentaux de de programme sanitaire nous
colle des affiches à qui c'est
d'ailleurs venu bien venu bien après.
Nous, on a de la formation de première
main de terrain de gens qu'on connaît,
de gens qu'on a formé, qu'on a qu'on a
triangulé pour savoir s'il nous
racontait pas de la merde, qu'on a
protégé parce qu'on leur a dit
"Méfiez-vous, les Chinois, ils vont
venir chez vous, ils vont vous démonter
vos bécanes."
Donc goutte de vernis sur toutes les
vis. Méfiez-vous, mettez des trucs pour
repérer s'il y a des gens qui viennent
chez vous.
On fait remonter que l'épidémie part en
sucette, que c'est créneau son triangle
information par X médecin qu'on a à
disposition sur ce type de maladie
infectieuse. Et on continue, on
continue, on continue.
Et derrière, on a une floppée de
journalistes patentés qui viennent nous
incendier la gueule alors que les mecs
font leur portage depuis Paris. Ils ont
aucune source sur place. Ils ont pas
envoyé des mecs dans les quartiers
pauvres pour savoir comment les Chinois
ils soudaient les portes.
Si tu étais pas dans le stream, tu étais
soit un conspirationniste, soit un mec
qui cherchait à vendre de la peur, soit
un agent chinois.
Les chaînes YouTube
blacklisté, les comptes qui sautent, les
machins, les bidules, les bidules, les
bidules. Journaliste à cette époque là,
il fait quoi ? Il se mange la langue, il
va pas trianguler et puis se dit bon on
va surtout pas dire ça. Comment ça se
passe ?
Je sais pas tu elle est spécifique ton
histoire. Tu t'indiques une dérive là.
Une dérive de quoi ? Covid-19 c'est pas
loin hein.
Oui. Non mais d'accord mais bon ok c'est
cette histoire. Tu
je t'en donne d'autres des derrières.
Non non mais tu dois en avoir plein et
puis ce qui
et puis de la surtout de sources de
première main. Ah
mais très bien mais tu dois en avoir
plein. Et j'imagine qu'il y a l'autre
pendant. Il y a aussi
c'est quoi l'autre pendant ? C'est l'
contraire de ce que tu dis c'est des tr
des binous pendant la P dans le 12e
arrondissement de Paris ou d'aller au
syndicat des journalistes comment ça se
passe pas capable je suis pas capable
d'estimer s'il y a plus d'histoires
comme tu le dis je je rentre pas
là-dedans. Ce que je dis que ce que je
dis juste c'est que tout ça forme le
journalisme actuel avec ces avec tout ça
forme le journaliste actuel avec c'est
ses ses travers comme c'estes bonnes
choses. Il y a de il y a de tout. Il y a
de tout
et c'est disponible. On te force pas, on
te met pas le pistolet sur la tente pour
dire "Vas-y, lis ça."
Ouais mais on me force à payer les
impôts pour payer c'est recul critique.
Faut avoir un recul critique. Il faut
avoir une diversité de l'information.
Faut pouvoir c'est ça le le truc. Après
il y a
comment on fait pour éduquer éduquer les
populations ?
Bah peut-être que ça ça c'est un vrai
sujet et ça doit peut-être maintenant ça
devent faut ça devien une vraie
considération que ça commence au niveau
des écoles. On l' trop
c'est trop tard. C'est trop tard. Ah
écoute, c'est trop tard. En tout cas, si
on le fait maintenant, le pays est en
train de s'effondrer. On a une balance
commerciale qui est en chute libre. On a
une balance énergétique qui est en chute
libre. Du moins qu'il a toujours été,
mais on s'en foutait, on faisait de la
dette.
Euh l'argent de l'éducation nationale,
bon, c'est ce que c'est.
C'est trop tard.
Bah moi, je suis pas aussi pessimiste.
C'est pas trop tard. C'est pas trop
tard. Non, mais je vois pas comment dire
autrement. C'est Non, c'est jamais trop
tard en fait. Il faut non, moi je je
crois en ça. Si on veut, il faut
éveiller nos enfants dès maintenant
avoir un recul critique. Il faut les
faut les les habituer à l'information à
pouvoir débunker, à pouvoir Il faut
faire ça et c'est pas trop tard.
Comment tu fais pour t'informer ?
Bah comme tout le monde ?
Bah oui, je vais je vais voir les
médias. J'ai ma sélection de médias.
Lesquels ? Ah, ça va, c'est tous les
journaux à peu près, le monde,
Libération, le Point euh La Croix
beaucoup, les pages internationales, les
pages Afrique beaucoup sur internet
aussi. Après, c'est des comptes, c'est
sur les réseaux sociaux, c'est des
producteurs d'information, des
journalistes.
Qu'est-ce que tu lis en ce moment
comme livre ou
qu'est-ce que je lis en ce moment comme
livre ? J'ai fini euh il y a peu de
temps pays. Alors c'est c'est un roman
graphique cher pays de notre enfance.
Un livre de journaliste. Un roman
graphique de journaliste.
Ça commence partout sur France.
Cher pays de notre France. Ouais. De
Colomb. Excellent excellent roman
graphique sur le service d'action
civique le sac. La police politique de
Dogon là. Très intéressant.
Tu vois des parallèles avec maintenant
ou pas du tout ? Bah non, on a j'ai pas
l'impression qu'on a un service comme le
sac actuellement.
Qu'est-ce que tu donnerais comme conseil
aux écoles de journalisme ?
Alors, tu vois, ça c'est un truc, on est
très conseil, il faut toujours donner
des conseils. Je te parlais tout à
l'heure qu'on doit donner son avis,
donner son conseil, communiquer, dire ce
qu'on pense, se positionner. Moi, c'est
pas trop mon truc.
Maintenant que tu as la légitimité,
il y a pas de légitimité. Tu t'es fait
tu t'es fait coffrer pendant 2 ans dans
le désert et que tes copains à la gerby
et
ça me donnerait le droit de donner des
conseils.
Non mais c'est pas des conseils. Tu
regardez les gars, moi je suis j'ai
recruté mon physiqueur sur Facebook.
Faut éviter.
Je quelle est la question ?
Quel conseil tu donnerais au M au piou
piou du journalisme
qui veulent qui veulent devenir
journaliste
journaliste ? Ne recrutez pas votre
fixeur sur Facebook.
Non, mais ils peuvent le recruter où ils
veulent tant qu'il ramènent du bon
boulot avec ce fixeur. Qu'est-ce que
Qu'est-ce que je devrais dire ? Euh
ouais, ne recrutez pas votre fixeur sur
Facebook. Mais non, ça ça pas ça a pas
de sens. Puis c'est pas un recrutement,
c'est je je je vois une image qui
m'interpelle, je veux savoir qu'il y a
derrière et il se trouve que cette
personne est dans des zones où on ne
peut pas aller.
Tout est là. il peut m'informer sur des
zones où on ne peut pas aller.
Pourquoi tu as décidé de rester 6 7 ans,
8 ans au Mali ?
Au départ c'était 1 an et puis
et puis bon pour des pour différentes
raisons, on est resté plus longtemps.
Moi, je voulais partir au bout d'un an
puis au bout d'un moment, c'est un pays
qui est attachant, c'est un pays qui est
déroutant et puis je m'intéresse
vraiment à ce qui se passe là-bas. Il y
a enfin il y a tous les ingrédients en
tout cas quand on écrit des histoires
comme moi et qu'on est journaliste, il y
a tous les ingrédients faire des bons
papiers quoi. Etth et puis on rentre
dans le pays, on comprend de plus en
plus, on on développe plus de contact.
Donc donc on allonge aussi.
On arrive à la fin de notre entretien.
D'accord.
Est-ce que tu as trois livres à
conseiller à notre communauté ?
Bah je l'ai dit cher pays de notre
enfance. Roman
comment s'appelle ton bouquin déjà ?
Prisonnier du dessert 700 jours aux
mains d'Alqedaïda
aux éditions Robert Lafond.
Non Michel Lafond.
Michel Lafond pardon.
Combien ça coûte ?
Euh waouh 19,99
€ ou 95. Allez, redonne deux autres
bouquins.
Alors, attends euh alors des bouquins
que j'ai lu dernièrement parce que moi
je relie les bouquins en ce moment. Euh
ah oui, euh le grand jeu de Peter
Hopkirk, super bouquin. Et le dernier,
qu'est-ce que je pourrais donner ? Ah
euh
cit madame Madame Saintclaircre, Raphaël
Confiant, la reine de la père new
yorkaaise. Il y en a trois.
Est-ce que tu es un sujet que tu
aimerais aborder avec nous, qu'on a pas
abordé
sur tout ce qu'on s'est dit là ? Je
crois que tu as été assez complet. Alors
pareil, il y a des petits trucs. Mais
des petits trucs.
Non mais je trouve que le en général le
bouquin, je voulais euh ce bouquin enfin
ce bouquin amène quand même des petits
éclairages assez intéressants, je
trouvais et je je les gens
facile à lire. C'est presque du pagnol.
Du pagnol. Merci.
Côté descriptif. Alors ça ressemble pas
à notre Provence mais tu sais bien
décrire. Non non non non. Il y a pas il
y a pas de sujet particulier, mais
peut-être c'est vrai qu'il y a des des
petites des petites choses que je que
que je voilà des petits éclairages que
je donne sur ce qui a pu se passer au
Mali, des choses comme ça ou sur des
transactions et tout et euh et c'est
vrai qu'on peut on m'a très peu posé
Hop là, très peu posé. Tu me donnes mon
livre pourquoi très peu posé de question
?
Je voudrais que tu montes la la
couverture et je voudrais que tu me
lises une page.
Waouh ! Que je lise une page. OK.
N'importe laquelle.
Euh au hasard.
Prendsla, fais vers le milieu. Non, pas
le début.
OK.
Alors, toute la page et
fais-toi plaisir.
Ouais, mais une pas ça suffira si je me
fais plaisir.
Oui, vas-y.
Je suis pas un super lecteur. Alors,
c'est le chapitre cal Alassan. Et pour
la petite histoire, c'est assez marrant
parce que c'est le premier chapitre que
j'écris. J'ai du mal à écrire le premier
euh le chapitre 1 parce que c'est
l'enlèvement et Alassan, c'est par ça
que je rentre dans l'écriture de lien.
Alors la tempête de sable épuisée par sa
danse folle s'est retirée, laissant les
hommes Agars émerger lentement tel des
naufragés sur le rivage du désert. Un
calme saisissant enveloppe le camp, un
silence déconcertant après le fracas et
la violence des rafales qui nous ont
malmené toute la nuit. En sortant de
sous ma couverture, j'aperçois Marwan
qui marche vers moi d'un pas lourd se
drappant la tête avec son turbant. Il
lève le pouce vers le haut en me lançant
un regard interrogateur. J'acquè de la
main. Il me fait signe de me lever et de
le suivre. Je m'étire et lui emboitete
le pas. Le sable s'est insinué partout
dans ma gorge, sous mes dents. Il irrite
ma peau et démange mes yeux. Le chèchant
roulait en plusieurs couches autour de
mon visage n'y a rien fait. Les
poussières du désert m'ont atteint. Je
ressens néanmoins une certaine fierté.
C'est ma première tempête de sable dans
le grand erg et j'ai bien résisté. Le
turban blanc de Marwan me guide au cœur
de ce champ éparpillé sur le ciel. Les
murs meurs des tuareg au visage fatigué.
s'élève lentement dans l'air matinale.
Leur silhouette érintée et en quête de
repère se faufilent entre les pickups
garés autour des feux éteints de la
veille. Un bois naissant de cli et de de
bruit de chaîne danse dans le vent
rompant la tranquillité fragile qui
régnait.
Qu'est-ce que tu penses de
l'intelligence artificielle ?
Je pense que c'est fantastique.
Tu as écrit ce bouquin avec de
l'intelligence artificielle ? Non, j'ai
écrit le bouquin avec mes souvenirs, les
notes et euh
la reformulation a été paria,
bah elle a été aussi avec la euh la
maison d'édition.
Quel impact ça va avoir sur les
journalistes Lia ?
Hm, c'est un vaste ce sujet ça.
Gain de temps, possibilité d'écrire. Lia
peut faire des tas de choses. Euh,
tu dises quoi toi ? Elle peut pas
Perplexity,
elle peut pas par contre remplacer un
homme sur le terrain. Elle peut pas
remplacer encore les émotions. Elle peut
pas elle peut pas faire tout ça.
Elle peut vérifier si Timara c'est
Timoara ou pas
avec des erreurs ? Pour l'instant, c'est
pas parfait.
Vérifier la fiole d'entrax dans la main
de Coline Paul.
Le fera pas. Non,
non plus.
Non plus. Non non, c'est pas c'est pas
c'est pas un fail du tout. Mais mais
c'est vrai qu'elle permet de gagner du
temps. Ça peut permettre de faire des
tas de choses. Après le reportage reste
le reportage, aller au contact des gens,
parler aux gens, faire des interviews,
investiguer et cetera. Bah c'est pas
tellement, elle peut aller sur les bases
de données, elle peut prendre tout ce
qu'il y a sur le web mais elle peut pas
elle peut pas gérer l'humain, elle peut
pas faire ça encore.
Quand tu es quand tu étais à Bamaco
avant de
ta colonie de vacances de où tu mettras
une étoile euh
pas d'étoiles,
tu metteras pas pas cinq étoiles même
pas pour non
pour la cheèf bouillie avec l'odeur
dégueulasse. Même pas.
Non, même pas même pas.
Parle-moi du ciel la nuit dans le
désert. Fantastique. J'ai jamais vu un
ciel aussi euh aussi beau, aussi étoilé.
Enfin, il y a une multitude d'étoiles.
On apprend des certaines constellations
que je connaissais d'ailleurs.
Tu as vu les couleurs ?
Euh non, j'ai pas vu. Euh non, j'ai pas
vu de couleur. Des comme des horreurs
boréales, tu veux dire ? En les couleurs
dans la Voie lactée.
Euh ouais aussi un peu. Oui, mais j'ai
vu surtout une enfin une myiade
d'étoiles. Et ce qui est assez
intéressant, c'est que les étoiles
bougent aussi beaucoup là-bas. C'est pas
enfin on croit que c'est des étoiles au
départ mais l'activité du ciel en tout
cas
de satellite.
Oui enfin il y a un peu tout mais ça
bouge. Il y a pas mal de choses qui
bougent.
Est-ce que tu as pas un conseil parce
que tu veux pas donner de conseil ?
C'est pas que je veux pas donner de
conseil mais après enfin voilà on a on a
on est saturé.
Tu as
51.
C'est peut-être le moment de
transmettre.
Mais ça c'est en cours. J'ai des
enfants.
Est-ce que tu as un conseil pour les
jeunes générations ? une bouteille à la
mer, quelque chose qui restera
impérissable.
Waouh ! Tu places ça tellement.
Tu commences avec les enfants, tu crois
quoi ? Je sais pas, quelque chose qui
restera impérissable. Non, je veux pas
quelque chose qui restera impérissable.
Euh non non non, il faut il faut faut
vivre sa vie, essayer d'en faire et de
se réaliser le mieux possible. On vit
qu'une fois, faut pas l'oublier et faut
aller au bout de ce qu'on veut de ce
qu'on veut faire.
Voilà, il faut pas Ouais,
c'est valable pour moi, ça marche pour
moi. Après, est-ce que ça marche pour
les autres ? J'en sais rien. Mais mais
un temps soit peu, ouais, il faut faut
on traverse ça. Autant de traverser au
mieux avec ce qu'on veut faire et pas se
sentir forcément, même s'il y a des
contraintes, même s'il faut vivre, même
s'il faut manger et cetera. Il faut un
temps soit peu se retourner sur sa vie à
la fin et se dire qu'on que c'était
chouette, qu'on a fait ce qu'on voulait
et pas être dans les regrets. Voilà,
j'ai pas fait ça, j'ai pas vu ça, j'ai
pas vu ça. Voilà.
Ton testament maintenant.
Non. Non non non, je suis là encore
longtemps.
Vivier Dubois, merci. Merci à toi.
[Musique]